hey everyone in this week's episode
we'll talk about the most popular and
commonly used programming language
python so let's begin and learn about
the development of python and gain
insight about the current id trends but
before that make sure to subscribe to
our channel and hit the bell icon to get
notified every time we come up with new
content python is very famous for its
simple programming syntax core
readability and english like commands
that make coding a lot easier and
efficient due to this it is the most
popular and preferred language
python has interpreted high-level
general purpose programming language
developed by guido van rossum at
national research institute for
mathematics and computer science
netherlands in contrast to popular
belief that python was named after the
snake python was actually named after
the show monty python's flying circus
guido van rossum formulated python in
the late 1980s as a successor to the abc
language in 1994 python version 1.0 was
released with features like exception
handling lambda map filter and reduce
python 2.0 released in 2000 introduced
features like list comprehensions and a
garbage collection system capable of
collecting reference cycles
python 3.0 was released on the 3rd of
december 2008. undoubtedly python 2.x
and 3.x have proven to be the most used
versions
as of today python 3.7.4 is the latest
stable version released in the summer of
2019. python is popularly used for
development scripting and software
testing top id companies like google
facebook
instagram spotify and netflix among
others use python some major
applications of python can be seen in
the fields of machine learning
artificial intelligence data science and
iot python also offers many libraries
like numpy sci-fi keras tensorflow
django and flask pep 8 is the official
style guide that defines the styling
conventions for python code
a few popular open source python
projects include pip env statistics
solving the traveling salesman problem
using self-organizing maps and python to
bpm converter some of the trending
python repositories on github today
include nlp ml from scratch by torch
transformers 100 days of ml code among
others
popular websites on the internet like
reddit and quora are built using python
civilization 4 battlefield 2 sims 4 and
world of tanks are some popular games
developed using python according to
indeed the average salary of a python
developer in india is about 5 lakhs per
annum and that in the us is around 124
000 us dollars users and admirers of
python especially those considered
knowledgeable are referred to as
pythonists pythony stars and pythoners
since its inception python has come a
long way to become the most popular
coding language and continues to
revolutionize the id industry python is
a widely popular programming language
that is used for web development game
development data analysis as well as
data visualization
hi everyone
welcome to this python developer full
course by simply loan
in this session we will cover all the
important python concepts techniques and
projects that will help you become a
successful python developer our highly
experienced trainers will take you
through this live session but before i
begin make sure to subscribe to the
simply launch channel and hit the bell
icon to never miss an update
so we will start by learning the history
of python and understand the top 10
reasons to learn python
you will look at the job role of a
python developer the skills they need to
possess and how the resume of a python
developer should be
then
we'll see how to install python and the
anaconda distribution of python
then we will shift our focus towards
learning the basics of python such as
data types variables operators lists
tuples and dictionaries
next we will understand about loops and
conditional statements
after that we'll get an idea about
object oriented programming concepts
and functions in python we will also
cover some important advanced python
programming concepts such as iterators
modules generators as well as packages
finally we will see the important python
interview questions that are often asked
so let's get started let's begin and
learn about the development of python
and gain insights about the current id
trends python is very famous for its
simple programming syntax core
readability and english like commands
that make coding a lot easier and
efficient due to this it is the most
popular and preferred language
python is interpreted high level general
purpose programming language developed
by guido van rossum at national research
institute for mathematics and computer
science netherlands
in contrast to popular belief that
python was named after the snake python
was actually named after the show monty
python's flying circus
guido van rossum formulated python in
the late 1980s as a successor to the abc
language in 1994 python version 1.0 was
released with features like exception
handling lambda map filter and reduce
python 2.0 released in 2000 introduced
features like list comprehensions and a
garbage collection system capable of
collecting reference cycles
python 3.0 was released on the 3rd of
december 2008. undoubtedly python 2.x
and 3.8 have proven to be the most used
versions
as of today python 3.9.4 is the latest
stable version released in the summer of
2019. python is popularly used for
development scripting and software
testing top id companies like google
facebook instagram spotify and netflix
among others use python some major
applications of python can be seen in
the fields of machine learning
artificial intelligence data science and
iot python also offers many libraries
like numpy sci-fi keras tensorflow
django and flask pep8 is the official
style guide that defines the styling
conventions for python code
a few popular open source python
projects include fit env statistics
solving the travelling salesman problem
using self organizing maps and python to
bpm converter some of the trending
python repositories on github today
include nlp ml from scratch pytorch
transformers 100 days of ml code among
others
popular websites on the internet like
reddit and quora are built using python
civilization 4 battlefield 2 sims 4 and
world of tanks are some popular games
developed using python according to
indeed the average salary of a python
developer in india is about 5 lakhs per
annum and that in the us is around 124
000 us dollars
users and admirers of python especially
those considered knowledgeable are
referred to as pythonists pythony stars
and pythoners
since its inception python has come a
long way to become the most popular
coding language and continues to
revolutionize the iit industry so what
really is python programming language
is an object-oriented high-level
programming language that supports
built-in data structures and dynamic
semantics
it supports multiple programming
paradigms such as structured
object-oriented and functional
programming python is often described as
battery's included language because it
has a comprehensive collection of
standard libraries
python supports different modules and
packages which allows program modularity
and code reuse
python was developed by guido van rossum
and its implementation started in
december 1989.
python 1.0 version was released in the
year 1994
python 2.0 came out in october 2000
while python 3.0 was released in
december 2008.
now that you have got an understanding
of the python programming language
let's now look at the top 10 reasons why
you should learn python
so at number 10 we have ease of use
one of the most common reasons to like
python is that it is quite easy to learn
and code
it provides a simple syntax that
improves readability and makes it easier
to understand so developers can create
any desktop or machine based application
using this language
python is very versatile and is
instrumental in artificial intelligence
and machine learning
we will talk about this later in the
session
compared to java or cc plus plus it has
fewer lines of codes
in the example here we are printing a
hello world program in java
as you can see
if you have to write a program in java
you first have to declare
the class name along with its scope
next
using curly braces you need to pass the
main method along with its arguments
and then using system.out.println method
you can print hello world that's quite a
tedious task isn't it
the same task for printing hello world
can be done using just one line of code
in python as shown here
you can write the print function and
pass whatever you want to display inside
the brackets and that will print the
output
it is so simple
that is why python is considered as a
high level language and its open source
you can just download it from the
website and start using it
at nine we have active community
you need a community to learn new
technology and friends are your best
asset when it comes to learning a
programming language python has large
community support
it has an extensive and active community
to assist engineers developers analysts
and data scientists with expert support
in case of programming errors or issues
with the software
you can just go ahead and put your
queries in the community forum
the community members will address your
queries in real quick time
communities like stack overflow also
brings many python experts together to
help learners python enhancement
proposals or pep is where the proposals
and the improvements are announced
also there are a set of recommendations
or core values called the zen of python
written by tim peters that represents
the guiding principles for python
development
up next at 8 we have portable and
extensible
multiple cross language operations can
be performed effectively because python
is portable and extensible in nature
for example
if the users have a python code written
on windows and they want to execute on a
mac operating system or linux operating
system or solaris they can easily do it
without any amendment
they can also run this code on any
platform flawlessly and without any
interrupt
due to its extensibility feature you can
integrate other programming languages
such as java dot net c and c plus plus
codes with python
the components of other programming
languages can be used with python and
thus it can be used to make a cross
platform suitable application too
so it is a really good feature that
python provides
the next reason to learn python is
testing frameworks
python supports several built-in
flawless testing tools and frameworks
that help in debugging and speeding up
workflows
some of the tools and frameworks
supported by python are pi test selenium
and splinter
this is the reason for which every
tester tries to use python-based tools
and frameworks to test any application
or code or to validate it in an easier
manner
pi test is the most recommended testing
framework for functional integrational
and unit testing
you can run selenium test scripts using
python programming language to automate
various tasks and splinter is an open
source tool for testing web applications
using python
it lets you automate browser actions
such as visiting urls and interacting
with their items
at number 6 we have libraries and
packages
another reason why python has become so
popular in the industry these days is
that it has a massive collection of
libraries and packages that make your
tasks simple and easy
it has a range of libraries packages
frameworks and modules for data
manipulation statistical calculation web
development machine learning and data
science
python programmers have developed tons
of free and open source libraries that
you can use
you can find many of them via python
package index the repository of python
software python provides the default
package called pip anaconda is a third
party python ecosystem other examples
include numpy
scipy and xango
then we have scripting and automation
python is not just a programming
language it can also be used for writing
scripts for automating tasks and
workflows without human intervention
the code can be written in the form of
scripts and executed later
further it is interpreted by the machine
and checked for errors at runtime
the machine is used to read and
interpret the code
once the developer checks the code it
can further run or be used several times
without any interruption
this allows you to automate a set of
certain tasks within a program or the
same code can be used with other
applications as well
at number four
we have web development
another reason to learn python is that
it makes the web development process so
much easier
it provides a wide collection of
frameworks that make it easier for
developers to develop web applications
some of the examples are xango flask
pyramid turbo gears cherry pie etc
these frameworks are written in python
which makes the code a lot faster and
stable
the task which used to take hours in php
can be finished in minutes using python
python is also used for web scraping
django offers many elements of intricate
programs such as template design
management panel signing in signing up
signing out
url routing etc
the user establishes the framework all
these features become ready to use
flask
is a microwave framework written in
python
of all the components that are part of
this module they are all ready to
execute in the server context
pinterest and linkedin use flask
pyramid offers more attributes than
flask
it will assist users with url routing
and authentication support
turbo gears
is a highly recommended and scalable
framework that supports features such as
authentication
caching
identification management of sessions
and pluggable applications
up next at number three
we have machine learning
the growth of machine learning has been
phenomenal in the last five years and
it's rapidly changing the world around
us
python is one of the most preferred
programming languages for machine
learning because of its simple syntax
and support for several machine learning
libraries
using different libraries and functions
in python the system can learn and train
itself from past data
once the system is trained it can then
learn to adjust itself to new inputs
finally it can make predictions and
perform human-like tasks automatically
at number 2 we have data science
machine learning and data science go
hand in hand
python is robust scalable and provides
extensible visualization and graphics
options hence it is widely used in data
science
python has libraries such as numpy for
numerical computation of data
pandas for operations to manipulate data
on numerical tables and time series it
also provides simpli for symbolic
computation and scipy for technical and
scientific computations
it has another library called pi brain
which is sought for python based
reinforcement learning artificial
intelligence and neural network library
scikit-learn is a machine learning
library for creating classification
regression and clustering algorithms
and finally it provides by torch and
tensorflow for deep learning
finally coming to the most important and
the top reason to learn python which is
career opportunities and salary
python language provides a variety of
job opportunities and promises a high
growth graph with huge salary prospects
it is been used by most of the tech
giants
industry leaders using python are amazon
google facebook ibm nasa netflix and
youtube
next you can see the google trends
but i have considered three programming
languages python java and c plus i have
compared them for the past 12 months
you can see it clearly on your screens
that python has become a frontrunner in
terms of popularity and web search
volume
it means people are interested in python
they want to learn it and use it in
their work
you can also check for the youtube
search
there also you will find that python
programming language is the most
searched language on youtube
now on your screens
you can see the report of
pypl which is popularity of programming
language index it is created by
analyzing how often language tutorials
are searched on google
it is a leading indicator
the raw data comes from google trends
the bar graph depicts that python is the
most popular and widely used programming
language across the globe followed by
java then javascript and c-sharp
the popularity of programming language
index can help you decide which language
to study or which one to use in a new
software project
the next graph
shows the popularity of python and java
over the years starting from 2004
till the current period which is 2020.
worldwide python is the most popular
language
python grew the most in the last five
years by 19.4 percent and java lost the
most by minus 7.2 percent
now let's talk about the different
career opportunities and the job roles
that you can get into if you learn
python language
first
you can become a python developer
where you will be asked to write and
test codes debug programs and integrate
applications with third party web
services
second
you can become a web developer here
you will be responsible for writing
server side web application logic python
web developers usually develop back-end
components
connect the application with third-party
services and support the front-end
developers by integrating their work
with the python application
you can also become a data analyst if
you know python
as a data analyst you have to gather
data from multiple sources using scripts
analyze that data develop and implement
databases and data collection systems
you can become a data scientist
as a data scientist you need to
understand the challenges in business
and come up with the best solutions
using modern tools and techniques to
analyze visualize and build prediction
models to make business decisions
lastly you can be a machine learning
engineer where you can develop
intelligent machines that can learn from
vast volumes of data and apply knowledge
without human intervention
so there's a lot of scopes if you learn
python
now let's have a look at the salaries of
some of these job roles
so if you become a python developer you
can earn an average salary of
76526 per annum in the united states
while in india you can earn an average
of 4 lakhs 98 000 rupees per annum
also
if you learn python and become a data
scientist
you can expect an average salary of 113
000 per year in the united states while
in india you can earn an average of 10
lakhs 28 000 rupees per annum
let me now go ahead and call out the 10
reasons for learning python once again
at number 10 we had ease of use at
number 9 we had active community at 8 we
had the portable and extensible feature
of python at number seven
we saw the testing frameworks
at six we had libraries and packages
then at five we saw scripting and
automation followed by web development
then we had machine learning and data
sense at number three and number two
respectively
and finally at number one we had career
opportunities and salary
so who is a python developer
let's answer this so here are some of
the technologies used by a python
developer pandas anaconda tensorflow
python ides django web framework and
python
a python developer is one who develops
backend components of a web application
using python
when working as a web developer now the
web frameworks like django and flask are
used for this purpose
a python developer is also the one who
writes effective testable and scalable
python code he also performs data
analysis when working in the field of
data science
so basically a python developer develops
deploys debugs and maintains a project
so let's go through the skill set of a
python developer
now the core python skills that a python
developer possesses are data structures
like arrays list stack cues trees and
graphs
there's oop concepts like inheritance
classes and objects and abstraction
there's packages and functions that is
importing external packages into a
python code
database and its connection that is
connecting a python backend to a
database like mysql when it comes to
data science skills there's numpy that
is a library for performing mathematical
calculations
there's pandas that is the library for
storing and manipulating data
efficiently this scipy and then there's
matplotlib which is a library for
plotting charts and graphs for a given
data and finally there are machine
learning algorithms which consists of
models like supervised learning
unsupervised etc
now coming to web developer skills there
are frameworks like django and flask for
back-end development of web applications
and then there's web scraping which
includes taking data from websites and
converting that data into usable format
there's api handling which is basically
handling api requests for a web
application to perform server side
operations and finally there is back-end
connection which basically involves the
back-end part of a web app
usually handled by python frameworks
now moving on let's look at the python
developer job roles
first up is python web developer now a
python web developer usually writes
server-side code works on the web
frameworks like django and flask
collaborates with the data team to
gather end users requirements develops
the server-side platform deploys
applications performs tuning usability
improvement and automation
moving on next job role is data analyst
now a data analyst generally works on
python libraries including matplotlib
numpy pandas etc carry out data analysis
collect using the scripting language
explore data sets gather requirements
tune in applications analyze problems
communicate findings with the team or
stakeholders
the next job role is automation test
engineer
now an automation test engineer usually
works on python test framework tools
including pi test pi unit
perform complex system tests
troubleshoot code issues create test
scripts design the automation framework
perform a b testing
next up is machine learning engineer
now machine learning engineer has the
following roles
to perform statistical analysis of data
put machine learning models into
production
research and transform data science
prototypes
research and implement appropriate ml
algorithms and tools
perform ml tests and keep updated with
the ml trends
the last job role is software engineer
now a software engineer is expected to
write server-side code collaborate with
the design team to gather end users
requirements develop the server-side
platform deploy applications perform
tuning usability improvement and
automation
moving on to the next topic let's look
at the python developer salary trends
now software engineers with python
skills are offered better salaries
across the globe
the average salary of a python developer
in india is around 7 lakhs 55 000 rupees
per annum the average salary of a python
developer in the us is about 79 000 us
dollars per annum
moving on to our last segment python
developer resume
so let's go ahead and understand what a
python developer resume should portray
just keep a few things in mind when
you're preparing your resume
your resume should be clear updated and
concise
you should prioritize the skills
according to the job role you're
applying for
and do not write anything extra that's a
big no the recruiters are smart enough
to know that
so do not lie and do not write extra
firstly let's look at the pressure
resume so if you're refresher these are
some of the points that you need to know
first you have the resume header
now the summary is supposed to be clear
and concise
just say what exactly you want and some
of your strengths next is the profile
links and your portfolio so you can
mention your linkedin profile link and
also your github repository link if you
have
next up is the projects now clearly
depict the goal of your project so just
in case you worked on see five projects
make sure you keep it concise and crisp
next up is your education do not lie
here make sure you give a relevant
education with grades next you have the
certifications if you have any
certifications or achievements go ahead
and write them down
next you have the technical skills now
again prioritize according to the job
role and lastly you have your
non-technical skills this could be your
communication analytical skills problem
solving skills etc moving on to an
experienced developer so again mention
the resume header
then you have the summary again very
crisp and clear go ahead and mention
your portfolios and your links
coming to experience now here you have
to clearly depict your work you will
have to make sure that you write down
all your responsibilities in that
company do not go overboard and write
extra keep it very concise
again relevant education and your grades
you have technical skills the same goes
for this as well prioritize according to
the job role and finally you have your
non-technical skills now let's go over
some of the features of python and these
features are actually why it's
considered
that using python is advantageous over
using other languages so let's start
with some of these points now as we
mentioned python is very it's a very
readable program code readability is
very important it's one of the design
philosophies behind this when it was
being developed it's very easy to learn
which is why python is an entry point
for many people that are just beginning
to learn programming and as i mentioned
earlier it's a high level language in
python we since python is open source as
as i already mentioned so it gets it
benefits from all the the benefits you
get from any open source technology now
it's also portable so what this means is
that if we create a code in python and
we create in a particular system say on
windows
we don't need to make any changes if we
wanted to use the same script or that
same piece of code on some other system
say on a linux system or
a mac system python itself comes with a
very large standard library this this
facilitates us
a lot because we don't need to
create our own libraries or modules or
have to download very specific libraries
most of the problems that we do
encounter
quite commonly can already be solved by
the standard libraries that have already
been provided by the developers of
python write right from the beginning
now later later on during the course we
will encounter what is the meaning of a
data structure a data structure is
essentially a manipulation of a if of an
object of an object of data and
as as you will see later
python has one of the most user-friendly
data structures
that can be found in any language
especially compared to some of its
contemporaries now python is a
dynamically programmed language and this
is very important and what this means is
that in most compiler based languages we
there are certain processes that can
only happen during the compilation stage
so
what a dynamic programming language does
is it takes all those
compilation specific
tasks and processes and
it it does it for us as we actually type
the code so we don't need to waste time
or spend extra time to do something that
would otherwise be needed to be only
done in compilation we would have to set
up specific uh runtimes just for that
so this allows us to create our programs
and solutions much faster and allows us
to debug much easier and
yeah so it's a it's it's a very
important feature about python now
quickly i will just go over some of the
areas of python where like areas of um
or different domains where python is
very heavily implemented and the first
one the first few ones that come to mind
are like web development and
ai and machine learning so you have
technologies like django and flash that
are
built on top of python that
are used extensively for web development
when it comes to something like
artificial intelligence or machine
learning you have
distributions such as anaconda you have
pandas and many other libraries like
scipy and numpy that are used
extensively to so tackle problems in
this domain and similarly python finds
use in most of the scientific work that
goes on nowadays
because of
again some of the libraries that i have
already mentioned such as scipy
interestingly if you are into game
development or gaming in general you
would see that python
actually has certain libraries and
certain
technologies that facilitate game
development very very well one very
popular game in fif in case you are into
gaming is a world of tanks that is built
on python some of the other applications
are of course desktop be creating
desktop gui's image processing graphic
design applications and
something that is very relevant to me
and of course you as well is a creation
of education programs and training
courses there are many technologies in
the environment of python that
were almost designed for the specific
purpose of
being able to present certain concepts
or to be able to
teach certain classes and
i can't think of too many programs or
too many environments outside of python
that are better to solve these education
and training course related
problems and situations let's uh let's
get to actually installing python so now
that so i will show you how to install
python on windows since i have a windows
system uh however i will also point out
uh the way you you would have to install
python on aim on mac os or linux or even
on mobile so yeah let's get started so
to install python on your windows
computer it's as simple as going to the
website python.org and selecting the
downloads section when you do click on
downloads you get redirected to this
website that uh this web page that i'm
on
out here it by default it will ask you
if you want to download python 3.9 which
is the latest version but of course if
you for whatever reason if you needed a
particular version of python you can
download that as well
by just scrolling down and choosing the
option that you want now it's important
to note that whatever option you choose
of course i would recommend the latest
one but no matter what option you choose
i would recommend you choose a version
of python three point something because
uh previous versions of python uh namely
python 2.7 and uh and basically every
version of python two point something as
it will not receive any more maintenance
and updates uh because uh the developers
have decided that python will they are
trying to shift towards uh maintaining
and updating python three-point whatever
completely right now so yeah let's not
delay this
any further and let's download python
3.9 so once you select the option out
here
you'll be you'll get an installer all
you have to do is click on that and
it'll give you two options to customize
installation or install now i would of
course recommend just to install now
since you're a beginner do not worry
about what a custom installation is if
you have multiple drives in your system
by default the python will be downloaded
into
the drive where your windows is actually
installed your your main drive so as you
can see now that once my setup is done
it should give me a pop-up soon so my
setup is done for python and this is
essentially how you would um download
python on your windows system uh but
what if you had mac os or if you were
using linux well for mac it's a it's
actually almost as simple you just go
if you see out here below this download
button python option you get the website
asking you are you looking for python on
a different os and it gives you the
options of linux mac and even other os's
but for mac if you wanted you would just
open this tab and
just like the windows option you would
choose a version and you would choose an
installer for that version so if i
wanted to say python the latest one i
would just download this installer and i
would install in my mac system now when
it comes to linux i cannot show you
exactly how you would install it there
are certain commands that you have to
execute but essentially again if you
would just choose the linux option out
here it would take you to a page with
different installers and
essentially packages for linux systems
in specific what i would recommend to
you if you are a linux user and you need
python is to go over to the
realpythen.com website and
they have a very good
essentially instructions on how to
install python and since i don't have a
linux system i cannot directly show you
how to install python on linux so yeah
if you do have linux please head over to
this website and this should be of a lot
of help to you now
as i had mentioned you can actually
install python on your mobile devices as
well so if you were say an ios user you
would go to the ios app store and
download an app called the python is the
app for ios it essentially is like a
full-fledged
python
environment where you can develop in
python on your iphone or even ipad
and if you're an android user you could
you would go and download an app called
the pydroid3
there's a free version and a paid
version for this app and of course the
difference between the free and paid is
that the paid supports
code analysis and code prediction these
are certain details you don't have to
worry about right now and
honestly if i wouldn't worry too much
about installing python on your mobile
devices currently since i am assuming
most people would be learning
programming and programming in python on
their pcs or laptops what i had actually
shown you was installing
what is called an implementation of
python
on your system an implementation is
essentially a program or a software or
an environment that allows you to
actually work in python so what i showed
you was how to install the by default or
the most basic or reference
implementation that has been created by
the developers which is actually called
c python even though you would not you
would not have seen the word the letter
c or the prefix c
but yeah that implementation that i had
i had downloaded myself and i had shown
you to download uh is actually the c
python implementation which is python
built
on top of c the the c language
essentially uh there are other
implementations such as iron python
which uses the.net framework and j
python that uses java virtual machines
that you could use if you were
interested but again these are things
that i would not worry about too much
right now so now that we have tackled on
how to install your implementation of
python
i want to introduce
what is called a distribution to you
this distribution is called anaconda
anaconda is a very important
distribution especially if you are
looking to
use python in data science and machine
learning and ai which i am assuming is
the motivation for many of the people
that are actually watching this video
that they actually want to move into
data science and they need to learn
python as a foundation towards the
moving towards data science and if that
is your goal or in any case whatever
your goal may be i would recommend that
you install anaconda distribution now do
not get confused between anaconda and
python their anaconda is python with i
in the form of a bundle and this bundle
contains not only the basic python
implementation that i had shown you
download but it contains a lot of extra
libraries and technologies and softwares
as well so
of course this means that would you need
to download both of course not if you
download a python you do not need
anaconda to work on python and if you
have already downloaded anaconda which i
will show you how to do it in some time
if you have already downloaded anaconda
you don't need to download python
separately so i'll just speak about
anaconda little briefly so as i said
it's a distribution it it contains a
bundle
which includes the basic python
implementation and a lot of
technologies and softwares and
applications
that have essentially helped us
to use python in
in in specifically managing the big data
applications and data science related
projects so so now i will show you
actually how to install python i mean
anaconda on your system it's as simple
as it's actually as simple as
downloading just the this thing so if i
did a quick quick google of
anaconda so the website that i'm looking
for is anaconda.com and i'm looking at
products and i'm looking at individual
edition there are other editions as well
like commercial team edition these are
for companies usually or
for more professional sort of projects
so of course we are looking at the
individual edition and if you selected
this page you would be taken to
this particular web page where it will
ask you if you want to download and
again there are options depending on
which machine you're using after you're
using a linux you would choose one of
these two if you are using mac os you
would use one of these two and since i
am a windows user and i have a 64-bit
system this is the option i would use so
again it will it will first download and
install it for you and as you can see my
installer has been
downloaded so
now upon opening it it will open up this
installation thing and you can just
click next on most of these again if you
want to specify your destination folder
you can change it here mine will be with
a default folder in the c drive and you
can leave this unticked you can you can
change these options much later so
this is how you install an account on
windows and it's pretty much the same on
other systems as well now once it's done
i will show you what exactly what are
some of the things that anaconda
contains that are not there if you
uh installed python like the way i had
shown you earlier just the bare bones
python implementation so as you can see
here my installation is actually
complete
and
now i will open anaconda and i'll show
you what how you can actually use this
anaconda so if i search for anaconda in
my system i would look for something
called anaconda navigator to actually
get started with this and when i open
that it should open something like this
so this is what opens when you click on
the anaconda navigator and as you can
see
there are a bunch of applications you
don't need to worry about what these
mean uh right now uh just understand
that this this is essentially a bundle
of uh different applications and
technologies that come along with just
the normal installation of python that
you get when you install anaconda
navigator now now that we have actually
tackled
where we've seen how to install and i'm
hoping and i would recommend definitely
that everyone is watching this video
installs anaconda not just the normal
python uh installation or implementation
now that we have gotten all the
introductions and the basics and the
installations uh regarding python aside
uh let's get right let's get down to
actually creating our first script so
now the question is uh how do we
actually start doing this task of
creating our first python script how do
we
how do we realize uh now that we've
installed a python like uh now let's how
do we start doing something so
the answer to that question is that
typically when you're working on python
the one of the most basic things that
you can do is create a python script and
execute a script a script is essentially
a sequence of commands and instructions
that you give
for python to run and execute to give
you a certain result so i will show you
how you can create a python script now
there are multiple ways of creating a
python script you can create it directly
from command line which is obviously
something i would not recommend because
it is not convenient and easy and it's
not very useful for a beginner another
way is using a text editor such as the
one i have opened right now which is the
notepad plus plus
text editor now it's very important to
not get confused uh between notepad plus
plus and the standard notepad that comes
with your windows
or wordpad for that matter in fact text
editors such as
notepad and
wordpad
that you are more familiar with create
text and files in a form that is called
rich text now rich text is something
is text that
contains formatting and fonts which is
actually a hindrance when it comes to
creating actual code so what we need is
a text editor that creates or writes
text in what we call as plain text plain
text is obviously text which does not
contain these fonts and the formattings
and it only respects white spaces and
indentations those two being actually
useful towards creating code unlike
fonts and formatting which are only a
visual thing so notepad plus plus is
obviously a text editor that creates uh
plain text documents uh that is very
that was actually created with uh
programming in mind obviously you can
use a bunch of other text editors such
as wim and atom and you can google for
these there are plenty of them so uh
without any further ado let's create our
first python script so one of the most
common one of the most famous examples
of
a first program in any program for that
matter not just python is creating a
print statement that gives us a
statement saying hello world so in
python this is how you would go about or
this is the syntax you would use to
create the statement
all right
now where it is very important when you
are saving your python program that you
use the dot py prefix so if i were to
save this i can choose whatever folder i
am going to choose
yeah this folder seems fine so now i
give the file name over here as say i
want to keep it as test i need to prefix
this with dot py and this
tells
any uh sort of interpreter or anytime we
need to read the script to know that
it's a python script we need to add a
dot py otherwise it will not be treated
as a python script will be treated as
some normal document sort of a thing so
now that i have stored it as dot py
i have created my first python script
now
obviously the next question is i need to
see
what happens when i execute this line
when i run this script essentially so
to see that um there are multiple ways
the first way that i will show you is a
command line method which is obviously
again before we get into it it's not
something that i will be using to teach
you it's not something i would recommend
you to immediately start using
but for the sake of showing i will show
you how to execute a script in command
line well to do this you go since i have
installed anaconda in my system and i
will be using anaconda to
work in python what i will look for is
something called the anaconda prompt as
you can see this is the option that i
get anaconda prompt this will
essentially open you a command line
under the environment of anaconda or
python so in this
now i'm already in the folder i believe
that had my script so
how do i call this script or how do i
run the script well the command is
python space the name of my file which
was test of course the prefix is very
important so i enter test.py if you if
this was in a different folder you would
have to change your folders and command
line which is again something that i
might show you later but since my file
is already in the folder that i am in in
my command line i would just have to
enter this command right now so if i
execute this as you can see it's given
me an output of hello world which is
which is what i wanted i wanted it to
print this
these two words and of course the
command line is now waiting for the next
command for me so this is uh one of the
most simple ways of or the most
rudimentary ways of executing a python
script now another question would be
well
this isn't the most visually appealing
or
not the easy to read or easy to use way
of
executing scripts and i would agree and
that's why i'm going to introduce a
another technology or a software called
the ide so the ide in python or in any
programming language stands for
integrated development environment it's
essentially a software that not only
allows us to run scripts but it allows
us to create the scripts it allows us to
debug it allows us to see outputs it
allows us to see intermediary outputs
it allows us to do a wide variety of
tools and tasks and it comes with a
bunch of robust features to enhance our
python programming experience so let's
let's see so i will show you a an ide
called spider which comes bundled along
with the anaconda distribution that i
had mentioned earlier so if i open the
anaconda navigator
as you can see the anaconda navigator
shows me a bunch of technologies and
options and i'm looking for something
called the spider ide which is over here
as you can see here it's a scientific
python development environment
this is exactly what i'm looking for so
i am looking to launch this so now that
i've launched it you can see out here
this is what an ide looks like now this
looks very sophisticated and it's it's a
one and any almost any ide is a
wonderful
software that where you can create your
code you can debug your code you can
check the results you can make
adjustments changes and you can do a
wide variety of tasks and functions with
relation to your programming so this is
the spider id in particular and this is
how it looks don't worry about the exact
details just know that on this left hand
pane is our current script that is open
out here and out here we will get the
results in this
what we call a console console
essentially so now that we have already
created our script in notepad plus plus
and i want to open that script and i
want to see uh how and i how it would uh
the result of that script would look in
an ide so let's just open it so we can
browse for our file and as i had
named it test this is the file over here
i open this and as you can see out here
in the left hand pane
my script has opened and the command
that had given our had written is out
over here now if i want to run this
application i press this green button
and as you can see the result of my my
execution essentially is over here it's
in slightly small font but as you can
see over here
it says hello world and it's way and the
next line is essentially it's it's
waiting for me to do another execution
of the script and then it will give me
new results so let's actually give the
system new results so now that i have
printed something called hello world
let's let's change what's written over
here let's say i will perform
basic maths all right and let's actually
perform the basic maths again don't
worry about the details the syntax uh
what i'm exactly doing these are things
that we will actually cover in the
in upcoming videos and modules so let's
create a variable called a let's store a
a number three let's create a variable b
story number five all right let's get
another variable c
which will store the result of what's in
a and b in the addition of a and b all
right and let's print the result or
print what's in
this variable c or what's the result of
a plus b i will print a statement saying
the result of
the addition
of 3 and 5 is all right and i will put
my result over here
as you can see
i should get the result in this pane so
let's execute this and you can see uh
my first line is executed saying i will
perform basic maths and the next line
says the result of the addition of three
and five is eight so
this in this script what i've done is
i've performed uh two print statements
and i've performed a basic expression
some variable assignments all of these
things we will be doing later this is
what i'm what i'm essentially trying to
show you is that ideas are a very
convenient way of not only creating the
scripts but actually seeing the results
and then making adjustments as well we
can com we can create a completely new
script we don't need to create a script
from some special file or text editor i
can just create a new file here and this
is my new script essentially so i can
start working on this new script right
over here from the get go so ides are
very powerful spider ide comes bundled
with anaconda there are other ideas such
as the i idle ide it stands for
indicated development and learning
environment so the idle
ide comes
as part of the
basic python implementation that i had
shown you in the previous video where if
you just installed a basic
python
implementation it would come along with
a basic ide known as idle or integrated
development and learning environment but
of course since we are using python and
that is what i would recommend
it comes with a more robust ide called
spider
which is actually very very helpful for
scientific
and numeric applications
and was designed specifically with that
in mind
now
this is not the only way we can actually
work with python there's another very
interesting and uh a very educative
method of creating python let's say
python programs and it's something that
i will be using extensively throughout
this course to explain different
concepts so this technology is called or
the software is called uh notebooks
now before i get into the details i will
state i will just open node a basic
notebook so the notebook that comes as
part of anaconda is called the jupiter
notebook and when i open or when i
launch the jupyter notebook this is what
i get
now
a very important
feature or a
a feature of notebooks is that notebooks
uh a web browser or a web-based
application so you it's not something
that you can use if you are offline or
disconnected basically if you're
disconnected from the internet it is
something where which for which you
would need an active internet connection
however it is way more robust and it has
very very good uh properties that allow
it to be used in education or for
presentations and such so as you can see
this is my jupyter notebook these are a
bunch of folders don't need to worry
about what these are right now i will
show you how to create a fresh notebook
so if you go here now you go to new and
you select under notebook the python 3
option it will open you your first
notebook as you can see
this line is essentially waiting for me
to enter some sort of a command or a
statement that i would give in a normal
python thing now if you would have
noticed the diff in uh until now
everything that we were doing involved
us uh creating a script which was the
whole series of commands and functions
so if i go back to my spider ide as you
can see like this is a whole script and
this script contains multiple different
tasks and functions that are
individually
being performed so this is a separate
print function this is a separate
edition another separated print function
and for longer
programs or larger programs you like you
have multiple different tasks being done
and if you were using a script you can
only see the result of something like
this by executing the whole thing at
once you cannot see exactly like what is
the result of just this print statement
or just this uh it's not typically what
an ide is used for and this is where
notebooks come in super handy if i had
to break down my previous script
essentially where i first did a print
statement where i said some random thing
say hello
yeah so if i execute this particular
line you can see it gives me the result
now i want to do what is five plus three
it should give me the result over here
eight now the next
another part of your program might be
storing five and three into variables so
i can do this and i can do this so now
this line will store the variables now i
want to do the addition of what is 5
plus 3 but i want to use the variables
and i want to see what's the result as
you can see a plus b means 5 plus 3
which is 8 and i've essentially broken
down various different parts of my
previous script into
into its individual tasks and i'm able
to see what each part of that script
does and this is very good when it comes
to making presentations or trying to
teach a class so i will personally be
using notebooks a lot to explain
different different concepts of
different concepts when it comes to
python and i would recommend that you
get used to
notebooks in general because
it's an amazing way to learn python
programming or programming in general in
fact
and again as i had mentioned earlier
notebooks are something that it's an
online
application it's a web-based application
so i will have to need a active internet
connection to be able to work on a
notebook which could be a disadvantage
if you do not have a consistent internet
connection and in that case you would
probably use your ides or text editor
which you can be used offline as well in
this video we will be introduced to the
concept of variables and expressions
let's start with expressions well an
expression in python is anything that
results in a value
its difference although the difference
between an expression and a standard
statement in python is that a statement
in python is something that results in
an action or an execution of a command
there is no calculation per se or any
sort of manipulation or as i said
earlier calculation resulting in between
two different say numbers or other
objects that results in a value and this
happens in the case of an expression so
for example if i were to add two numbers
say five plus ten this is an expression
which should where two objects five and
ten are being added and a result is
being given to me which is fifteen now
let's see an example of a statement well
a statement could be something like a
print statement so when i ask python to
print something for me
it's not calculating anything it's not
evaluating anything it's simply
performing an action that i have or a
command that i have given the system
which is to print whatever i have
entered over here as you can see so this
is a statement similarly there are
another type of statement known as
assignment statements which we will
learn actually right in the next section
well let's move on to variables right
now now earlier you might have learned
about objects in python so
objects are essentially data
that we can work with or manipulate in
python now variables are a place to
store these different objects um usually
it's much easier to
store objects in python instead of using
the objects explicitly themselves
because objects may be very completely
complicated whereas variables are very
simple to use and very simply
very
unnamed in a very simple manner so that
we can use them quite often in our
programs now it's important to note that
in python we do not have to explicitly
declare or define a variable to create
them in fact variables are created in
the same statement where we assign some
object to that variable in python the
assignment of variables happens using
the assignment operator which is the
equals to sign so if i were to if i
wanted to assign a number say 100 to a
variable say b well it would be as
simple as doing this now anytime i want
to know what is stored in b i just have
to enter b and i will get the value that
is stored in it and we can store
different types of objects inside a any
variable let's say i store i want to
store this particular word in the form
of a string now this is stored in x and
if i want to know what is an x i can
just see what is here and it's a string
hello which i had stored earlier now
it's very important that we follow
certain naming rules when it comes to
naming our variables in python or else
we may be thrown errors or we might get
some problems in our program so the
first rule is that you cannot start your
variable name with a number so if i were
to give a variable name like four num is
equal to something say
the same string hello this would be an
illegal variable name and i will get an
error when i try this so if i were to
choose a num for
is equal to hello this would be
perfectly fine i won't get an error the
second rule is we are not allowed to use
any
non-alphanumeric characters except the
underscore character while naming our
variable so for example if i were to
name my variable num underscore 4 and i
say i said random some random string
this is perfectly fine however if i
change num underscore 4 to num hyphen 4
this will throw me an error as you can
see over here next the third rule is
that variable names are case sensitive
so if i have a variable called num
or say num if this was one of my
variables and i stored say the value of
50 this is not the same as me writing
num all in capitals and say storing some
other value 60 these are two different
variables so it's very important that
when you name your variables you are
aware of what case you are writing them
in because python variables are case
sensitive now the final and probably one
of the most important rules in python is
that you're not allowed to use what we
call reserve words in python now python
has a bunch of reserved words these
words essentially are performed or they
are used to perform certain special
functions and are used as identifiers
for certain special functions in python
that we that have a special purpose like
that particular word has a special
purpose within the python programming
language and we cannot use them to name
our variables so a list of them either
you can see over here some of them are
like false def if
uh d e l raise and there are like there
are around 33 of them and
sometimes some of these words are taken
out sometimes there are more words added
as python gets updated now let's let's
move on to a concept
where we try to really understand
what do we mean by storing data inside a
variable now when i say that we are
storing something inside a variable you
get an image or you get an idea in your
head that this variable is like a
container where we store or we put a
particular object inside it so does this
mean that variables have a place in the
memory are they also an object that is
placed in the memory where we can put
other objects inside of well i'll show
you an example where this idea is kind
of disproven or where i'll show you that
the idea of variable is kind of
different than what we understand by
storing something inside a variable now
let's say i'm storing the same object
i will take this object as some random
number let's say 100 and i'm going to
store it into two different variables so
i take x is equal to 100 over here
and in the next line i will store 100 in
y as well now if objects were i mean if
variables were objects that we placed in
our system then x and y should have two
different ids but let's see what happens
when i check the id of x and the id of y
they should be different in case
variables were their own objects however
as you can see the id of x and the id of
y are exactly the same so well obviously
we know that two different objects in
python cannot have the same id so does
this so what does this mean when it
comes to the nature of a variable well
the the fact is that variables are not
actually objects in python in fact
variables are more like pointers or
references to the actual object so when
i said x is equal to 100 and y is equal
to 100 what i'm actually telling the
system is that there is this variable
name called x that i want to refer or
point towards the actual object that is
in my memory called 100 and i do the
same thing with another variable y so i
am not exactly creating a different
space in my system for these variables
these variables are more like
placeholders or references that point to
a particular place in the memory where
this object is located and that is what
happens when i do id of x and id of y
it's not giving me the idea of something
called x or the id of something called y
it's giving me the id of 100 each time
because 100 is stored in x and y so as
you can see this is something like a
visual representation of what i'm trying
to say and similarly if if i were to so
in this example on the left as you can
see i've used the
value of 50 to explain my point so as
you can see initially x and y are
pointing towards this value 50 because i
have stored 50 and 50 in both x and y
now what if i changed the object that is
stored in x well that means x is now
pointing towards
this new object and i have stored this
new object called hello the string
called hello as you can see here so now
x is pointing to a new object in the
system and it's called hello and
i haven't changed anything with respect
to y so y will point towards the same
thing and i can also make the pointer of
y different or what i'm trying to say is
i can store something else in y see i
stored this list in y 50 60 100. when i
do that now y is pointing towards a
different object in python and x is also
pointing towards something else so what
happens to this object 50 well now that
there's no variable referring to this
object 50 it becomes what we call an
orphaned object and we can actually see
that when we do the id of x now let's go
back to my example on the right where i
stored x is equal to 100 so as you can
see it gives me some id represented by
this number now let's say i stored x i
stored something different in x say 200
now if i do the id of x it should give
me a different id because as you can see
the values are different and this is
because this object 200 is what is
stored in x and when i do the id of x
i'm actually getting the id of this new
object now 200. so as you can see point
as you can see variables are
they should be and they are treated more
like references or pointers
instead of containers for a particular
object in this video you will be
introduced to the concept of objects in
python now what are objects in python
well all the data that we manipulate or
use in our operations in our code are
represented as objects or relations
between objects so if you want an
example two numbers that you add in your
code well both of them are objects and
they're usually numeric type objects
similarly if you want to store someone's
name or an address of your hometown in
your code you usually store it in a form
of text and that text is also an object
usually a string similarly you might
want to create a container of different
smaller objects inside them and that big
container is also a type of an object
and one of those containers are called
lists and similarly we have many
different types of objects which we will
be covering during the duration of this
course the following pictorial
representation gives us a broad
classification of different python data
types and objects as we can see there
are five broad classifications numeric
which contains integers complex numbers
and floats we have the dictionary data
type we have the boolean which
essentially consists of objects that
have only two valid values true or false
then we have sets and we have sequence
data types such as strings lists and
tuples every object in python has three
important properties that kind of define
that particular object they are its
identity its type and its value the
identity of an object is it can be
considered as a place in the memory or
its address in the memory where an
object is stored an object's identity
does not change one once it has been
created so for example if i took an
example of
say a string called hello i can use the
id function which is this is how you use
the id function to find out the id of
this object and it should be
the answer should be in the form of a
particular long integer as you can see
the id of hello is this integer two
three two six four seven six six two
three zero two four similarly all
objects in python have an identity we
have another operation with uh regarding
the identity of an object is the is
operator and the is operator compares
the identity of two objects so if two
objects have the same identity it should
give the answer true otherwise false now
the next property of objects is the type
type of an object is essentially
what defines what kind of values and
operations
that that object can have so for example
a numeric dr type in python such as an
integer would allow us to do arithmetic
operations
and similarly string object type in
python will allow us to do concatenation
operations much like its identity the
type of an object cannot be changed as
well now let's see what's the type of
that particular object that i had shown
you above as you can see it should be
string str stands for string similarly
if i did a type for a number say 50 it
should give me int as you can see now
the third property of an object in
python is its value now the value is the
actual data that is contained in the
object it's the thing that we use that
we display that we can manipulate and
that we can perform operations on so for
example if i were to talk about this
string the string is hello so the value
of the string is the word or the
sequence of letters that spell out hello
and similarly this particular object is
a numeric object with the value of 50.
let's see in this in this pictorial
representation i have shown you that you
can assume this dash blue area as the
memory of the system now within this
memory we have objects created called 50
and hello and this list containing
smaller objects called cat pen and 40.
now what i'm trying to show you here is
each of these objects have a type an id
and a value and let's see what they are
if i wanted to see as we had already
seen the type of 50 now let's find the
id of 50. as you can see we get this
unique id for the object 50 which is
obviously not the same as the id of the
object hello above and the value of this
object is the value of 50 itself so that
was a brief introduction into objects in
python in this video we will cover the
topics of numeric object types and type
conversions in python let's get started
numeric object types in python are a
broad classification of objects plenty
of common real-life applications that we
associate with numerals such as
arithmetic operations and calculus are
done in python using numeric object data
types there are three main types of
numerals or numeric data types in python
they are integers float and complex
integers as the name suggests represent
all integer values in python these can
be such as 100 minus 3 to 305 and so on
floats are used to represent numerals
that contain decimal points such as
100.3 3.9 4.8 minus 6.8 and so on then
there is the complex object type which
is used to represent complex numbers in
python and this is an example of a
complex number 3 plus 7j
this is a complex number 3 plus 7j where
the real component is 3 and the
imaginary component is 7 all complex
numbers have a real and imaginary
component and this is how we denote them
now it's important to note that this j
is a very common symbol in maths and
engineering used to denote the imaginary
portion of a complex number
and it's the same in python as well so
moving on let's talk about type
conversion in python type conversion
refers to the conversion of an object
from one data type to another for
example from string to an integer and
there are different types of conversions
and let's go through some of them first
of all let's consider the conversion of
something to an integer and more
specifically let's consider the example
where we convert a string to an integer
so let's consider
my example string to be
some something called one four five and
i'm sewing this within a string for a
reason because i want to convert a
string to an integer so as you can see i
have stored this 145 within my within a
variable x and if i were to confirm that
is actually an integer i can use the
type function and see that it is
actually an integer str now let's
convert this into an integer using the
int function so how would we use it is
simply passing the end
sim by passing the variable that we want
to convert into the in function and as
you can see this is what i've done over
here but before this i will also store
it into another variable all right now
let's see what's in y well y gives us
one four five but are we sure that it's
an int we can just check it by using the
type function and as you can see the
type gives us
the answer end that means that we've
converted the string to an end
interestingly
we can convert something
and
also specify what base we have to treat
the number as
by default when we pass something in the
in function the program or python will
treat whatever we have passed
within the string as something in base
of decimal but what if we were to pass
something that is well not in a decimal
well we could do it like this now let's
store y
and ny let's store
let's do this and i will show you what
this means x
and i will give a comma and 8. what this
does python is well i want to convert
the string in x
into an integer but i want to treat
whatever is an x as a number of base 8
so
145 is actually 145 in the base 8. now
when we
see what's in y we get 101 which is
different to 145 because well 101 is
actually the decimal equivalent of 145
in the base 8. similarly if we were to
give it in the base 2 we would just
replace 8 with 2 over here now next
let's talk about converting something to
a float now as we know float is just
simply something that has a decimal
point so let's convert an integer into a
float how would we do that simply by
using the float function so if i give
120 and i pass this integer through the
float function i should get 120.0
these two are not the same though they
may mean the same things to us but in
for python 120 is an integer and one
120.0 is a different object which is a
float and this is how we convert
something to a float now what if we
wanted to convert an integer to a string
well we can use the str function we can
also use the hex and the oc function if
we want to convert a particular number
to a hexadecimal or an octal string
respectively let's look at all three
examples say i have a number 688 and i
want to convert this into a string i
just use the str function around this so
as we know just to confirm let's see
what the type of 688 is this is
this should be an end as we can see but
when we pass when we let's say
we convert it into a string 688 and
let's store it into some variable let's
call it a all right now let's see what's
in a it gives us 688 in the form of a
string but we can confirm
by checking the type of a it is an str
so it is a string similarly we can use
hex
if we wanted to convert an integer into
its hexadecimal equivalent in the in in
as an output of a string as you can see
this comp this sort of this sort of
complicated thing is actually telling us
that we have converted 688 in terms of
hexadecimals now how do we read this
output this 0
should not be treated as anything it's
more like an identifier which says that
the letter after this first 0 is the
base of this whole number so it's saying
that x x stands for hexadecimal so it's
saying
that 2 b 0 is to be treated as a
hexadecimal number and if you did basic
maths uh you would find that the decimal
equivalent of 2b0 is 688. similarly if i
did oct if i use the oct function for
688 it will give me the result something
like this so again how to read this the
first zero is to be treated as an
identifier and not part of the number
what it's saying is the letter after the
first or after this zero is the base of
the number following these two following
these two characters so as you can see
as you can see what's this saying is
that this whole number is an oct
represented by this letter o
and the number itself that we are
dealing with is one two six zero and one
two six zero in octal system is the
equivalent of six eight eight in the
decimal system so this is how we've
converted a an integer in uh an integer
into a hexadecimal or a an octal string
now what if we wanted to convert two uh
numeric objects into a complex data
object well for that we can use the
complex function as you can see here
if i passed complex 5 and say
say something like 3.1
let's see what this gives us as you can
see it gives us an
a complex object where
our real part is 5 and our imaginary
part is 3.1 so what this does is
essentially
you pass two numbers the first one is
the real component and the second is the
imaginary component it combines to give
you a complex number as you can see here
now let's look at some other type
conversions the next type we will be
talking about is converting something to
a tuple or a set or a list so what if i
wanted to convert a string into a tuple
i will use the tuple function and as you
can see over here so let's say i have a
string called
random let's call it random all right
now if i want to convert this to a tuple
i will use the tuple function as you can
see over here the output will give me
tuples where each individual component
of this tuple are the individual
components or the individual characters
of my string random similarly if i
wanted to convert the string to a list i
would use the
list function and this will give me a
list of the individual characters of the
word or the the string random and i
could do the same thing with the set
function to create
a set
of
individual characters of
the string random as you can see here
so yeah these were some of the basic
python
type conversions that i have shown you
as we learn about more complex data
types and different object types in
python we will learn different
type conversions and functions
associated with them in this video you
will be introduced to the concept of
strings strings are an object type in
python used to store textual data this
textual data could be something like for
example someone's name it could be an
address of a place or it could be
something like a word or a sentence now
strings in python are an object type
that is actually a subtype of a broader
classification of objects called
sequences sequences are objects in
python which contain components placed
one after the other where each component
is given what we call an index a numeric
index this numeric index identifies the
component in the sequence and its
position within the sequence now since
python is a zero index based language
the first object of any sequence is
always index zero the second is index
one the third is index two and so on now
let's move on to defining strings how do
we define them well strings are defined
using what we call delimiters and
delimiters occur in pairs an opening and
a closing delimiter in python these
delimiters are pairs of single or double
quotes so for example if i were to use
single quotes to define a string i could
i would do it like this
this is a string
as you can see this is a string is
printed over here this is delimited
using single quotes similarly if i were
to define a string using double quotes
it's as simple as doing this this is
also a
as you can see
now a valid question arises what if i
wanted to include a
single quote within my string well
if i tried to let's see what happens if
i try to print a statement with a single
quote naturally inside it so say i'm
saying it's my
birthday
all right let's see what happens if i
try to print this statement it says
invalid syntax and this is because as i
had mentioned in python single quotes
and double quotes are delimiters so they
have a special function in python and we
cannot simply just use them within a
string because python will treat them
specially for a special purpose so what
python will do is it will pair this and
this delimiter so single quotes and say
okay this looks like a string to me and
it's not going to understand the rest of
this and then it will find a random
single quote and it won't find its pair
and it will basically throw us an error
because of this so
one way or one workaround to introduce
single quotes into a string is simply to
delimit our string itself using the
other type of delimiter or double quotes
so if i want to include a single quote i
will close my string using double quotes
so if i did this instead of what i had
done earlier
this is a perfectly valid and legal way
of defining my string and i could i
would do the opposite if i had to
introduce a double quotes within my
string i would use single quotes to
close it so
if i were to write a speech statement
she said
i am
hungry all right i have i want these two
double quotes to essentially show that
this is a speech and i'm going to close
the string using single quotes and this
is a valid way of doing it as you can
see my string has these two double
quotes now i had mentioned that strings
are sequences well let's describe how
are they sequences so first of all all
sequences in python are a um it's a
essentially a sequence of smaller
objects that form the sequence right so
let's try to understand like how do how
are strings to be treated as sequences
some sequences that we will learn later
are like lists or tuples and in all
sequences
we can retrieve any particular object or
component in that sequence using its
index and how do we use indexes in
python well we enclose a numeric index
within square brackets now let's see
what i'm trying to talk about by this
example now say i'm storing a particular
string called say random within now my
variable name here is test and i'm
storing the string random within it all
right and this is a way of retrieving a
particular
index from test i write the variable
name and then next to it i put the
square brackets now i'm supposed to put
um a numeral within the square brackets
to
tell python like what a particular index
i'm looking for so let's try zero now as
i said python is 0 index based language
so the 0 index essentially means the
first part of for the first component of
a sequence so let's see what happens
when i ask python to retrieve the first
part of
what is stored in test it gives me the
string r in fact is just one character r
and it's a string so as you can see it
has given me the first character of the
string random which is r so what this
shows is that this string random is
essentially a collection or a sequence
of one character strings so this is so
random is essentially a collection of
the string r the string a the string n
and so on together combined to form the
whole string that we call random
similarly if i wanted the character at
the third position of this thing i would
use well since the third position and
since we're working in python i would
use the index 2 and it should give me
the letter n as you can see it's given
me the letter n so this is how we can
show that
strings are also sequences in python
well now let's move on to
certain string operations and functions
that we can perform well as you have
seen already that we can retrieve any
particular character within a
within a string using numeric indexes
well what if we want to know what index
is a particular character at and we can
do it like this
we use the index function so let's say
my test and i want to know where or what
position the character d is in my string
random so this is how i would use the
index function index
and within the index say i'm looking for
the character d and now i it should give
me the answer 0 1 2. it should give me
the answer 3. so if i execute this it
gives me the index 3. so this is the
index function that we can use for our
strings now what if we want to
say slice a string into a into its into
a smaller part we want to slice it and
we want to retrieve only that particular
size well here is an example say i'm
gonna i'm gonna use the same string
called random and stored in test right
so let's
so one way of so the way of doing this
is like this
now let's see what this let's just see
what this does first as you can see it's
given me a and d and if i went to my
string random a and d is this particular
slice now let's try to understand what i
have done by entering one colon 4. well
what this has done is it's retrieved a
slice
from the first position
the first index which is the character a
up until the fourth position which is
the character o but it has not included
o so it's very important when i index
like this every every time i put
something to the right of this colon i
am not including this itself all right
so it's essentially one when i say
one colon for what i'm telling python is
give me the first the second and the
third character but not the fourth one
so it's given me a n and d and it's
that's this is how we do a slicing
operation in python similarly if i were
to say slice from the first if i wanted
only the first and the second character
i would do this is what i would do
if i wanted the first and the second
character i would do one two three so
this way it says python that i want the
first i want the second but not the
third off so as you can see i get a and
n now so this is a basic slicing what if
i wanted the portion of a string from a
particular point all the way to the
right or all the way to the left well
let's consider the example of where i
want the portion of the string random
from the say fourth character until the
left well the way i would do this is
test now since i want it all the way to
the left i don't enter any index to the
left of my colon sign and since i want
everything to the left of the fourth
character i enter 4 here so as you can
see it gives me a r a and d which is
everything from the fourth character of
my string random to the left similarly
if i wanted something to the right of it
i would just do it like this i would
enter some index here and i would leave
the portion to the right of the colon
blank so this will give me everything
including the third character since this
is how we treat the
indexing in python everything including
the third character all the way to the
right so this is dom as you can see now
another perfectly valid um
slicing is say i want to slice
or take out
different characters from the string but
i want to skip certain characters like i
want this one then i want to skip one
and i want to take the next one and then
i want to skip one well in that case we
have to introduce a step
so one way of doing this is now how do
we read this so as you can see i have
written 0 colon 6 colon 2. so what this
is telling python is i want every
character from my string test
starting from the zeroth character up
until the sixth but not including the
sixth after skipping or taking two at a
time taking two time can also be assumed
as
skipping one at each step or skipping
one character at each step so what this
will do is it will go to random it will
take the zeroth one it will take r and
then it will skip the next one so it
will not consider a and then it will
pick n and then it will not consider d
and then it will consider o up until the
sixth character whichever that may
whichever that may be and if you see the
output it gives us r and o which is
exactly what we wanted we wanted r we
wanted n we wanted o where we skipped uh
a and d or we skipped the every second
character essentially so this is a way
of
slicing strings while also skipping
certain characters or skipping
characters and steps now python is also
an uh there's another interesting
technique that we can use in python to
where we can start retrieving characters
from the rightmost side of a sequence or
a string we can use negative indexes so
if i were to for example show you let's
see what this what this gives me test
what what is a minus one index it gives
me the character m now remember a string
is random so minus 1 gave us the last
character of the string random which was
m so this is a way of using negative
indexes and similarly if i used test
minus 2 it would give me the second last
character which should be the character
o as you can see here now there are some
other important functions that you may
use in python for that let's create
another let's get another string let's
call it upper
lower all right i'm storing it again in
the same variable test let's see what
happens when i use the upper function
and what happens when i use the lower
function
now i'm going to use the lower function
for this
these two functions will respectively
give out or give us the result or give
us our string in uppercase and lowercase
respectively so as you can see the upper
function created the first string in
full upper case and the second one
created this string in full lowercase
now another important and probably one
of the most important methods that we
use for strings especially when it comes
to data science is the split function so
let's see what i mean by split function
let me create another string let's call
it hello world
all right i'm going to use a split
function and i'm going to see what
happens when i
use this function essentially so what
i'm doing in these in this these three
lines is i'm creating the string hello
world i am storing it in test and then i
am using the split function on the test
and whatever result i get i'm storing
another variable called sliced and then
i'm just going to show you what is in
sliced as you can see what's happened to
the string hello world is that i have
broken it into its components or its
component words if that makes any sense
into hello and world and i've stored
both of these into what we call a list
now you might ask well how does python
know that it has to separate at a blank
space well the split function by default
will
break up a string at its blank spaces
but if we wanted we could break it up
using or add every comma so for example
if i wrote hello world using comma and
if i put a comma inside over here and
now if i try to execute this
like for example i am going to find i'm
going to look for commas in the string
and i'm going to try to split it as you
can see there's no splitting happening i
have one list with my original string
itself because it's not found a comma
what if i introduced a comma over here
now let's see what happens as you can
see the splitting has happened it's
found this comma and it's caused a split
between hello and world similarly if i
in my string if i put this comma again
and i put something else it should give
me the split over there again so we can
define our split using some whatever we
put in between these uh circle brackets
after the split function it's just
important to note that by default if in
case we do not enter anything over here
it will use blank spaces to do the
splitting
another very important operation and
very common operation in strings is what
we call concatenation so if i have two
strings first and say another string
second
and i want to join these together well
the operator i would use to do this is
called the plus symbol this is the
concatenating operator when it comes to
strings so what is the result of this
let's see let's print this out let's
print this whole thing let's see what is
the result as you can see what this has
done is it has combined the first string
first and the string second into one
string called first second so this is
the concatenated concatenation operator
now finally uh the last topic in this
lesson is the topic of escape sequences
now escape sequences are special
commands that tell python to either
suppress special meaning of some
character or symbol in a string or give
or give the special or give some special
meaning to an otherwise ordinary
character
in a string so let's look at the first
example now remember my in my for
earlier in this video
where i was i was telling you like uh
what what is the way of writing or how
do we introduce single quotes or double
quotes into a string and i told you the
trick if i want to use a single quote in
my string
i just close it using double quotes or
if i want to use a double quote i close
it using single well another way of
doing this is using what we call an
escape sequence and an escape sequence
in python is the backslash character all
right so let's see what happens when i
use the backslash character where i want
to introduce my single quote so if i use
my previous example where i wanted to
introduce a single quote and say
i'm going to close it using single
quotes
as well so i'm going to go back to my
error example so as to speak now this
would throw me an error right as you can
see it has thrown me an error so what if
i used the escape sequence that i
mentioned the escape sequence is just
backslash character now this is the
point of the string where i want my my
single quote so i introduce the
backslash now i have my single quote and
i continue writing the rest of my
statement let's close the string now
will this work as you can see this has
worked so what this has done is this
backslash character has told python
to not read this
special character or the single quote to
not treat it specially and let it be as
a part of the string so as you can see
that's what's happened here now the next
case or the other uh use case of escape
sequences is when we want to
give a particular character that is
otherwise just ordinary some special
meaning so
let's take the example of the character
t and the character n we use the
character t to introduce tab space
and use a character n to introduce what
we call line brick well let's see by an
example so
normally the character t has no special
function so the character t within a
string will just
be outputted as the characterity itself
however as you can see here i'm going to
introduce a backslash before this
character t
let's see what it does it introduces
this thing that we call a tab space
which is a larger than normal space
similarly if i were to use the uh
backslash n combination this would
introduce what we call
a line break and if you were to see the
output of this you can see at the point
of the string where i have this
combination of backslash n a line break
has occurred so
there are plenty of other escape
sequences that you may choose to learn
and
these are just two of the probably the
most common ones that are used in this
video i will give you an introduction
into lists and tuples starting off with
lists lists are a collection of ordered
orbit arbitrary objects that are similar
to what we call an array in other
programming languages but lists are way
more flexible when it comes to python
python lists are a type of sequence and
we might have you might have seen what a
sequence is when we were learning about
strings and much like in sequences or
any other sequence
list objects are assigned a numerical
index and whenever we want to uh
manipulate an object in a list we use
its respective index how do we define
lists the lists are defined using square
brackets so this is a simple way
or a simple list that i have just
created and assigned to a variable a
which contains three objects one two and
three let's talk about some of the
features of python lists python lists
are ordered and what this means is that
even if two lists contain the exact same
elements if they if the elements are
placed in a different order the two
lists are actually unique and different
and i can check that over here i have
created a list one two and three and see
if i create another list two
and one and three the same elements were
in different order i will use the is
function to check whether these two
lists are the same and if they are the
same when i use is function it should
give me the value or the answer true and
if they are not the same it should give
me the value false and as you can see i
get the value false because even though
i have two lists with the same elements
they are in different orders and so they
are different and that's what we mean by
lists are ordered the next property for
lists are that they can be manipulated
using their indexes or the elements and
the objects inside a list can be
manipulated using the indexes and we
will see that in the section where i
show you list operations the next
property is lists are mutable what this
means is that once we create a list
object we can actually make changes and
modify them without having to create a
new list object the next property is
that lists are dynamic and what this
means is that as we are making or as we
are programming we can actually make
changes to an already created list as we
are
programming without having to go through
a compilation stage so if we had to say
increase the or we had to add certain
elements to an already created list that
original list grows in size to
accommodate for these new elements the
next property is that lists can
contain any arbitrary objects so if i
created a list right now where
say if i want to store some numbers
say some floating point numbers now
and i can put strings
as well into my list all of these are
valid uh when it comes to objects that
can be put inside a list we have no such
restrictions so we can put any arbitrary
objects inside our list the final
property that i want to talk about is
that lists are
they can be nested to any arbitrary
depth what this means is that i can put
a list within a list and i can keep
nesting it essentially by putting
as many lists i want within my list and
i'm only essentially restricted by my
system's memory so if i created a list
like this
within this say i put another list and
within this list i put another list i
can keep going on to by keep going on
doing this and i'm only restricted by
the memory of my system that i'm using
so moving on let's move on and talk
about some important list operations
that we will be doing when it comes to
lists so let's create a basic list
called a where i'm storing six numbers
so now say if i wanted to retrieve a
particular element say if i want to find
out what's on the index three this is
however do it if i wanted a slice of my
original list and much like strings i do
it the same way so what this does is it
tells python that i want all the
elements of list a from index one to
index four but not including index four
so it will give me one two and three
index
objects so it should give me two three
and four in this case as you can see
here two three and four i can do the
same thing by considering elements
say two at a time if i wanted to
consider elements or consider every
second element what i would do is this
syntax i would use this syntax and when
i give this command to python what it
tells what it understands is i want
every element from a
from index 1 to index 4 but not
including index 4 but i am going to
consider 2
every second
element essentially so what it will do
is it will go here and then it will skip
one and then go here and then skip one
and that's essentially what we uh what
it's essentially what we call start
slicing by using strides so i'm taking
strides i'm not considering elements
consecutively but i'm skipping certain
elements in between if i wanted to
consider every third element i would
change this to three fourth element i
would change this to four all right so
let's see what happens when i take every
second element it should give it should
give me uh it will consider say from one
to index three right so it should
consider essentially
this section but since it's going to
skip one it's going to consider this
skip this and then consider this it
should give me two and four as you can
see it has given me two and four and
like in other
sequences we can use negative indexes as
well negative indexing essentially
starts looking from the right hand side
of the list so when i say a minus one
it's essentially looking at the last
element of the list so it gives me the
sixth or the last element which is the
which is object six if i did a minus two
it gives me the second last element
similarly another neat trick that we can
use for sequences is the following
syntax double colon and we give a minus
one what this tells the
what this tells the system is i want the
list a but with all the elements
reversed so as you can see i get my
element uh my list a but the elements
have been reversed right now let's move
on to
uh concatenation and replication well
concatenation much like in strings is
done by using the plus sign so as we
know on either side of the plus sign
should be two similar objects so if i'm
doing a plus something a being a list on
the other side it should be a list as
well so let's add a list like this
now let's see what's in a
as you can see my original list has
789 added to it and i can also add
things to the beginning of a list
similarly so if i wanted to add say
zero
you know at the beginning of a list i
just do it like this
and i get the element 0 added to it it's
very important to note that i
i actually added 0 within a list because
if i did 0 like this
it would throw me an error because like
this 0 is just an int object and it's
not a list but when i put the square
brackets i make it a list
and then this concatenation becomes
valid because a is also a list similarly
if i did a star 2 this is essentially
replication or a replication function
where i'm repeating the values in a
twice if i did a start three it's the
same function
but now i'll have the elements repeated
thrice as you can see here let's move on
to modifying list values
this also shows the mutable property of
lists that i had mentioned earlier so
let's consider this example so i created
a list with elements where there's three
strings eggs apples and carrots and i
have
five int objects one two three four and
five
now if i wanted to change say the first
element all i have to do is take the
zeroth index
and say if i want to replace eggs with
say mango this is how i would do it
now i've replaced eggs with mango if i
check what's in b
you can see the eggs have been replaced
with the element mango similarly i can
use the slice syntax to replace a
particular slice from my list with a
slice essentially so
let's look at this
i'm replacing i want to replace the
first three elements i want to replace
mango i want to replace apple and carrot
so what i will do is i will consider
this since this carrot is the second
index so i will consider zero to three
because the third is not counted now i'm
going to replace this with three
different um
let's see tv
and say sponge now let's check what's in
b you can see my three elements have
been replaced in fact i don't have to
replace like for like if i want to
replace say three elements with only one
or two elements that is also possible so
now if i want to replace the first three
elements kiwi orange and sponge
with
just one element this is how i'll do it
let's say
wine
now let's check what's here as you can
see three elements have been replaced
with one mine i can do it vice versa as
well i can replace smaller number of
elements with a larger number of
elements but here there is a slight
caveat that i want to show you so an
obvious way of doing this would be say
if i wanted to replace the first element
wind with three different elements an
obvious way would be just consider that
elements index
and then put whatever objects you want
say i want to add instead of wine i want
to add beer i want to add
ball
and
say club yeah well let's see what
happens
now if i say b check what's inside my
now you can see my elements have been
added but they seem to have been added
as is you know
i had entered a list over here and that
whole list has been replaced
or this vine has been replaced by this
whole list in the first position but
that's not exactly what i wanted i
wanted the elements within this list to
be individually placed into my list and
the way to do that is not this syntax
but actually what i'm going to show you
now if i want to replace one if i want
to replace the index or the object at
index 0 i would give this statement a
slice statement where i will give zero
colon one so when i do this and if i um
so let's create my old scenario again
where i had one
and i had one two three four and five
now if i do this b
zero but i give a slice then this slice
is essentially a single object slice
it's essentially the zeroth index again
but because of this uh formatting or
this this type of syntax that i'm using
what python will do is
now when i say
peer
and
ball
and club now what python will do is it
will not consider this whole list and
add it to in place of
wine or whatever i want to replace it
will actually consider the elements
inside of this individually and then
replace so if you see here
now if you see my list i actually have
the
i've removed wine and in place of it
i've put beer ball in club but these
three are actually individual objects
within my list and not
objects within a list that is then
placed within my original list so this
is an important caveat that you should
take note of so moving on let's talk
about certain methods associated to
lists let's take a simple list now one
two and three the first
operation that i want to show you or the
first method is the append method so
when i do a append and say if i want to
append the list by one object called 4
i just do it like this now let's see
what's in a i put so as you can see the
append has put the object 4 into my
original list now say if i wanted to
append
three different objects i want to append
five six and seven now let's see what
append function does
oh no as you can see it's done a similar
operation to what we have seen earlier
when we gave a single index or the
single element replacement
that we saw earlier it essentially put
this whole list into this particular
spot into the list and this is not what
i wanted i wanted 5 6 and 7 to be
individually placed and we do have a way
of doing that and the way to do that is
the extend function that is what i'll
show you next now if i want to extend
say the original list by three different
elements 8 9 10 when i use the extend
function it will not put this whole
thing it will consider each object
inside this thing individually and then
add it to a so if you see my result this
is exactly what i wanted now the next
method that i want to discuss is the
remove method
so the remove method is what you how you
use it is within the parenthesis you put
the
object that is present in the list that
you want to removed so you don't give an
index over here you give the object
itself so if i want the object 8 all
right this number if i want 8 itself
removed what i will do is put the value
8 here and it will remove it from my
list so if i check my list a as you can
see the value 8 has
it's gone our next another similar
function to remove is the pop function
now the pop function by default will
remove the right most value from the
list but unlike remove the pop function
actually outputs a value
and that value is what we have popped
out of the list so by default it will
pop out the right route right most value
of a list or right most element of a
list and in this case that element is 10
so it should give me 10. but of course
if we want to pop out any particular
object in this case we do not give that
particular object we give its index so
now say if i want to remove this
this list object from my bigger list
as i can see it's in index 0 1 2 3 4
it's the fourth index so if i want to
remove the list which is at the fourth
index i give the index value inside the
parenthesis and it pops that out for me
as you can see over here so this was it
for lists let's move on to tuples next
so tuples are another ordered collection
of objects much like lists but they
differ from lists in two key properties
first of all the tuples are defined
using parent thesis instead of square
brackets so this is how i would define a
tuple with elements one two and three
and the next very important property
that is different or that differentiates
tuples from lists is that tuples are
immutable and what this means is that
once we create an object of type tuple
we cannot make any modifications to it
we would have to only create a new
object if we wanted something different
and this is obviously a key difference
between a tuple and a list but apart
from this
every operation that we have done on
lists are actually
possible to do in the case of tuples as
well so any operation that we did to
lists that did not modify the list or
that does not do any modification we can
actually apply to tuples as well so if i
wanted the first element of this duple
all i have to do is call it by the index
0 it should give me the value 1 as you
can see if i wanted a slice
i can do that as well it should give me
2 and 3. and if i wanted to reverse my
tuple well i can use my same neat
technique that i've used for lists and
that i can use for the sequence i mean
strings as well so it gives me my old
tuple but with the elements reversed so
now the natural question is why do we
use tuples over lists well one important
difference is that when we con when we
make a program execution where or where
we are manipulating a tuple if we did
the same thing for the exact same
objects in uh that if it were present in
a list it would be much faster than a
tuple essentially program execution is
just faster on tuples when compared to
an identical list so use tuples over
lists when we want to be efficient while
we are creating an ordered list of
objects so whenever we create an ordered
list of objects that we don't need to or
we don't want to make any further
modifications to we don't need to create
a list we can create a tuple and another
very important area where we use tuples
over list or why we need a tuple instead
of a list is
when we are using dictionaries
dictionaries as we will see later is a
data type in python that needs an
immutable component
while we are creating the dictionary so
if we
want to use
uh something that is like a list
but since lists are mutable we can use a
tuple instead and use that when we are
creating our dictionary and we will see
like what uh what i mean by the
immutable component for a dictionary
when we actually uh learn about
dictionaries but yeah these are some of
the places where we would use a tuple
over a list uh a brief section on tuple
unpacking and packing is what i would be
doing right now and what that means is
that when i create when i give this sort
of a statement
you can assume this to be
me packing this tuple into a object or a
variable t now what's very interesting
is and this is something that's very key
to tuples is that i can unpack a tuple
onto another tuple so let me show you
what i mean by that so now that i have
packed one two three and four tuple into
t let's unpack it into another tuple
let's call this let's uh put these
elements into this tuple and i put this
into t all right now let's see what i
mean by unpacking something onto
something let's see what's uh what what
what happens when i put a if i just want
to see what's in a it actually gives me
the value one if i see what's in b it
gives me the value two if i see what's
in three giving value three and d gives
me value 4. so essentially if you think
of it what i have done is i have matched
this tuple then put it into t and then
put that tuple t into this tuple a b and
c d so what it's what what has happened
essentially is the element a has been uh
or a better way to say this would be the
element 1 has been packed onto or
unpacked onto a 2 has been unpacked onto
b 3 has been unpacked onto c 4 has been
unpacked onto d to show you what i've
done in a single line is essentially
this
this is essentially what i've done
i have assigned 1 to a 2 to b 3 to c 4
to d i have matched these two tuples
together like this and this is a very
neat feature of tuples the only only
important thing that you have to keep in
mind is the elements of this tuple and
the elements of this tuple
should be equal so if there are four
elements here there should be four
elements here all right i in fact
another very important thing about or a
neat feature is that we don't really
need to mention the parenthesis when
we're doing this
unpacking or packing so if i did x
comma y comma z if i did it like this if
i put say 5 and 6 and 7 this is also a
valid way of packing and unpacking so
now if i see what's the value in x it is
actually 5 if i see what's the value in
y it is 6. if i see what is the value of
x and z it should give me a tuple
containing 5 and 7 as you can see over
here so this is a neat feature of tuples
called packing and unpacking in this
video we will cover concepts surrounding
dictionaries dictionaries are another
type of composite data type in python
that are also a collection of objects
much like tuples and lists and like
lists they are also mutable dynamic and
can be nested however a key difference
and property of dictionaries is that
they are unordered items in dictionaries
are paired using keys unlike in lists
and tuples where the objects are
assigned numerical indexes to define a
dictionary we use curly braces each key
value pair in this dictionary in a
dictionary is separated using commas and
the key and values themselves in a pair
are separated using a colon let's look
at an example this is a dictionary where
i have three key value pairs as you can
see they have been separated by colons
and each of the pair themselves are
separated by commas and these are
enclosed in curly braces to define the
whole dictionary in this
example
these are the keys banana apple and
grape and their respective values are
yellow red and green so this is very
important that in this particular
data type we have what we call a key and
that key is assigned a value and we can
have multiple such pairings and we have
three such pairs in this particular
example another example or the or
another type of way to define a
dictionary is using the dict function
this is how we use it as you can see i
have
inputted two value or two object tuples
this is a tuple this is a tuple and this
is a tuple and when i use it in a dict
function
when i place it within a list what
python will do is it will consider the
first element of each tuple as a key
and
the second element of each tuple as its
respective value now if i check what's
in d as you can see the key banana has a
value yellow the key apple has a value
red the key grape has a value green this
is another way of defining dictionaries
an important
note over here is that
the
the objects that we use for keys have to
be of an immutable data type so we
cannot use for example lists
as an example of keys but we can use say
integers or strings for our dictionary
keys also keys have to be unique when it
comes to a dictionary you cannot have
two different keys with uh
or should i say the same key having two
different values you can have only one
key and that one key will have a unique
value assigned to it duplicate keys are
not allowed however when we speak about
values we have no such restrictions you
can have a mutable or an immutable data
type as a value in a dictionary and you
can have duplicates as well so if i
created a dictionary with a key say
banana
and if i gave if i associated with it
a value green i cannot create
another key banana and associate
a value yellow let's see what happens
when i actually do this if you actually
see
what has happened here is python has
considered the second case so it's it
first looks at the first pair it goes
okay so my dictionary has a key banana
with a value green but right after it
sees another key banana with the value
yellow so it overwrites my first key
banana with the second key and it
overwrites the first value green with
the second value and we essentially get
one key banana with the second value
yellow so obviously this is a python
does this to avoid duplicacies however
if i
created a dictionary with a key banana
again
if i created i gave it a value yellow or
say green
if i created another
key and if i gave this also a value
green this is perfectly fine and this
will not
nothing special will happen in this case
because values do not have to follow
such rules let's speak or let's see
certain dictionary operation operations
and functions now so let's uh bring back
our
original dictionary which we had created
earlier with the three pairs all right
so what if i wanted to
we can use keys to
essentially do these operations and
functions let's see what happens when we
so much like how we use sequence how we
use indexes in example of sequences we
use keys when it comes to dictionary so
let's see what happens when we use a key
over here
so we as we know banana is a key in this
dictionary let's see what happens when
we do where we give this command it
actually gives the value associated with
that key which is yellow what if we
wanted to change a particular value
associated to a particular key i would
give i would do this i would give the
key and assign it
the value that i want to change it with
all right now if i check my dictionary
you can see the key banana no more has
yellow value but the value gold what if
i wanted to add a new pair you know a
new key with a new value completely i
would do it pretty much the same same
way as i did in the previous step i
would
essentially write my new key whatever i
wanted say if i wanted a new key called
watermelon i would assign it a value
red
and now if i check my dictionary at the
end of the dictionary you will see that
my
new key pair key value pair has been
added watermelon red as you can see over
here now what if i wanted to remove if i
wanted to remove a key value pair from
my dictionary i can use the delete
function which is
called by using this the del function
now how do i do it say if i want to
remove
the key value apple in red so all i have
to do is do d e l
d and within square brackets i have to
only mention the key i don't even need
to mention the value just the key so
you can probably draw parallels in how
we use indexes when it comes to lists
and tuples and even strings and how we
use keys when it comes to dictionaries
they are quite similar so if i did this
and if i um oops i think red is actually
not a key as you can see red is a value
my
key is apple actually it's not red it's
apple as you can see now if i see my
dictionary the key apple and its value
red has been removed so these are some
of the operations that we can do
for dictionaries using keys what if we
wanted to use certain inbuilt functions
that are associated with dictionaries
well some of the examples are as follows
there is a get function when we use the
get function all we have to do is
enter a key inside the parent thesis and
it will get the value associated with
that key so if i gave the key great
let's see what value is associated with
it as you can see it's green
there is also a function called items
that returns the key and value pairs in
our dictionary as a list of two object
tuples where the first object is
the
key and the second object is a tuple so
let's see what it does as you can see it
gave me a
list and in this list the
objects inside the list are two object
tuples where the first object is always
the key and the second is the value and
it's the same for each of the tuples so
this is what items function does let's
see what
the next so the next function is keys
let's see what the keys function does as
you can see it returns a list of all the
unique keys within our list i mean
within our dictionary similarly we can
there is a function for values as well
and as you can see it returns all of the
different values that are present in our
dictionary in the form of a list also
it's important to note that if we have a
particular value that has occurred
multiple times in a dictionary it will
appear as many times it has occurred in
the dictionary or appeared in the
dictionary in our list over here when we
use the value function so if say a
particular value say i had another key
where its value was green again so i
would have the value green appear in
this list once more essentially our next
function is pop item what this does is
much like the
pop function in list
it gives us the last entered um key
value pair that is present in our
dictionary so the last centered pair was
watermelon
key watermelon with the value red and
that's what has popped out when we give
this function another important function
associated with dictionaries is the
update function and the update function
is a very neat function that is used to
merge two dictionaries together so
say if i had a dictionary let's say i'm
creating a dictionary using the dict
function where
i have say
some key called key v so as i had
mentioned i will use two object tuples
in this case and
let's say i give this also a value green
all right and another
pair would be
say mango and
let's give it a value yellow
alright so this is another dictionary
that we have created as you can see over
here we have created a dictionary with
the key called key v with value green
and another key mango with the value
yellow and i already have a dictionary d
with
these values all right
now if i want to merge these two
dictionaries i can use the update
function what i do is say if i want to
merge d with x or x with d only the
ordering will change and that doesn't
really matter when it comes to
dictionaries so if i want to merge d
with x i use d update and then inside it
i put my target dictionary now when i
check what's in d i have the
the the dictionary x and its key value
pairs
merged inside my original dictionary d
as you can see i have my original ones
here and i have the merged ones over
here so this was the update function in
this brief video i will explain what we
call the type hierarchy or the standard
type hierarchy and python it's also
known as the data model in python and it
probably has other names so essentially
in the what we do or what we speak about
in this is
how the different types that we use in
python are categorized and classified
and what are their subtypes so it's
important to note before we continue
further that there in future versions of
python there might be new types that are
introduced or the existing ones may be
modified but it's safe to say that
what i will speak about in this video
will still form the core of what we call
python standard type hierarchy so let's
begin so the first type is the nun type
uh it's accessed through the built-in
name none its truth value is false it's
essentially used to denote
functions or it's you it's returned as
the value for functions that don't
really return anything so if you have an
expression or a function that returns no
particular value you actually get a data
type called none that is how python
interprets it
then there is the ellipses ellipsis is
something that you might encounter later
it is accessed through the built-in name
ellipsis um it is used to indicate the
presence of this particular
syntax this particular symbol or
expression
or syntax in a slice its truth value is
true again don't worry too much about
ellipses right now next is numbers and
numbers is something that we are very
familiar with we have seen we work with
numbers a lot they are an immutable type
they are created through numeric
literals and they are the outputs of
arithmetic expressions and built-in
arithmetic functions its subtypes are
integers floating point numbers and
complex numbers
within integers you have plane integers
that represent numbers in the range
this number and this number so this this
number is basically the largest positive
value that you can represent using 32
bit notation in two's complement and
this is the equivalent
for the the negative the negative side
long integers on the other hand are used
to represent numbers in an unlimited
range that is only subject to the
available memory of your system so these
are two types of integers and as we know
floating point numbers represent machine
level double precision floating point
numbers or numbers with a decimal point
and a component after that complex
numbers are numbers that contain a
floating point number that represents a
real part and a floating point number
that represents a an imaginary part so
these are the types of numbers then we
have sequences sequences are finite
ordered sets indexed uh by natural
numbers so each element in a sequence
has an index and that index is a natural
number the different types of sequences
are based on the mutability whether the
objects can be changed or not is
essentially what we mean by mutability
right once we create an object whether
we can modify it or not and that is how
we differentiate different types of
sequences so there are
mutable and there are immutable types
now the different types of immutable
ones are strings we know what strings
are they are sequences that contain
characters unicode is the other
immutable sequence and then there are
tuples tuples are a collection of
arbitrary python objects and unicodes
are
sequences that contain unicode
characters then we have
mutable sequences and
there is only one currently there is
only one built-in
mutable sequence in python and that is
lists
lists are also again collection of
arbitrary python objects finally we have
well not finally but next we have
mappings and mappings are
again
sets of
objects but these objects are now
indexed using arbitrary
index sets you know the difference
between a mapping and a sequence you
could consider
sequences are ordered but mappings are
not ordered and
the indexes given to the objects in
sequences are always numbers they are
natural numbers whereas in mappings they
are not natural numbers but they are
certain arbitrary objects that we can
set for ourselves again in python there
is only one built in standard
mapping type that is the dictionary
dictionaries are
there they represent finite sets of
objects indexed by nearly arbitrary
values the only condition is that these
indexes must be of an immutable data
type so these so what i have mentioned
until now are probably the most common
data types that we encounter uh or that
we have encountered now the next types
are like callable types such as user
defined functions user-defined methods
built-in functions built-in methods
classes and class instances so again
callable types as a whole are referenced
using the call function and this is
something that we will learn when we
start learning about functions when we
learn about object oriented programming
and methods and functions and such the
other type are modules so modules are
module objects or modules essentially
are referenced or called using the
import function again modules can be
considered as these large libraries or
larger pieces of code or applications
that we
that contain various different methods
and functions and objects and classes
within them
again modules are something that we will
think about a little later files are
data types that are called using the
open function so anytime we and as we
will during the course of this tutorial
we
or during the course of this uh this
this course essentially we will be
working with a lot of files these some
of these files are text files some of
them are comma separated files so all of
these files that we open using uh the
function open or some other certain
specific functions
where we create file objects out of
these files these are what we call file
data types
finally there are internal types that
are used by python interpreter again
this is something that does not concern
us right now but just know that
the interpreter for python uses these
data types for its functioning in this
video i will show you some of the
categories of operations that are
possible in python so let's start off so
the first category of operations are
arithmetic operations and as you can see
in this table there are different types
such as addition subtraction
multiplication so let's go over them one
by one so a simple addition operation
would be like 5 plus 6 giving me the
value 11 i can do 5 minus 3 that's
subtraction similarly i can do a
multiplication using 5 say 5 into 2.
there's division where i use the
backslash so say i did division of eight
divided by two now you might encounter
another type of division which is called
the floor division where we use a double
backslash and what this does is it
returns us the largest whole number that
is lesser than the result of our
division uh so the division difference
between the float division and and the
normal floored and uh the floor division
or the single and the double backslash
is this say i did 9 divided by 2 using a
single backslash it should give me as
you can see 4.5 right so this is the
actual value now let's see what happens
when i do 9 double backslash 2. it will
give me 4 which is the largest number
lesser than or equal to 4.5 that is also
a whole number so this is what we call
flow division essentially finally we
also have
if we want to raise something to the
power of something so if i want to do
five i say six raised to the power 3 so
i would use double asterisks and this is
how i would do it give me 216 as you can
see if i wanted remainder between the
division between two different numbers i
will use the percentage sign so if i
wanted the remainder of the division
between seven and three this is how i
would do it i get the answer one as you
can see so next category of operations
are logical operations the first one is
the logical and operation where we use
the operator end all right so let's see
what we mean by this i am creating so as
we know the and operation returns the
value true if both the operands are true
so
that's actually let's actually do this
for an example let's give this variable
the value true and this the value of
false actually should be done like this
false so now uh think of it like one and
zero so one and zero is obviously 0
right so if i did a and
b i should get the answer false or 0
because i'm doing true and false so it's
like doing 1 and 0. so if you see this i
should get the answer false if i change
this to true as well now if i do this i
will get the answer true as you can see
the next logical operation is the or
operation where
well logical or is if either of the
operands are true then we should get the
answer to our order operation as true as
well so in this case obviously if i did
or over here it will naturally give us
true if i change this to false
it should again give us true and it will
only give us false if both are false as
you can see here now it's false the next
operation is the logical not uh it's
done by using the not operator so in
this case the
value that we get
is true if the operand is false so let's
take a as we know a is false over here
so if i did not a i should get the
answer true but if i change this to true
now if i do not a i should get false as
you can see so this was the
logical operations let's move on to the
next set of operations that is
comparison operations so there are a
bunch of them let's go over them one by
one if i want to check if two operands
are equal so if i did x is say equal to
2 and now y is equal to 3. if i want to
check if they are equal i will use the
double equals to sign and if
they are equal i will get the value true
if they aren't it will get value false
as you can see since x is 2 and y is 3
as you can see x and y are not the same
so there's false they are not equal if i
change this also to 2 now i will get the
answer too another the next
comparison is the x
not equal to or where we use the
exclamation sign so over here this is
this um the result of this is true if x
and y are not actually it's the same so
i should get false over here as you can
see but if i change this to say 5 now i
will get true because x is not equal to
y in this case the next one is greater
than so if i did x greater than y as we
can see 2 is not greater than 5 i will
get false over here similarly there is a
lesser than if i did x lesser than y i
should get true over here as you can see
there's also a
greater than or equal to and less than
or equal to we simply add the equal to
sign here so let's see now if i say x is
less than or equal to 3 i should get
true because x is 2 i and if i put 2
here i should also get 2 but what if i
put 1 here since x is equal to 2 and 2
is not lesser than equal to 1 this is a
false statement and i can do the same
thing with like this using the greater
than equal to now it's true because two
is actually greater than equal to one
and so this was comparison operations
the next set of operations that we can
do in python are assignment operations
if you've already seen a whole bunch
we've already been assigning values to
variables we've been doing assignments
throughout already but let's go over
them and see some of the assignment
operations so as we already know the
equal to operation is
assigning everything that is on the or
the value on the right hand side of the
equal to sign to what is on the left so
if i did a is equal to 5 plus 6 it will
assign the value of 5 plus 6 or 11 to a
let's check what's in a as you can see
it is 11. there is a plus equal to sign
and what this does is so for example if
i did
say a now since a is 11 let's create
another variable called b and call this
five all right so now if i did a plus
equal to b what this will do is it will
add b to a and then store it in a so
let's see what this does once i do this
now let's check what's in a it should be
5 plus 11 as you can see 16. so this a
plus this is this plus equal to sign is
essentially the same as doing a is equal
to a plus b it's essentially the same
thing they're both the same uh there's a
similar thing for this the negative
symbol or subtraction as well minus
equal to so now that a is 16 and b is
still 5 of course if i did minus equal
to b now i'm subtracting the value of 5
from 16 so i should get a is equal to 11
again as you can see here and this is
the equivalent of doing a minus b a is
equal to a minus b i mean as you can see
so
uh the next similar like assignment
operation let's create a is equal to say
6 in this case and say b is equal to i
will say 2 all right now if i do a star
star equal to b what this does is it
multiplies b to a and then assigns it
back to a so if i see what's in a now it
should be 12 as you can see here
similarly there is similar thing for
subtraction as well so if i added a is
equal to 6 and b is equal to 2 and if i
did a sorry for division so if i did a
division symbol and
equal to sign and then if i give b what
it will do is it will divide a by b or 6
by 2 and it will assign that back to a
so my value on a should be 3 as you can
see here 3.0 obviously this is a single
uh single backslash so this is a float
division the resultant of a single
backslash is always a float i can do the
same thing with a double backslash so
let's see if i did a is equal to seven
now and then b is equal to three now if
i did a double backslash equal to b now
it will do the same division
but uh it will do a floor function so it
should give me 2 in this case if i did
the same thing
with a single backslash just to show you
the difference between single backslash
and double backslash division in this
case it will give me
the value around 2.3 or something a
float basically 2.33 as you can see here
then there is the modulus you can use
the modulus sign as well with this
assignment um say a is equal to say 5
now b is equal to 2 now if i do a
percentage symbol equal to 2 i mean b it
should give me it will assign the uh it
will take the modulus on both sides and
then assign it to the left and operand
now let's see what's in a as you can see
it it did uh a divided by two the
modulus symbol is basically the
remainder of the division between two
objects so in this case it will divide a
by b and then give me the remainder and
then put the remainder back in a and as
you can see the remainder of 5 divided
by 2 is 1 and we get that over here
similarly we can also do exponential so
if i have a is equal to say
5 b is equal to 2 and i want to raise a
by if i wanted to raise the value of a
by the value of b and then store that
back in a this is how i would do it
so it should be 5 to the power 2 which
is 25 as you can see here so this is
assignment operations so finally we move
on to
uh two special sets of operators one is
the identity set identity operators and
the other is the membership operators
let's look at the identity operators so
when we talk about identity operators
what we when what we mean is the is and
the is not operator so what the is
operator does is it checks whether two
operands uh have the same location in
the memory essentially this does not
mean that it does not check for whether
two objects have the same value and this
is very important so let's look at this
if a is equal to 1001
and b is equal to 1000 plus one all
right if i did a is equal to this is an
equality check are they the same values
true now if i say a is b let's see what
happens as you can see it's false this
is because this object and this object
are not the same and this is what the is
operation does uh we can confirm this by
checking the id of a the id of a gives
us some value like this and the id of b
gives us as you can see a different
value so the two objects are not located
in the same place in the memory as we
have seen using the id function and that
is what we check uh through the is
operator and the is not is essentially
just the opposite of that so so that is
the identity operator now the membership
operator is used for checking whether
something is present in a sequence or
not so let's create a sequence i will
create a list to
show in this example my list is one two
and three basically simple list with
three integer objects one two and three
i will check whether
now say 2 in a so is 2 in a if it is it
will give me true as you can see is 5 in
a it should give me false because 5 is
not an a and the a not in operator is
just the opposite of that it checks the
other condition essentially so this is
the membership operators in python in
this video we will be looking at the
math module in python and we will look
at some of the math functions that are
associated with this module in python so
starting off what is this math module
well uh the python map module is an
important library or a feature that is
uh designed to deal with mathematical
operations this math module is part of
the
basic python installation so you don't
have to install this separately
to use this math module all you have to
do is import this module and this is how
you would do it you just do import
math and this will import your math
module for you to use in your
programming and in this in the course of
this video i will be showing you certain
concepts surrounding the math module
such as what are the constants that come
with the math module some of the
arithmetic functions the logarithmic
functions um power functions and even
trigonometric functions that we can do
using this math model and the function
inside the math module so starting off
let's uh look at some of the constants
that are part of this so as you can see
the standard constants are available uh
in this module are pi there is tau there
is euler's number nan which is a special
it's a it's a programming specific
concept and infinity
so let's look at this one by one so
starting off
our first constant is pi
um
pi is as you know in maths it's the
ratio of the of a circle's circumference
to its diameter and pi is an irrational
number you know the value of pi is 3.14
something since it's an irrational
number it does not we cannot define it
in terms of a specific fraction but it
can be approximated to the fraction 22
by 7. so how do we access this
pi constant is as simple as this once
you have imported maths uh the maths
module all you have to do is do match.pi
and it will give you the value as you
can see so as you can see the value
returned to us is a float this is
important to note and
the number of
number of decimal digits uh the number
of digits after the decimal point that
we can see here are 15 and this is like
a by default uh thing for python that if
you call the pi constant it will give
you the value of pi correct up to 15
decimal points so an example of where we
can use this thing is say we have the
radius of a circle three it can be in
any units three meters or whatever you
want um and you want to find out its
say circumference so as we know the
circumference of a circle is two pi r so
if i had to find the
circumference of a circle in my in my
code for some application with the
radius 3 or all i would have to do is
use the formula 2 pi r and to call the
value 2 pi r instead of specifically
writing 3.14 or something i can just use
this function math dot pi over here and
then i can enter
the r
as you can see it will return me the
radius as you can see so moving on uh
the next constant that we will talk
about is tau tau is similar to pi
in fact tau is the ratio of a circle
circumference to its radius pi is the
ratio of a circle's circumference to its
diameter and tau is the ratio of a
circle's circumference to its radius so
important to note this difference so
because of this definition tau is always
two times the value of pi this is by
definition and
much like pi if you call the tau
constant in
you from the math module it will also
return you a float number and
to find that this is the function that
we use or this is the syntax so as you
can see this is this is actually 2 times
the value of pi 6.283 and even this is
returned correct up to 15
places to the right of the decimal point
and this is by default uh next constant
is the euler's number uh the euler's
number is a it's one of the most
widespread constants used in the world
of sci uh in the scientific community in
mathematical community
you will be using the
euler's number probably a lot as a if if
you move into data science or ai or
something like that so what is the
euler's number it is
it is the
base of the natural logarithm if you
know what the natural algorithm is it is
used to calculate rates of growth or
rates of decay and as with numbers or
constants like pi and tau even the
euler's number is an irrational number
with infinite decimal places uh the
value of
the euler's number uh in short it's
denoted by the small letter e
so this value of e is are usually
approximated to around 2.718 so how do
we call this
constant is simply as math dot e
this is how we do it so you get this
value again this is also a float and
it's correct up to 15 decimal places so
the next concept that we will be talking
about is infinity now infinity is a it's
more of a mathematical concept and this
is very important to note because
infinity doesn't is not really a number
there is no number called infinity it is
it is used to define something that is
infinitely large or infinitely small so
positive infinity something that
is higher than any known number to us
and negative infinity is lower than any
known number to us um so this is the
concept of infinity and how do we call
this uh function well so let's see what
happens when we call the math function
math constant infinity so this is how we
do it and as you can see it will return
us this
it might look like a string to you but
this is actually a special type in
python um which is not a string this is
also a float it's a type of a float in
fact this uh infinity value it's it's a
it's like a special data type it's a
special data type that you can
you can consider as an equivalent to a
float but um it's not it's not a typical
float that we know like you know 3.14 or
2.71 the value of mathematics will give
us
inf and this is this inf is actually not
a
string so we can we can confirm that
over here as you can see when i do it
typed when i check the type you see it's
actually a float in fact this was
recently added in python 3.5 um a
special type known as the math dot inf
um it returns this inf data type
which is the equivalent wave float
so this is this is how we use infinity
if you wanted to get the
value of say minus infinity all you
would have to do is math dot inf with a
minus sign preceding this constant and
you will get minus iron f now let's
check if
the concepts or the properties of
infinity are
maintained you know like every a
positive infinity is greater than any
number that we know and negative
infinity is greater than any number that
we know so let's just confirm this um so
i will take math throat in and i will do
a check
is this greater than say some really
large number something that comes off
the top of my head immediately okay so
let's see if it's if this is true then
this is conceptually correct and as you
can see it is true in fact i can change
this number to anything as large as i
want this will be true because infinity
is true is larger than any number that
we know
and similarly if i did minus math dot in
inf uh and i checked some very small
number you know a very very small
negative number so just consider some
minus uh 10 to the power something right
this should also be true uh sorry it
should be a smaller sign symbol this
should also be true because i'm checking
minus infinity it's smaller than any
node number to us and it is true as you
can see so uh it's very uh also if you
did uh if you did something like so
let's say if we do
let's add something to this you know
it's a number so we should be able to do
arithmetic on this let's actually see
what happens when i add say 10 to
positive infinity it actually gives us
the same value back infinity because uh
intuitively we know that infinity plus
anything is still going to be infinity
right and this is exactly what python
does for us even if we add a number to
this the math dot inf or the infinity
constant in python it will still give us
uh the same value the same data type of
inf or infinity similarly if we
subtracted something from the negative
of max dot inf you know um say minus say
again let's say minus 100 so if we
subtract something from minus infinity
we're technically still minus infinity
itself so this will again give us my s
and
minus inf as you can see and this is
absolutely what we need and this is a
very very interesting feature in python
finally the last
constant that we will discuss is the nan
or the not a number constant so this is
not really a mathematical constant uh
there is no constant in maths called not
a number this is a computer science
related concept that
it's it's used to
is used to
denote invalid inputs or in it's used to
indicate
a certain places where say a variable
that should have a
number um it's been corrupted for
whatever reason and it it now has a text
or a symbol and our code throws an error
then in these in these cases where
python expects a number from us or from
your code and it does not get it it will
throw you a nan
value and this is usually used in cases
where you have errors in your code so
again just to check like what this this
constant i like how to call it this is
how you actually do it math.nan and it
will give you a data type called nan
also much like the infinity constant
let's see what's the type of this um
this constant again might look like a
string to you but of course this is not
a string this is a
numerical concept and as you can see
it's still a float so this is like um
it's another special uh data type that
was created for specifically this case
where uh it's some it's the equivalent
of a float but um it's not really the
typical float that we are that we
associate with so this was a constants
in the math module so our next topic
will be arithmetic functions that we can
do in the
using the math module so some of the
common arithmetic functions that are
available to us are factorials the
ceiling operation floor operation
there's permutations there's
combinations you can find the greatest
common divisor or the gcd and the lcm or
the least common multiple and you can
truncate numbers so let's look at them
one by one so starting off with the
factorial operation the factor of
operation is done using the factorial
function as you can see here actually
defined like this math dot factorial all
right so now what we pass in between the
parenthesis will be uh what we calculate
the factorial for uh as you know
factorial is so factorial is always for
a positive integer and the factorial for
say a number 10 would mean 10 times 9
times 8 times 7 so on until the number
1. obviously factors are only defined
for positive integers uh it is not
defined for uh negative values or it's
uh and it's also not defined for decimal
values so
let's see let's look at an example so as
we know um so let's say we pass
math dot factorial for six and let's see
what's the value so
this is exactly what we expect so we
expect the value of six times five times
four times three times two uh that is
actually seven twenty let's see what
happens when we pass zero
this should give us 1 since we know 0
factorial is 1. now let's see an error
case where we pass say minus 5.
as you can see this will throw us an
error because factors are not defined
for negative numbers now moving on let's
uh so the next function that we'll talk
about is the ceiling function so the
ceiling function is defined using math
dot see
seal as you see here so again we pass
the number that we want the ceiling for
in between the parenthesis so what is
the searing function it gives you the
largest uh sorry excuse me it gives you
the smallest number that is
greater than or equal to what we pass
over here so for an example if i gave
you 6.6 and i asked you okay what is the
ceiling function for 6.6 it should give
you 7 because 7 is the largest integra
in integral value that is greater than
6.6 or equal to it obviously if you give
the ceiling function for an integer it
will give you the integer itself so
let's look at an example 7.8 so this
should give me the value 8 as you can
see here let's look at another negative
number so minus 12.3 uh an integer that
is greater than minus 12.3 uh is minus
12 the smallest integer that is greater
than minus 12.3 and this should give you
12 as you can minus 12 as you can see
here
a similar function is the floor function
which is defined like this
again the floor function what it does it
gives you the greatest number that is
smaller than
whatever value we pass between the
parenthesis so if i gave it 2.3 it
should give me the value 2.
again if we pass integers
it will uh just give us the integer
itself again just to reiterate this uh
ceiling and floor functions uh they give
you int in integer values so the floor
function will give you the largest
integer that is smaller than what we
pass over here so let's look at 6.7 so
the largest integer that is smaller than
6.7 is 6 and as you can see this is our
answer over here uh the next function
that we will look at is the truncate
function
the truncate function is defined using
this truncate is very similar to what we
have seen this is how we define the
truncate function
it is very similar to the ceiling and
floor
in the truncate function what we do is
we pass a decimal value a float number
to the between between the parentheses
and what we get back is the number
without the decimal component so only
the integral component so if i gave it
7.8 for example it will give me only the
seventh part it will return me only the
seventh part and it will chop away the
0.8 part um if i give it minus 12.3 uh
it will chop away the 0.3 part and give
me only minus 12 back so let's look at
an example 8.9 it should give me only 8
as you can see here see i did minus 8
or minus six point
nine this will give me minus six so you
can think of truncate function as
it does the floor function for positive
values and it does the ceiling function
for negative values because it rounds
down and rounds up respectively for
positive and negative values so now
let's look at the next set of arithmetic
functions um let's move on to
permutations permutations are defined
using this as you know so in between the
parentheses i have to pass two values n
and k so i have to pass n n and a k the
k has to be less than or equal to n
because the permutation as you know is
uh the number of ways in which we can
permute
from n objects k tire k different
objects
so what this mathematically what this is
is
permutation of n and k is n factorial
divided by n minus k factorial so if i
pass say 10 and 6 it will give me the
permutation of 10 and 6. so let's look
at what's the value as you can see it's
a very large value
15 151 200. similarly there is a
combination function and this is a
combination the permutations are used a
lot in probability so if you're going to
move into that sphere which you will
encounter a lot in
machine learning ai you will be using
these functions quite a bit um so the
combination function again you pass an n
and a k again the n should be greater
than or equal to this k what this
evaluates is n factorial divided by n
minus k factorial times k factorial so
again this is a mathematical concept so
let's look at the permutation sorry the
combination of 10 and 6 so as you can
see it gives me 210 which is the
combination of 10 seconds in the
arithmetic function section um our gcd
and lcm as we know gcd is the greatest
common divisor lcm is least common
multiple so as of the newest version of
python in three point python 3.9 the
math module gets these two new functions
that were very lately added actually um
since i i cannot show you that because i
don't have the absolute latest version
of python on my system but using the
math dot gcd function this is the
function and in between this we would
what we would do if we had the latest
version is we would pass two numbers or
as many numbers in fact and what this
function would do is find the common
divisor amongst them so if i gave these
say for example if i gave these numbers
it would give me the value 10. similarly
the lcm function again added in the
python 3.9 finds the common multiple
amongst
whatever we pass over here so if i
passed say 20 and 30 this will give me
uh the value of 60 which is the lcm of
20 and 30. so again these are uh it's uh
something neat that if you say you have
python 3.9 or
if you have python 3.9 or after that
you will have access to these functions
as well if you when you import the math
module so that was for the arithmetic uh
functions let's move on to the next
section which are power and log
logarithmic functions so let's start off
with the power function um there are two
there are uh multiple ways you know you
can actually do a power function in math
in python so you can do something like
this which is the equivalent of 2 to the
power 3 or you can use the inbuilt
module math and you can use the
pow or the power function which is this
is how you do it and if i had to do same
2 to the power 3 i would just pass 2 and
3 as arguments like this and it should
give me the value as you can see 8 over
here what if
so there's actually one more function
which is simply the pow function and
this is
not part of the math module it's a
function not part of the math model but
it's still part of the
base python you use this as well and you
can do the same thing vow 2 and 3 it
should give you the value 8 again the
you know you might ask what's the
difference between these two functions
well it's not much for at least in a
beginner's standpoint it's not that much
uh just note that the math dot
power function is slightly
computationally faster than the simple
power function so yeah moving on the
next topic would be the next function
that we'll discuss is the exponential
function which is defined like this
again exponential function is again e to
the power something so if i did
exponential of 3
this would give me e to the power 3. as
you can see oh of course i did not
define the module beforehand so math.exp
now when i do this it should it will
give me some value which is basically
euler's number or e to the power 3. so
this was the exponential function and
let's look at an example so we will look
at the example of rate of dk and we will
use the uh this function in that example
so the exponential rate of decay
for
is used to calculate the amount of
radioactive elements that is present in
a substance after a certain amount of
time so the the
the the the expression is uh something
like the initial amount of radioactive
elements that were present
right at the beginning times the
exponent of minus 693 times t
t for time divided by the time period
the half lifetime
so let's just write it down to make it
simple so again as you can see
the uh so this will give me the
remaining amount of radioactive elements
right so let's uh let's write down
remaining let's assign this to a
variable remaining so the initial again
um initial is the initial amount of
radioactive elements so let's give it
some value say 100 um the time let's
assume it's 10 years
and let's say the half-life
half-life
is
around i don't know let's give some
value say 3 or something again this is
the details are not important so this
will uh i'm using the math dot
exponential function over here as you
can see and for these values uh now when
i check what's the value of remaining
after i calculate it it's something
so this is it's basically what this
tells me is that i started off with 100
units of some radioactive element
and in 10 years this is what is left so
yeah so this is how we would use say the
exponential functions in a particular
example of ours so next the next
type of again
functions are logarithmic functions so
let's look at some of the logarithmic
functions that are part of the math
module so basic log function would be
written like this math.log in between
this i would pass the number that i want
the log for by default if i just pass
one number it will it will calculate the
log of 8 to the base of e as we know e
is the euler's number so let's see what
it does in this case it gives me some
value what if i wanted to specify a
particular base well i would pass a
secure argument in this case i want to
find the log of 8 to the base 2 this
should be the value 3 as you can see
over here
there are two specific functions that
are also provided in this math module
that is log2 uh what this will do is
again it will again have to just pass
one argument and this will automatically
find the value of the log of 8 to the
base 2 as you can see here
similarly there is a math dot log 10
function if i give if i did this i will
find the value of
something here to the base 10 as you can
see so this was logarithmic functions
then you have the finally you have the
square root function so how would we use
the math uh the square root function is
math dot sqrt
again we pass the what we want over here
if we want the square root of say
49 this should give me the value 7 as
you can see finally we move on to the
final set of functions that we can do
using this math module they are
trigonometric functions and they are
hyperbolic functions so
uh let's start off with some of the
trigonometric functions as we know
we can do sine we can do cosine and tan
uh some of the basic functions
the way we would do it is math dot sign
in between this what we this is to
calculate the sign of a particular
angle and this angle must be passed in
radians this is very important to note
we do not pass it in degrees but in
radians so if i say past
sine of
3.14 as we know 3.14 is an approximation
of the value pi uh my sine pi is uh
supposed to be uh in fact it's supposed
to be zero so let's see we get something
close to zero again since this is an
approximation it won't give us the exact
value uh similarly we can use math dot
cos to find the value of a particular
angle um if you want to find
if you want to find the value of the uh
sorry the cost of a particular angle we
can use the tan function in case
we wanted to find the tan similarly uh
we have the next set for arc sine and
the arc cosines of
the certain of angles so to use to find
the arc sine for example we would use a
dot sine i mean sorry a sine uh for r
cosine we would use this and for r10 we
would use this the next set would be
hyperbolic functions again hyperbolic
functions are
basically the sine and the cosine and
the time calculated not circles but on
hyperbolas
again the details don't have to be you
don't have to know the details you just
should
you should know that if you wanted to
say for example find out the uh
hyperbolic sign of an a of an angle we
would use math dot
sine h
and we would pass what we wanted between
this similarly if we wanted to find the
cosine it would be cos h uh tan it would
be tan h and if we wanted to find the
inverse
of
the hyperbolic inverse what we would do
is what we would do is use a so we would
use a tan h if we wanted to find the
hyperbolic inverse
of sine we would use a sine h and
similarly for cos it would be cos
a cos h in this video we will learn
about conditional statements
and we will learn about how do we create
these control structures
where we have these conditional
statements uh we will learn about the
keywords that we use in python to create
a conditional statement block the if
keyword the lf keyword and the else
keyword we will also learn about
indentation and its importance in python
so let's get started so the basic uh
syntax if you will for a if statement in
python consists of the keyword if
followed by an expression as you can see
from this
pictorial if if there's an if statement
there is a expression
there is this block of code which if you
can actually see is slightly indented to
the rest of the code
and then we have the rest of the rest of
our code after that so what we're
looking at is this so this is our if
statement block
now let's let's break this down so what
is this expression that we are speaking
of uh an expression in this context is a
boolean expression which evaluates to a
true or false statement so when we are
speaking about the if statement we have
an expression and if this expression
evaluates to true then we execute
everything below the if statement
otherwise we skip that portion as you
can see if the statement is true we
execute this statement or these
statement blocks
otherwise if it's false we move on to
the next the next statement block or the
beginning of a new statement so let's
look at an example to further understand
this let's take this if statement over
here as you can see in this if statement
i have this expression 50 greater than
30 so what python is going to do now is
it's going to check whether 50 is
greater than 30 and it's going to check
in a boolean context if this is true
then we can move on to the next portion
which is this but if it is false then we
will skip this so let's see what this
what happens over here so since we know
that 50 is indeed greater than 30 this
is a true expression we move on to this
block of code which is saying that print
50 is indeed a larger number than 30. so
let's see if this actually gets printed
so as you can see we get this uh the
result which is this is a true statement
and we get our print statement getting
executed what if we give a false
expression over here so let's look at
what happens if i gave a false
expression now i'm checking if 50 is
less than 30 which is a false statement
so if it's a false statement we do not
move on to this portion of our if
statement block and we we directly in
fact we directly skip so if i have to
execute this you will see nothing gets
executed in fact my print statement is
just not executed because we never
entered this because our expression over
here was indeed false so yeah this is
how a basic if statement block looks
like in python and this is how the
how we move on to
how we check for the true the truth
truthfulness or the falseness of a
particular expression in the if
statement so moving on
let's move on to the topic of
indentation in um in python so as you
can see
this uh this if statement is an example
of a control structure so without moving
without defining what a construal
control structure is
in detail control structures consist of
these conditionals or loops or
iterations if you will
so all of these control structures
involve heavy indentation so what does
an indentation mean well what if i gave
you an example say i gave you some
variable called age and i wrote 20 over
here now if i gave you an if statement
saying if age is greater than 10 now
it's very important to note that when
i'm defining an if statement i need this
colon otherwise this if statement is not
defined so this colon is important uh
anyways so now i'm checking this
expression if age is greater than 10.
now what is this what happens if age is
greater than 10 now what if i want
python to do something only if age is
greater than 10 well how do i tell
python that there is a piece of code
or a section of code that i want
executed only if this condition is met
well this is where indentation comes
into play so if i want say if i want
this line
this person is an adult again this is
some random line where i'm assuming age
is pertaining to this adult all right or
this person so if i have uh this
variable age where i write this number
20 which denotes the age of some person
and i'm doing a check if age is greater
than 10. actually let's be specific here
well the adult age for most people is 18
in most countries so let's see if age is
greater than 18. now if i'm doing this
check uh i want to print this statement
only if this person is a person's age is
above 20 above 18. so
how do i tell python that i only want
this statement to be
executed only during this if this
condition is met well this is where
indentation comes into play as you can
see exactly as you can see uh this part
this portion of the code is slightly
indented compared to the if statement so
when this condition is met then only do
we move on to this if this condition is
not met we move on to whatever the next
section of code will be like whatever
whatever
code that we have after this if
statement so let's see so this since
this condition is actually met as you
can see this print statement is actually
executed so this is the importance of
indentation now we will see uh in as we
move as we learn more about if
statements and else statements and lf
statements how indentation plays a key
role in defining what we want as an
output when a certain condition is met
all right so for now it's very important
to understand that this is how
indentation is used in python in other
languages we might use uh we probably
don't use indentation in fact popular
language the c language uh does not use
indentation at all but some languages
and python in probably the trademark
language for indentation and programming
so you might say that
so different people have different
opinions on an indentation the general
consensus is that indentation helps make
the code look very presentable and very
readable and this actually is one of the
facets of python programming is the
indentation and the easy readability of
it anyways moving on so what if we have
um multiple conditions in our code or if
in our if statement block that we want
to see so let's create this
list or let's actually just copy this
example that i have written over here as
you can see what i am doing in this
piece of code is i have a list x where i
have this integer 50 i have two strings
cat and apple now i want to check a
bunch of things so i want to check if 60
is an x and i also want to check if the
string cat is an x
and i want a final sort of like if none
of these conditions are met i want
something to happen so how do we do that
well we start off our state our if
statement block with the standard if
keyword all right now if we have
one more condition that we want met then
we can use the l if which
is kind of a short form for else if
so we use the l if keyword so it so what
this python
what python reads is it checks this
condition then it will check this
condition and then finally we have this
else keyword and else is the keyword
used in our block to tell python that if
none of our earlier expressions have
been true then do uh what is in the uh
that is within the else uh keyword that
is indented within the s keyword so
again we don't pass an expression for
else because else is uh only we only
reach this l as statement in case all of
the other earlier conditions have not
been met or have
come to be false and not true so let's
look at uh this particular code example
so we have a list of 50 cat and apple
and i'm my first expression that i'm
checking is
is 60 in x so this is how we check
actually so if 60 and x should be read
as is 60 in the list x so is this 16
elix list x well actually no we don't
have the object 60 so this part is not
executed we move on to the next
condition is the string cat in x well
actually it is uh the string cat is
indeed in x so we move on to this
statement block which is within the
condition that is met which is print cat
is in list x and you will see that none
of the other statement blocks will be
executed because we have met our
condition over here so if i execute this
as you can see that the print statement
cat is in list x is what is actually
executed and we do not
execute this obviously because it is
false and we do not even check or we did
not even move on to the statement
because well we have a condition met
over here so it's a one thing that is
important to note is that we can use as
many elif statements to check for as
many conditions that we we want to check
for
but it's very important that we only use
and if we are using that we only use one
else statement and only at the end of
our block okay so moving on now i'm
going to show you a very neat example
about how python actually does its uh
these these condition checkings so it's
very important to note that once a
condition is met none of the other
conditions are even checked for so
we do not even consider the next
statements and we directly leave this
if statement block so let's look at this
example over here now in this example
that i have over here is where i've
stored the string cat index now i have
three um i have three conditions that
i'm checking i'm checking is 50 greater
than 60 i am checking if the value of x
is indeed cat and i'm checking i'm some
random expression 1 divided by 0 this is
not even a check this is literally just
checking if one divided by zero is true
or false and as we know we cannot divide
anything by zero so
let's see what happens when i execute
this statement now typically if i wrote
one divided by zero python will throw me
an error because 1 cannot be divided by
0 that is an error error in a statement
so let's see what happens when i do this
actually as you can see i have a
statement being printed but i have no
error even though i gave it wrong i gave
an error statement in 1 divided by 0
well now you might ask why is that so
well it's simply because i have actually
never reached this condition i have not
even
python is not bothered looking at this
because if you actually see there is a
condition previous to this
over here which is met and which is true
so we move on to this block we execute
this block and we forget about the rest
of the code so we don't actually get to
uh this erroneous statement which is an
interesting thing and which is an
example that i have shown uh to show you
that once a condition is met in an if
statement block we do not look at any of
the further conditions that are being
checked okay so finally um i have one uh
one small topic that i would like to
share with you is the conditional
expressions or the python's ternary
operator now this is slightly different
to the if statement that we have talked
about up until now
in the sense that it is not a control
structure so what this actually is is
more of an operator that defines some
expression so let's see what i'm trying
to say over here so as you can see over
here highlighted is the
syntax for what i'm trying to talk about
this ternary operator so let's look at
this example and let's see what i'm
trying to do over here so i have this
variable age all right and this age is
26. now x now just just read this
statement x is equal to adult if age is
greater than 18 else child now i could
have done an elaborate control structure
with an if statement then an indentation
within that if statement and then um i
could have written else and then another
indentation and i would have written
another statement over there but instead
of that i have used this operator to
assign a particular value to the
variable x and this
what value i'm assigning to x depends on
if this condition is true or false so
as you can see the condition says is age
18
greater than 18 so if this is true then
i assign this particular string if it is
false then i go to the else statement
and i assign this so since age 26 is
greater than 18 i should assign the
string adult to x and as you can see if
i execute this and check what is an x
you can see adult is indeed an x so this
is a very neat a very needable readable
and a very um
it it's a it's probably a more it's it's
a better looking way uh to perform
simple else uh some simple if and else
statements where you don't want to
create a whole um if stay if if else
statement control structure block so
yeah this was the ternary operator
finally we let's uh we we make a short
note on the path statement uh in python
so the path statement or the pass
keyword is a
a place where it is a placeholder of
sorts so what if i had an if statement
and i'm writing a piece of code but i
don't know what to do with this if
statement so if if a statement is
correct if a statement is true um but i
don't know what to do if this statement
was true
how do i tell python well let's just
keep it a hold for now and i might
put something into this block later in
the future well i would use the pass
statement so if i had this uh say the
sum condition again so i'm checking age
is greater than 18 but i don't know what
to do with this i would just simply use
this pass statement and uh this
basically does nothing uh it it's a way
to it's it's like a way to create a
placeholder where maybe in the future i
might have i might write some sort of a
say a print statement or some sort of a
different function or something else
within this indentation so but in the
meantime like currently i don't have
anything to place over here so i just
leave it with a pass statement so this
is
a way where you can use a pass statement
in um if an else statement or infinite
control structures in this video we will
be i will introduce you to the concept
of iterations in python and we will be
speaking in specific about the
indefinite iteration in python otherwise
known as the while loop so let's look at
what an iteration means an iteration is
uh
executing the same block of code over
and over potentially many times a
programming structure that implements an
iteration is called a loop now in
programming we have two types of
iterations definite and indefinite
iterations and in this example we will
be speaking about indefinite iterations
in definite iterations in python is the
while loop where we use the while
keyword to define an indefinite
iteration so let's look at the basic
syntax as you can see this is the basic
syntax where we have the while keyword
followed by an expression and again the
colon and below that is something
indented again we encounter indentations
just like in fl statements a set of
statements where
what happens here is following the while
keyword we have this expression where
this expression is evaluated in a
boolean context again we check if this
expression evaluates true or false and
if it is true we
execute all the statements or the
statement block that is indented below
this file statement this is another
example of control structure much like
uh infinite statement blocks where we
use a lot of indentation so let's look
at a basic example now of while loop so
let's copy this example and let's see
what this does so i have a variable n
where i am assigning it a value 0. this
is called an initializing process and
it's very important to note that most
while loops consist of an expression
which contains a variable a control
variable uh which
is usually initialized prior to starting
the loop and then this control variable
is
typically very modified somewhere within
the
main loop body so in this case my
control variable is n and i am
initializing it by assigning it the
value 0 so let's uh move into the loop
now so the loop has this wire keyword as
you can see followed by a
an expression n lesser than or equal to
5. now what this is is an expression
which is going to check if it's true or
false is n lesser than or equal to 5 and
as long as this expression is true we
will continue doing whatever is indented
below this y statement and what is below
this while statement is a print
statement first of all which says value
of n is and it basically prints the
value of n in that particular iteration
and as you can see at this compound
assignment where we add the value of n
by 1 and we assign it back to n so what
this is uh let's see what this does
actually let's execute this and see what
this does uh important to note the value
of n again is initialized at zero so
this while loop will keep going on until
the value of n remains lesser than or
equal to 5. so as you can see i have the
execution of this
particular block of code or this while
loop where i get the
multiple different iterations of this
print statement that you can see here
the first iteration it says value of n
is zero then it's the value of n is one
what i'm doing is i am writing i am
assign i'm writing uh the value of n
multiple times uh and each time the
value of n is written over here based on
what iteration it is so what is
happening actually is
that initially the value of n is 0 and i
print the statement value of n is 0. now
i add
the value of what is in n by 1. so now
what is the value of n so again we do
this check so after this first iteration
we
come back like once this whole
block of code is executed we again come
back to this expression and we again
check if this statement is true so now
that the value of n is actually one
this statement is still true so again we
execute this and that you can see over
here value of n is one now again we add
the value of n by one and again we go
back here once this uh this block is
executed and we check if this statement
is true again and as you can see the
value of n when it's 2 is still
making sure that this expression is true
and this keeps happening until the value
of n is greater than 5. so once the
value of n becomes 6 this condition is
no longer met and finally we do not
execute the statement because this
expression evaluates to false and we do
not do this anymore and we finally leave
our while loop so let's check what the
value of n is just to confirm this as
you can see the value of n is indeed 6
and that is why we have left this while
loop over here so this is an example of
a basic while loop where we check for
this uh an expression if it evaluates to
true we evaluate everything within it
once this is done we go back and we
evaluate this expression again if it is
again true we again go back into
whatever is indented within it and we
keep doing this until the expression
gives us false and interestingly we
don't we don't necessarily have to
define these control variables always we
can actually use uh iterables and we
will learn about iterables actually in a
future video but we can use iterables
and an example of an iterable is
the list so let's look at this list and
let's look at this whole block all right
so i created this list a which contains
five objects one two three four and five
all integer objects and i have another
variable a x where i store the integer
one now i'm this while statement now it
might look confusing now it says it says
while a now what is a well a is not uh
your typical expression where you're
making sure if some condition is being
met or not but this the way you read
this is while a exists so in the context
of a list as long as a which is a list
contains objects within it a is true if
it does not have any objects within it a
is false so while a basically what it
means is while a has objects within it
and if it does have objects within it or
as long as it does we continue executing
whatever is indented within this while
statement and this y statement is a
print statement again we
do like we we have this value x where we
um we're doing this this we're printing
this is iteration number and
we pass x so the first iteration
obviously pass x is equal to one and
then we add x by one and then the second
iteration should pass this iteration
number two and then so on and finally we
have another statement within this block
called the a called the pop statement
where we're popping the elements of a
now as if you would have seen the list
the video and list the pop statement
removes the right most value
from a list so if i do a dot pop
initially it will remove five from this
list and i will have the rest of them
again if i do pop it will remove four
from this list and then you will have
the rest of these so let's actually see
we'll actually check what's left in this
list each time we do this pop statement
so that i'll also print the list
a each uh during each iteration and
let's see what happens over here as you
can see what is happening out here is
while a or while a has elements we are
going to continue doing this while
statement whatever is within it so in
the first iteration obviously we have
all of it
and it is iteration number one and as
you can see the list contains everything
then i pop it then iteration number two
it again has elements but it has lost
its most rightmost element and this
keeps on happening until the list
finally has no elements left and once
element or events the list has no
elements left we this expression while a
evaluates to false and we do not execute
this anymore and we leave the while loop
and again let's check what is in a a
should have no elements as you can see
it's an empty list when i check what's
in a it's an empty list and that is why
while a returned near false and we did
not print any further so this is an
example of using a while statement using
lists
and of course
the next topic would be discussing
nested while loops and
this is a broad topic what i mean by
this is that when when i'm saying nested
while loops i'm actually talking about
nested control structures so we can have
while loops within while loops not only
that we can have if an else statements
within while loops we can have while
loops within if and else statements and
we can have if and l statements within
if and l statements so if you think of
all of these loops uh and we will even
speak about for loops in the in the in
in another video for loops again a type
of control structure so all of these are
control structures while loops are
control structures for loops are control
structures if and l statements or
control structures all of these are
control structures and nesting can
happen within them and it does not
matter
which is the like the parent of the nest
and then the child or the nest we can
have a while loop within an infinite
statement you can have for loops within
a while loop all of this is valid in
python and uh it's one of the one of the
great features of python that is very
flexible in this way so let's look at an
example where i have a while loop within
another while loop so i'm copying this
piece of code where i have this list one
two three four five and another list
first and second now my first while loop
i print i print what is popped from a so
i take a then i pop the zeroth index so
basically from the left hand side and i
print what is that all right and then i
have another while loop where i have
this list b and i'm doing the same thing
but this while loop is within the first
while loop and let's see what happens
out here so as you can see my first
my first iteration of this parent while
loop causes me to pop what is the first
element which is one then i do these
while loops and this is completely
executed and only then do i go back to
this first one and then i come back and
do all of this again then i go back to
this one and then i come back and do all
of this again and that's why you can see
this repetition so i have this first
iteration and then i do
the second while loop then i have the
second iteration and then i do the
second while loop and i keep doing this
and this is an example of a nested while
loop okay so our next topic in this
section this video would be break and
continue statements now break in
continue statements are
ways to abruptly end iterations uh in in
a particular loop you can use break in
continuous statements not only in while
loop but you can use it in also in for
loops so let's look at how we use it in
while loops and let's look at what we
mean by breaking continuous statements
first of all well the break statement
terminates the loop entirely so once the
break statement is found
the the complete while loop that we are
using is completely terminated and the
continuous statement on the other hand
terminates only the current loop
iteration and it goes back to the
beginning or the expression and it
checks whether uh the expression or the
uh the controlling expression is again
re-evaluated and it is checked whether
uh the loop will execute again or
terminate this pictorial that you can
see here actually emphasizes or it shows
the difference between break and
continue so i have this while loop and i
have an expression all right i have a
bunch of statements and i have a break
command over here and have a continue
command over here so if i encounter the
break command it will not execute any of
this in fact it will not execute this
while statement at all and it will move
on to the next piece of code that we
have but a continuous statement if a
continuous statement is encountered in a
while loop will not completely break
away but it will not uh it will not
execute the the rest of the statements
in that iteration only these two but it
will go back here it will check this
expression again and again we will do
this all over again so this is this
small uh difference between the break
and continue statements but both are
used to abruptly end an iteration in a
loop so let's look at an example of how
we use the break statement so i will use
this example where i have again i have
initialized some controlling variable n
to 0
my first loop will check whether n is
less than equal to 5. if this is true
then i will print this statement then i
will what i'm doing over here is i am
incrementing it by one now in my
previous my earlier example using a
similar uh using the similar example uh
i had no like this this part was not
there so what you got was i was printing
the value of n so it was printing as
like value of n is one i mean zero and
then one and then two and then three
four and five but over here i've
included a small i've nested an if
statement and within that i put a break
statement and this if statement is
checking if if n is equal to equal to 2.
so once n is 2 i move on to this and i
do the break statement so let's see what
happens now as you can see once
so when i have executed this i don't get
the whole value of n is 0 and then 1 and
then two three four five i o i stop at
one and that is because once n is equal
to two i actually do not execute this uh
while loop again i do not go back and
execute print value of n is two now in
fact i break from this whole while loop
and my while loop terminates right then
and there and that's why you only get
these two iterations value of n is zero
and then value of n is one okay so now
i'm going to show you a neat example of
what happens or what is the difference
between a break and a continuous
statement okay so let's uh go back to
our initial example where we're printing
this value of n is 0 1 2 3 4 and so on
but i've added one more statement where
i print hello at each iteration so let's
see what happens when i do this as you
can see it will print hello after each
of whatever i was doing already now
let's introduce our break statement
first of all so when i do break well
let's
go back to this if statement if
if we check this condition then we break
let's see what happens now as you can
see something interesting has happened
where we have this first iteration
completely being executed but the second
iteration kind of stops where there's no
hello and that is because we have broken
from this while loop before the second
iterations hello was printed let's see
the difference between a break and
continue now so now i have this continue
statement instead of a break let's see
what happens here as you can see it
seems familiar to our first example
where we did not have any break or
continue but there is a small difference
that i want you to catch and that is
very important about this continue
statement so as you can see the first
iteration has value of n is 0 and then
hello and value of n is 1 but there is
no hello and this is because and this is
because once this condition is actually
met we do not move on to this statement
but we go back to this expression and we
will evaluate this expression and then
once we evaluate this expression again
and it's found to be correct we do
everything the same again where we print
hello but except for that one step where
this if statement was met and we did
continue and this following statement
was not executed and that happens only
for one iteration and that is when n is
equal to equal to two and as you can see
that is what happens over here in one of
the iterations we may say hello and that
is the difference of the continue
statement between uh there is a
difference of the continue statement
with the break statement this video will
be an extension to that topic where we
will be looking at three examples where
we are using while loops along with
other stuff like say if and if
statements so our first example will be
where we calculate the factorial of a
number in this example as you can see
here we are first going to ask the user
to enter a particular number for us now
this number is supposed to be an integer
once we have this integer we store it to
a variable called number now we have
this you can say this
variable called fac which does one and
you we will see how we are using it
later now we know that the factorial of
zero is one that's how it's just defined
so we have an if statement checking
whether our entered number is 0 and if
it is 0 we
say that the result is 1 or the
factorial is 1. however
if we enter a number that is greater
than 0 we must calculate the factorial
for this number and that is what we are
going to do in this else statement block
over here now in this else statement
block we have a while loop in this while
loop the condition is checking while
number is greater than or equal to 1 so
as long as this condition is true
everything within that while loop will
be executed so as long as number is
greater than equal to one we are going
to execute these two lines now what do
these two lines do let us see so the
first line takes the variable fac where
we had the number one stored and we're
going to store fac times number into it
number being the number that we have
inputted so in case for example we still
we entered eight then what this will do
this line will do is one into eight and
it will store that back into fac now
once that is done we move on to the next
line where we are decrementing the
number variable by one so if we have
stored eight or we have entered eight
into our input it will become seven now
as we know 7 is still greater than equal
to 1 so this condition is still being
met and then we do this process again
where we are going to multiply fac this
time f ac stores the value 8 and we
multiply it times the new number which
is seven now so we do eight into seven
and then again we decrement this uh also
once we do eight into seven we store it
back into fac and we keep doing this
where we keep multiplying eight times
seven and then we decrement the number
variable uh by 1 and then we check this
condition again so what ends up
happening is we are going to keep doing
8 into 7 into 6 into 5 into 4 into 3
into 2 into 1 and once we are at 1 again
when we do this document operation the
number variable will store the value 0
and then this condition will no longer
be met so number will be 0 and this
condition will be false and we can move
out of this while loop then finally we
store the result into a variable called
result which stores the result of 8 into
7 into 6 into 5 into 4 into 3 into 2
into 1. this is of course if we did
enter 8 when we were asked to give an
input so let's see this um in real time
once we execute this so i'm executing
this the first thing it asked me is to
enter a number so let's say i enter my
number eight as i was speaking about
eight all right now that i've entered
eight as you can see the result that it
gives me is factorial of eight is four
zero three two zero which is correct and
you can check this for yourself where it
will show you um eight times seven or
eight factorial is basically this this
number okay so now in our next example
we will be looking at how we can
generate fibonacci numbers for this
example we will be using bunch of if and
else if statements along with a while
loop so let's look at this piece of code
where we are actually doing this so as
you can see the first part of the code
is basically an input statement asking
us how many fibonacci numbers we would
like to generate and then the user would
be asked to give an input which is
stored as an end into a variable count
now in this uh if statement the first
if statement checks whether what we have
entered is 0 in which case we just store
an empty array in the variable called
fib
next if our
entered integer is 1 we just store the
value 1 in this array called fib if our
entered number is 2 we store 1 and 1 in
the array fib all of these are different
sets of fibonacci sequences this
obviously an empty
an empty array shows that well there is
no numbers to be generated in this
sequence if we have one we just print
the first number of the fibonacci
sequence which is one itself if it is
two we print the first two numbers which
is one and one now the actual
calculations happen when we say we want
a fibonacci sequence for more than two
numbers now in that case we move on to
this block in this statement block we
initialize the fib variable with the
first two fibonacci numbers one and one
and we store in this very in this array
now we are going to do a while loop
within this and in this while loop we
are going to keep executing the
statement block as long as this
condition is met or this condition is
true and what this condition is is it's
checking this variable i which we have
initialized as 1 over here and we're
going to check whether that is lesser
than count -1 count being the number
that we have been asked to input if the
statement is true and as long as the
statement is true we will be executing
the statement block which is basically
us appending this expression into the
array fib now what this expression is is
basically it's going to keep adding uh
each subsequent numbers and we're going
to store each subsequent numbers back
into the
array fib so in this case if you see the
what the first step will do is it will
take the value at the first position of
the array film and it will add it to the
value at the zeroth position of the
array fib and both of these values since
they are one and one when we add them we
get two and we append that to fib so now
our fib will look like one comma one
comma two then we increment this by one
and what we do is we
do the same process again so in the next
step what would be what we would do is
we would do two plus one so we would get
three now this would keep going on until
this condition is met or basically until
uh the numbers that we actually want to
generate in our sequence so let's like
let's let's uh execute this and let's
see an example of what happens so it
asks me how many fibonacci numbers i
would like to generate and i will say i
want the first let's say six fibonacci
numbers so i execute this as you can see
this gives me the first six numbers in
the sequence which is one and one and
then two which is basically one plus one
and then three which is one plus two and
then five which is two plus three eight
which is 3 plus 5. so if we wanted more
numbers we would just enter over here
like say if we wanted the first 10
numbers it would give us
the first 10 numbers in the sequence as
you can see here now in our next example
what we are going to do is we're going
to write a program which takes two
digits that represent the dimensions of
an array so for example if we want a
three by three array we will enter three
comma three and we are going to generate
a two dimensional array in which each of
the elements of the array are basically
the row times the column position of
that particular element and what i mean
by this is say we have a position i
comma j on the array the value of the
element at that position would be i
times j so for example if i'm looking at
something at the third row and the fifth
column or say the third row and the
third column for example the value of
the element would be three times three
and if i'm looking at something at the
second row and the fourth column i am
going to do two times four so let's uh
let's see how we can do this using code
so if you look to the right over here i
have a piece of code where i'm going to
in where it asks me to input two numbers
two integers to represent the dimensions
of my uh example my sample array now
once we have done this we are going to
store
these uh these
dimensions in the
inputs uh in in a variable called input
string so obviously when we enter say 5
comma 5 that will be stored as an in in
this particular string or this variable
what we want is we want
five say we entered five comma five we
want five as a separate integer and the
other five as another separate integer
and that is what we do in this
particular statement where we're going
to split up our input string
based on the comma separator and we're
going to store the first part of that
string into the zeroth position of
dimensions which is an array and the
next dimension in the first position in
this particular array now
we are going to store the number of rows
as row number and that is the zeroth
position of this array and we are going
to store the number of columns as the
first position of dimensions or whatever
we've mentioned in the input so now we
we have this um our results array called
multilist which is basically what what
our final array is going to look like
and we're going to store into multi-list
and in this example we will be using for
loops to
do this or to create this particular
array so as you can see here our first
uh we have initialized our multi-list
saying that
we're going to have
only zeros in our sample array so
initially once we have initialized this
array all multi lists will contain is a
say for example we have inputted a five
by five array it will have basically a
5x5 array with all elements as 0 and
that's what this line does once we have
done this we are going to move on to the
for loop portion where we are actually
going to create our array that we want
so as you can see we are our first for
loop is going to say for row in range
row number so obviously uh range will
generate a
an iterator which can be iterated over
um and since it says range row number
and say our the number of rows that we
entered were five what it's going to do
is it's going to create an iterator
containing the value 0 1 2 3 and 4. so
for row and range it will basically
basically row will take the value 0 1 2
3 and 4. and a similar thing is going to
happen in this nested for loop which is
within this where we're going to again
uh create a an iterator using this range
function and for the column number once
we have this we're going to do the
simple process of
multiplying the uh the value of the
element based on its position so if it's
at the position three comma four we're
going to store the value three times
four into that particular position of
the array and we're going to do this for
every position which is what happens in
these two for loops we're going to first
go by each row and then within that
we're going to check each column and
we're going to perform these
calculations and finally we print our
result so let's look at an example now
i'm going to say i want a 3 by let's say
a two by four matrix so let's see what
the results will be when i give this as
uh so what i'm saying is i want two rows
and four columns now as you can see here
it might not be very clear to you right
now but what you can see here is this is
the first row and this is the second row
and each row contains four columns so
these are the this is the my final array
that i get so what you can see here is
this is the zeroth position and the uh
or you can say this is the first row
first column first row second column and
uh since python is zero based so this is
actually the zeroth row and this is the
first row so as you can see uh this this
value basically is zero times one this
value is zero times two zero times three
zero times four and over here it is one
times zero one times one one times two
one times three so similarly if i did
for example a five by five matrix what
you will get is five rows now five rows
and five columns and for example like
this particular value is uh one two
three or zero one two three so zero one
two three and the first column so this
is three times one um if i took this
value this is like the fourth row for
example fourth row times the um zero one
two three third column so this would be
four times three which is twelve so and
uh each value of this has been generated
in the similar process so this is an
example of how we can use for loops
for a particular exercise that i have
shown you right now in this video we
will be covering the topic of definite
iterations uh using for loops in python
so starting off we know that there are
two types of iterations in programming
are definitely indefinite we have
already covered indefinite iterations in
the form of while loops
definite iterations on the other hand
are done using the keyword for
and the basic syntax or the standard
syntax for a basic for loop in python is
as you can see over here we have this
four keyword we have some variable we
have the in keyword and we have this
iterable and
we of course define this control
structure with the colon and then
indented we have this statement block so
once this for loop has started we
execute all of these uh statements
within the statement block as part of
the follow-up iteration so yeah let's uh
now let's to understand like how for
loops work uh exactly let's uh look at
the concept or meaning behind what we
call iterables and iterators so so think
of it in a stepwise manner all right so
we in python we have different objects
that can be used as iterables and an
iterable is basically some
object that uh it's it's a collection of
other objects so you know think of your
lists uh think of dictionaries and sets
so all of these are essentially
collections of objects
so once we have these collection of
objects
we can create an iterator out of it
how do we do that is we use the iter
function so for example if i passed this
list a if i pass this list a through the
iter function and i store it in some
variable iter underscore a
and i see what is iter underscore a it
is actually a list iterator at some
random memory location which we don't
really care about similarly if i gave a
tuple and i did the same thing i will
create a tuple iterator and in the left
if you can see over here i've done the
exact same uh functions with sets and
dictionaries as well so i'm creating
iterators out of these
iterables so as to speak
now what is an iterator well an iterator
is an object that yields
values successively so
if my list contained five values or five
objects an iterator of this list will
yield these values one after the other
and that is kind of how or that is the
basis for which we do
we create loops let's see what we
exactly mean using this uh
using another function that we call the
next function so the next function keeps
moving from object to object within an
iterator so since i've created this list
iterator let's just do it once again so
as you can see i've created this listed
iterator iter underscore a now with this
item underscore a what i'm going to do
is i'm going to use this next function
what next function does is starting from
the leftmost object within this iterator
i will keep yielding or keep producing
the values so let's let's just see what
happens when i do next either when i do
next for this particular variable it
gives me this object first now let's see
what happens when i do it again
now it gives me the object second what
if i did it again it gives me third now
if i kept doing this it will keep giving
me the different objects that were
initially stored in a that is first and
then second third fourth and fifth one
after the other so let's actually
perform that now i get fourth now i get
fifth now a natural question is now that
i've exhausted all of these values what
will happen if i perform the next
function again well let's see what
happens i get a
an error or and this error is the stop
iteration function error which basically
is telling me
look you have
exhausted all of the objects that were
initially present in this list a and you
cannot you cannot keep doing the next in
the next function anymore you cannot go
you keep going further so yeah so this
is uh what the next function does when
it comes to the
concept of iterators all right so now
we've learned two things what is an
iterator and what is the how do we
create an iterator out of different
collections of objects like a list or a
tuple and we've also learned how to use
the next function now let's uh move or
let's come back to our for loop that we
started off this video with so our for
loop again let's consider our for loop
over here
as you can see some for loop with
objects again one two three four and
five all right this is a list now i'm
going to do for x in a print x and let's
try to see what happens when we do this
okay as you can see when i have executed
this it gives me one two three four and
five so i have first of all let's look
at this for loop i in this for loop i
define a new variable x and then i say
for x in a print x and what's happening
well in each iteration i am printing
whatever the value of x is
at present so in the first iteration it
is the first object one in the second
iteration it is the second object two
then three four five and then finally uh
on its own like uh this for loop knows
that okay now once i have exhausted all
of the objects within my iterator i can
stop doing this for loop and i can move
on with the rest of the code all right
so think of it like a three-step process
uh a for loop in python the first step
is it calls an iter function to obtain
an iterator
for whatever we pass over here this
iterable second step it calls the next
function repeatedly in each iteration
all right to keep getting the next item
from the iterator so it gets one then it
calls next then it gets two then it
calls next and it gets three and then
four and then five and so on and then
finally the third step is the
termination step is when after we do the
final next where we get this
error as you can see the stop iteration
error or exception finally this tells
the for loop function or the for loop
that um okay we have reached the end of
our definite iteration or the end of our
definite for loop and this is where we
must terminate our loop and then
continue with the rest of the code all
right so this is how a for loop works in
python now it's very important to note
that whatever we have discussed when it
came to while loops such as nesting of
while loops and nesting of other control
structures is also applicable in the
case of for loops so if i had a for loop
within another for loop that is
perfectly fine if i had a vial within a
for loop that is perfectly fine so all
of these are valid statement blocks that
we can do
and again for loop is another control
structure and so we must follow the
concept of
indentation when it comes to writing our
statement blocks within a for loop okay
so now i'm going to speak about in
specific i'm going to speak about the
this uh something called the range
function that is uh quite
you could say it's used definitely it's
used in other areas of programming but
it's widely used in python uh i mean
i mean the for loop in python now what i
mean by this is that um
range this range function is very
important for the for loop and we will
see why okay so let's look at um one of
the examples of using the range function
so what does a range function do is if i
give range 5 let's see what it does it
gives me range 0 to 5. what this
basically tells me is that this will
create an iterator that contains
integers from 0 to 5 so it will contain
the object 0 1 2 3 4 and 5 and we can
use this as an iterator so let's let's
look at this i have range 5 let's store
this in x okay now let's do a type just
to see what happens when we do type x it
should give me the type of range as you
can see and this is the type of an
iterator in python now let's see what
happens when i do for i in x
print i okay let's see what happens as
you can see it prints the number zero
one two three four an important caveat
when it comes to the range function is
when we say range 5 it creates an
iterator from 0 to 5 but it contains the
objects 0 1 2 3 and 4 only it does not
contain the object 5 itself okay this is
something that is very important too so
uh once again i created uh i use this
range function to create an iterator
from
iterator of five objects from zero to
four zero one two three and four uh i
use that in my for loop and that's what
that is what you are seeing here now
let's use this range function in the
context of something else for example
let's see so i had my earlier list a
right look at my list a here
so you can see list a contains these one
two three four five five objects okay
let's see what length of a is length of
a is five okay uh let's use the range
function on top of the length of this
list a and this is uh like i can't show
you an example right now without any
context but this uh this form of using a
for loop is used is widely used in uh
python programming you will use it so
much in data science you will use so
much in machine learning and ai i cannot
tell you uh this is so this is a very
important like sort of uh for loop
expression so you have four
let's say i
in
range
len
a let's see what's going on here first i
create first i do length of a that gives
me five then i do range of five that
creates an iterator between zero and
four right when you do range five it
gives you an iterator of zero one two
three and four as we saw earlier and
this is what we're doing over here we
have created an iterator out of the
length of a list
now when i do print i it should give me
again one two three four zero one two
three four of course so as you can see
here it will give me zero one two three
four and this is a very neat way of
using the range function on top of the
length of a particular collection of
objects in this case we're using the
list a this is something that you will
use a lot so i i would recommend that
you get used to this form of creating a
for loop as well using the range
function also of course um there are uh
the you can use break and continue
statements as you have in the case of
while loops uh exactly this it works
exactly the same in the case of for
loops wherein the break statement will
abruptly stop the for loop completely
and we will move on to the next piece of
code whereas the continue statement will
break that particular iteration and then
we will resume with the next iteration
so yeah that was break in continue
statements and for loops finally i would
like to show you something about
how to use dictionaries as an iterator
or as an iterable when it comes to for
loops so let's create our dictionary
let's go we have a dictionary already
here in fact create this dictionary
again restore it in a okay so i created
this dictionary a all right so i have
dictionary a uh what i'm going to do is
i'm going to pass it through the
iterator function as you can see and now
i'm going to just for the sake of
showing you it will show i'll show you
that it is actually an iterator of type
of a specific dict key iterator type all
right so
now let's uh let's do something on this
so as you can see in the dictionary i
have the key first that has the value
one i have the key second that has the
value two i have the key third that has
a value three and then fourth for four
fifth for five now
a good question would be when i do
iteration or when i do a for loop on top
of this a well what is it going to pick
up is it going to pick up first uh is it
going to pick up the keys like these or
is it going to pick up the values or is
it going to go one by one key and then
value and then key in the subsequent
value uh let's see what actually happens
let's do 4 i in uh iter underscore a
print i let's see what what is the
iterations happening upon using this so
as you can see we're using the keys
so by default when we do this when we
perform when we create an iterator out
of a dictionary we use only the keys as
our
iterator elements or at iterator values
but of course like if you wanted to use
values all you would have to do is pass
a dot values
over here and if you remember from a
dictionary video this uh a dot values
gives us a a list of
or it by it gives us the essentially a
list of
the values in our dictionary so when we
pass this to the iterator uh iter
function and we create an iterator out
of it let's see what happens over here
now let's see what is it underscore a
you can actually see it's now the dict
value iterator at a particular memory
location so it's not the dict key as we
saw earlier it's a dict value iterator
so now that we have this dictionary
value iterator now let's print what are
our iterator elements and as you can see
now we are printing values and not um
the keys so this is how to these this is
basically two different ways of
iterating through a dictionary one
through keys and one through values in
this video we will be doing a small
exercise on if statements now in the
previous video you might have already
seen some of the basic concepts
surrounding if statements however in
this video just to drive home the point
or the purpose of an if statement we
will be doing a small exercise so let's
first revise some of the concepts of an
if statement so basic if statement can
be something like this
we have a small condition where we're
checking if a variable x is greater than
5 or not and if it is greater than x we
print a statement over here so if this
condition is met we print this statement
else we move to this statement block now
our variable x has the value 5. now
since x is not greater than 5 what this
will do is it will check the statement
and since this will be false we skip the
statement block and move on to this
statement so as you can see here
similarly we can do something
where we are checking multiple
statements we use the l if statement in
such a case so
now in this block we are checking in one
of the one of the conditions we're
checking is if x is equal to 5 or if x
is greater than 5 and then finally if
both of these conditions are not met we
say else and we print whatever or we do
whatever is in this particular statement
block which is a simple print statement
so as you can see x is indeed good is
equal to five so this is the block that
will get executed as you can see here
now another example are nested if
statements so nested if else statements
are if statements within if else
statements so let's look at an example
as you can see here we have a string
stored in a variable called orange
quality and the string is fresh now we
have an integer or a float in this case
4.0 stored in orange price now our first
statement is checking whether orange
quality the variable orange quality is
it equal to the string fresh now within
that if the statement or if this
condition is met we do another check
where we're checking what is the price
is it lesser than 5 if it is we do this
block else we execute this block finally
if our initial statement our initial
condition is not met we move on to this
else block now when i execute this what
should happen is i will enter this block
because this is true and finally i will
enter this block because this condition
is also true so i should have this
printed i will buy five dozens as you
can see here now let's move on to our
main exercise for this video so this was
all just a revision now we're gonna use
some or all of these concepts in a
sample project or a sample exercise
to for your further practice
so in this exercise what we're going to
do is we're going to request the user to
enter a number between 1 and 20 and our
our code is going to check whether this
number entered is an even number or an
odd number so as you can see there are
two sets of checks that we're going to
do in this code the first check is going
to be whether the number that is entered
is between 1 and 20 or not and if it is
not we have to say it's an invalid
number but if it is entered between 1
and 20 we have to move on to the further
checks which is whether it is an even or
an odd number so let's see how we do
that so in this piece of code what we
start with is a print statement saying
please enter a number between 1 and 20
and then we add an input command this
input command will open a box where we
can enter whatever number that we want
to enter
now we use this in keyword to make sure
that whatever we have entered into the
input box is stored as a int data type
in the enter num variable
once we do that our first if statement
is going to check whether the entered
number is greater than or equal to 1 or
less than equal to 20. sorry and less
than equal to 20. so both of these
conditions have to be met if this
condition is true then we have a valid
input and this statement is printed that
we have entered a valid number and then
we move on to the rest of the statement
block within this if statement which is
another set of if and else if statements
if our number is not between 120 we move
to this block and this block prints that
we have entered an invalid number now
once we have
say entered a valid number we move on to
this block this is in
if else
if elif statement block now what this
block is checking is whether the entered
number is an even number or not now as
we know an even number is divisible by 2
and leaves the remainder 0 when divided
by 2. so this is what this check is
doing if this check is true that means
our number is even and we get printed
that our number is even the other other
check or the other uh if statement is
checking whether it's an odd number and
that means when we divide by two we
should get the remainder one as you can
see here and we get printed your number
is odd so let's execute this and see
what happens when we enter a number now
it's asking me to enter a number let's
say i enter 17.
now that i have entered 17 as you can
see it's a valid number that i have
entered and the code is telling me that
my number is indeed odd let's look at
some other what if i entered something
else here let's say if i enter 16 now
since it's an even number as you can see
16 is also a valid number as it's
between 1 and 20 and my number is even
and the code checks for that let's see
if i what happens when i enter an
invalid number let's say 25 now will i
enter 25 as you can see it says i have
entered an invalid number and in this
case what has happened is this condition
itself is not met and i have moved on to
the statement block so to give you a
breakdown as to how our code has
executed this let me show you an example
for the number say nine when i enter
nine the first check that happens of
course is this check whether it's a
valid number or not and since it is
between 1 and 20 we move on to this
block and in this block is checking
whether our number is divisible by 2 or
not and since it is not it will remain
it will leave a remainder 1 and we
execute this block it says our print our
number is odd as you can see here in
this video we are going to learn about
the topic called file handling now file
handling is basically needed because so
most of the times when we're handling
large and different types of data in
python or in general we cannot store
everything into a variable and we will
have to use files now there are two
types of files that we are going to deal
with they are binary and text files so
binary files are some of the files that
we most of the files that we commonly
encounter like document files image
files video files etc now all binary
files are encoded in a particular format
and they cannot be read by a normal text
editor and we would be needing certain
specific softwares for specific files
text files on the other hand do not have
any specific encoding and they can be
opened in the normal text editor itself
and they are like
xml css html files and so on now there
are four main operations that we can do
on
by in python on files they are open read
write and close um there are certain
other operations as well though like
rename delete so some of the most basic
operation that we can do is obviously
creating and opening a file and the
syntax is as you can see here where we
store where we use the open command and
we give a file name and we give a mode
and we store that in a particular
variable now a mode is
basically telling python how to handle
this opening so we can have a read-only
mode which is done by this letter r a
write only mode which is done by letter
w and for there are a bunch of other
modes such as read or write mode which
is done by r plus and we are going to
see them as we encounter them now the
it's important to note that what i just
mentioned is for text files if we are
going to do
for binary files we're going to do this
file handling then we would be using the
letter b in front of whatever we were
using in the case of text files so if we
were doing a read-only mode for opening
a binary file um we would be using rb
and if we were doing read and write mode
read or write only mode for a binary
file we would be using rb plus
so basically just adding the b in the
case of binary files let's look at a
basic example when we want to open a
particular file we are going to like in
this example i'm going to open some file
called filehandling.txt in a read and
write mode read or write mode and i'm
going to store it in fo so this is as
simple as it gets similarly if i wanted
to do it for the binary file since i'm
using a binary file i will use the
letter b as well in the mode and that's
how you do it here now let's look at
different ways in which we can read from
a file and there are three commands that
we can use we can use the read command
followed by
optional number of characters we can use
the read line command followed by an
option number of characters and the read
lines command so this optional number of
characters is denoted by n over here um
and basically telling us how many
characters we want to print so let's
look at a simple example of
where i'm going to print something
called
so i'm going to take this and i'm going
to do a print on top of this so i have
done first i've opened it and i've
stored it in my file and then i'm going
to do a
a method or a function called read and
i'm going to say like in this example
just read the whole thing so as you can
see my file that i have opened has all
of these lines this is like the whole
file basically but now what if i wanted
to open only the first five characters
of this file which is basically this
well in that case let's open this once
again now let's do the same read command
except we will give the character number
which is five as you can see it's only
printed five now let's do a print read
command and uh try to read the whole
thing again and you will notice
something very interesting now when i do
the read command you can see it's kind
of picked up from where we left off you
know from our previous command and that
is the nature of how um python handles
files so if i wanted to again take the
cursor back in such an example i will
have to open this again
and then i use this read command once
again to get back to where i started
from as you can see here now another
command that we can use is the read line
command so let's uh once again open this
over here and now we're going to use the
read line command
over here so what redline command is
going to do is going to each time we use
this command it's going to go one by one
and read each particular line from this
file so in first case it will take
artificial intelligence then data
science big data and so on so as you can
see if i execute this it first takes
artificial intelligence now if i did
this command again
it will say data science next time if i
do it it should say big data as you can
see here okay so this is the readline
command now within the read line command
also we can enter uh characters and that
will tell us basically um that we want
these number of characters from the next
line so if i want the first six
characters of the next line i will say
six i will enter six here and it will
give me the first six characters of this
particular line which is the next line
that is to come as you can see here now
another way in which we can
print whatever is there in our file line
by line is by using a for loop so again
i'm going to open this file i'm going to
store it here
now i'm going to use a for loop saying
that well for line in my file and what
this does is basically at each each
iteration it's going to take each line
and store it in this variable that we
end over here which is called line
itself and we're going to print that at
the end of the loop what we'll have is
all of the lines have been printed one
by one and another thing that we can do
right now is um say we want to read a
particular line see i wanted you to read
the
fifth line of my file i can use this
technique where
i just say okay i'm going to store 5 in
this variable called line number and i
have this
another variable called current line
which i'm going to initialize with 1 and
i'm going to any i'm going to what i'm
going to do is i'm going to
do the same loop where i'm going to say
4 line in my line but i'm going to add a
condition saying that only if current
line when it's equal to line number am i
going to print the line and then i'm
going to break out of this whole thing
and at end of each
loop i'm going to say current line is
going to be incremented by one until
basically these two variables are equal
so when i do this i get my result which
is machine learning which is the fifth
line of um my which is the fifth line of
uh whatever file i had now we're going
to move on to the topic of um image file
handling so we we saw how we handled and
we we saw certain operations around
text files
and text files obviously something that
we're going to use a lot
but we are also going to be using files
such as images a lot and let's uh look
at certain examples in certain
use cases around image file handling so
my first step is going to be importing a
bunch of modules and packages now the
details of these modules and these
packages are not important as of right
now because they will be covered in a
future video but just keep a note of
some of these packages such as um they
say numpy and
image the image
package so once i've done this let's
move on to my example so what i'm going
to do is i'm going to store certain file
locations in two variables so it's
basically two strings uh i've attached
the uh this prefix r to say that this is
a read-only uh sort of a prefix so the
next topic that we're going to be
handling is image file handling now we
have already seen many examples
pertaining to text files so text files
are obviously something that we're going
to be using a lot but image file
handling is something very important as
well and we're going to see certain
operations that we can do around image
file handling so starting off i'm going
to import a bunch of
packages and modules what these packages
exactly are and what these modules
exactly are are right now not of that
important of not not that important to
you right now but it's something that
will be covered in a future or in future
videos
it's important to just keep note of what
these are such as numpy and image so
once i've done that what i'm going to
store is i'm going to store two
particular file locations into variables
location one and location two and i've
prefixed them with r just to say that
these are raw strings so once i've done
that i'm going to use the image
from the image package i'm going to say
open and i'm going to say open from this
particular location in this particular
location and i'm going to store these
image images in im1 and im2 over here
very similar to a normal text file
opening now once we have done this
we can access certain properties of this
image using say format which tells us
the format of the file
it attributes the it identifies the
source of an image and if the image is
not right from a file it is set to none
we can also see the size of the file
using the size attribute and we can see
the mode which basically defines the
number and names of the bands in the
image and also contains the pixel type
and depth certain common modes are like
l for luminescence rgb for true color
images and cmyk for pre-press images so
let's look at them so when i
access this you can see my first file is
of jpeg of this size and an rgb format
image and my second image is another
jpeg slightly bigger image and again rgb
now we
can also of course display these images
and to do that we can use the plt um
again plts the is supposed to stand for
a matte plot lip dot pipe plot it's a
particular for a particular package
that again you don't need to know the
details of right now but this is how we
would um do this so
i'm going to use a bunch of um commands
and methods such as figure and subplot
and then i am sure so once i have done
this as you can see both of my images
with this being im1 this being im2 have
been produced on the screen as you can
see i can also use display this display
function followed by the name of the
file and this will simply display my
image as you can see here now
i can obviously
save a particular
image using the save function which is
as simple as doing this so i'm going to
save the image as
i am underscore save dot jpg over here
now if i wanted to crop an image i can
do that as well so i initially i stored
the dimensions that i want cropped in
the form of a tuple as you can see here
and i'm going to pass that tuple to the
crop function and i'm going to apply
that on top of im1 and i'm going to
store that to region once i've done that
as you can see so basically what i've
done is i've cropped this image based on
whatever passed here and i've stored it
into region and now if i wanted to see
what was actually in that crop i can
just do the i am show function and i am
going to pass the particular cropped
image which is denoted by region as you
can see here and you can see my cropped
image is basically a certain a left
portion of this whole image has been
cropped out and i have produced it over
here now i can also use the copy
function using it's a simple basically
copy base you use the copy function and
it copies an image onto another variable
that you have assigned and when i use
the i am show function i'm going to show
you the copied image which is basically
the same now we can do the transpose
operation as well so let's see some of
the let's see what we've done here so in
this transpose opposite operation so in
this uh basically i've done a bunch of
operations such as rotating by 90
degrees rotating by 180 rotating by 7
270 and finally once i'm done with all
of these multiple operations i am going
to show you the final output which is
basically a certain transposed image
like this which is basically the result
of whatever i have done before this so
this is it for this video on file
handling i have shown you two slightly
more comprehensive examples on
text files and
even certain examples on image files
however we can use file handling and
different libraries pertaining to file
handling for
audio files and even for like stuff like
pdf files and uh this is like this is
just only the beginning and i'm sure you
will encounter a lot of different use
cases different examples as you continue
learning
python programming this video is going
to be the first of a part of a series on
object oriented programming so to start
off with let's try to understand and get
an introduction into what is object
oriented programming well as the name
suggests object oriented programming is
all about creating objects an object is
a group of interrelated variables and
functions variables can be referred to
as the properties of the object whereas
the functions can be referred to as the
behavior of an object so if we were to
treat say for example a car as an object
its properties would be its color its
model its price and its brand whereas
its behavior or functions for that
matter would be like accelerating gear
change breaking similarly if i give you
an example of a dog as an object we
could consider the properties of the dog
as its weight or its name its breed its
color whereas its functions could be say
barking playing eating walking etc
objects provide a better and a clear
structure for a program now lets move on
to what is a class and an instance now a
class is like a blueprint or a template
of certain functions and entities
whereas an instance is a particular
realization of a class classes are used
to create user-defined data structures
and define certain functions called
methods within the class whereas
instances are realizations of these
classes and when we are speaking of
classes and instances classes don't
contain any real data they are just
merely templates instances on the other
hand contain real data to think of an
example of the difference between a
class and an instance think of a class
like a empty form or a questionnaire now
an empty form of a questionnaire does
not have any information but it does
have a template to it it tells you to
fill in certain information and based on
who is filling in the information that
information or the data on a particular
form will be different so an instance is
like a filled out form with its own uh
unique set of information that is one
way of
treating or understanding what is a
class and an instance now for our first
example on classes i will be taking you
through a class where i've defined based
on the circle object so
this class is going to define basically
information about your general circle
such as its radius and this area so
let's go through it now obviously to
define a class we need a keyword well in
the case of classes we use the class
keyword followed by a name for that
class so in this case my name is circle
now after the colon every every
information that is part of the class
has to be obviously indented as is
typical for python now you can see over
here a bunch of def keywords followed by
sir something that you might not be
familiar with and i will try to get you
through this so if you see here you have
a def keyword followed by init and this
init is
prefixed by a double underscore and it's
suffixed by a double underscore and you
can see the same thing for str and repr
well this double underscore is called a
dunder and any method these are of
course methods this is a method this is
a method this is a method this is a
method now any method that is prefixed
and suffixed by double underscores are
called dunder methods um these under
methods are or can be thought of like
predefined or built in methods for
any class that you define so these we
have like three dunder methods over here
and we have one user defined method that
we will get to so this first method that
you see here is the init method or the
initialization method and this is
invoked or called whenever we create an
instance of this class circle and what
we do here is basically we pass
when we create this instant circle uh we
are what what happens is that we are we
get an option to pass an a value for
a
what is this uh keyword or variable
radius so if i pass so you will see me
uh later on creating an instance where
um i will be passing a value and that
value is basically stored as the radius
and by default the radius that will be
passed whenever we create an instance
for this class is one um the str method
is basically used to return a
descriptive string for the the instance
of um class um repr is not something
that you have to bother with right now
and uh now get area is something that
you should follow because if you see
here i have not used any double
underscores so this is a user
user defined method um user defined
methods are it's a method that we define
and these are like tasks that we define
on our own so in my user defined method
called get area i will be returning the
area of the circle based on the radius
that i passed to it now if you notice
here the before every um in every method
i have the self keyword before any other
attribute so
like this herself this herself even the
get area herself now what this means um
self is like an optional keyword that is
used to improve readability of a program
first of all and it's also the function
of the self keyword is basically um
telling python that well any of the
methods that we are invoking in this
class or the instance of this class has
to refer to attributes and variables
within that instance of that class so if
i'm going to use get area function i am
going to
get values and attribute values and
variable values based on only the
current instance of
that particular class self is obviously
optional we don't really need it but
basically the first attribute of any
method is
is basically the is basically what the
mel is is the instance that um the
method is invoked upon so if i say self
i'm telling
this particular function that okay all
the value that you're going to get for
performing whatever task you want is
going to be found in that particular
instance where you have been invoked
itself now don't worry if all this is
very confusing um this might be in the
beginning but just try to understand
that this is something that we do for
good practice and you will understand
when 20 yourself or when not to yourself
as you learn about object oriented
programming so if you see here my get
area function is supposed to return the
value radius times radius self dot
radius is basically telling um whatever
value i've passed for radius for that
particular instance you can read this as
radius times radius times pi as well so
obviously this is pi r squared which is
the area of a particular circle now let
me show you an example where i am going
to perform some of these functions so if
you see this first line i have created
an instance of the class circle where
i've passed 2.1 for the radius of the
circle so now the value of the variable
radius in this particular instance is
going to be stored as 2.1 and this
particular instance is going to be
stored in the variable c1 now the print
c1 function invokes the str self-defined
or predefined function now if you
remember str was it's basically used to
return a particular string that
describes like what the class will do
and this is something that we define on
our own in our example str will return
the uh the string saying this is a
circle with radius off and then it will
return the radius that we passed so in
this case it should say this is the
circle of radius 2.1 as you can see over
here so if i execute this you can notice
this line this is a circle with radius
2.1 and this is invoked by the print
function the print basically invokes the
dunder str function which does all of
this now in the next line we say print
c1 dot get area so this is going to
print the value of the
what what gets returned when we invoke
the method get area for this particular
instance c1 so obviously in this
particular instance our radius is 2.1 so
the get area function should do pi times
2.1 square and the value is as you can
see here is some 13.85 so that is the
area that we got now if we want to print
a particular radius um we just say print
c1.radius so this will print the value
of what is
what is stored in radius for the
particular instance c1 now you might
notice me using a dot whenever it comes
to defining a certain function or a
keyword well anytime that we want to
invoke or use a method of a particular
class we have to use the dot keyword so
we use the instance name c1 dot followed
by whatever method that we want to use
so if we want to use the getarea
function we say c1.getarea if you want
to find out what is there in the radius
key radius variable of a particular
instance we say c1 dot radius now before
we move on let's talk about some of the
naming conventions class names are
initial capitalized so if our class name
is
for example um
like for example if it's camel case well
each word that is part of this class has
its first letter capitalized variables
and method names are in lower class so
if my class was called circle we say
class circle with c being in capital now
moving on let's talk about how we
initialize or define instance variables
now instance variables are declared
within the init method if you remember
from the earlier example of circle init
is a dunder method it's followed and
it's preceded by double underscore as
you can see here now if you see in this
particular
case i have again used the self keyword
and as i mentioned earlier the self
keyword is the first parameter of all
member methods um and it this basically
binds that particular method to the
particular instance itself during
invocation so every time a new circle
object is created the dot init function
sets the initial state of the object by
assigning the values of the object's
properties so the init function
basically initializes each and every new
instance of um whatever of our class so
we can give in at any number of
parameters but the first parameter must
always be a variable called self now
when a new class instance is created the
instance is automatically passed to the
self parameter in init so that new
attributes can be defined on the object
inside the init method the self.radius
basically means that we want the value
of radius based on the current instance
itself so as you can see radius defines
an instance variable radius and we're
going to use the particular instance and
its value of for radius in our variable
radius now instance uh the i mean the
init function is not a constructor but
it is an initializer to create instance
variables the init function also will
never return a value and it is optional
and can be omitted if there are no
instance variables now let's move on to
um class variables so now as we
mentioned earlier all the attributes
that are created inside the init
function are instance specific
attributes and the instance attributes
are obviously specific to a particular
instance of the class for example all
dog objects now if we have a class
called dog then all dog objects have a
name and age but the values for the name
and age will vary depending on which dog
we are talking talking about or
basically which instance of the dog are
we talking about now class attributes
are attributes that have the same value
for all class instances and we define a
class attribute by assigning a value
value to a variable outside of the init
function so if you look at this example
over here we have created another class
called circle and we have this
initializer again where we have a class
specific variable called radius which
whose value will change depending on
whatever we pass for that particular
instance however if you look before the
initial the init
init function or the initializer
function if you see here we have another
variable called shape object which
stores the string circle and this
variable is going to be the same and
constant for every instance of
the class circle and unlike the
variable radius we will not have
different values depending on a
particular instance okay now let's talk
about instantiating an object and let's
see what happens when we create two
different instances of the same class so
as you can see here i've created an
instance c1 for class circle and i'm
going to check its id well if you see
the id is something like this now if i
created another instance over here
called c2 and if i check its id well
it's something different now so if you
see each instance basically has a
different memory location in our
memory
and each instance is this is how each
instance is different each time we
create it and they are created in
different memory locations finally
before we conclude this topic on um the
introduction into oop let's talk about
class methods instance methods and
static methods now class methods are um
usually declared are actually declared
with the
at class method operator or decorator as
you can see here it accepts the class as
its first argument so in this case i am
going to say i'm going to define a class
called my class i'm going to use this at
class method decorator to say that
whatever follows here is going to be a
class method and i've defined a class
method called hello that takes in a um
that uses again self and a name
attribute so what this does is it prints
um whatever i have passed to it in the
form of hello from
self.name now what this this is going to
do is basically it's going to give out a
string saying hello from name of is
called
the string name my class with a
comma and then whatever we passed
initially which was rakesh next is then
instance methods and these are the most
common types of methods these are
invoked by an instance object so we have
to create an instance to actually use an
instance method and it takes the
instance or the keyword itself as its
first argument so if i say class dot
class if i define a class myclass in
this example
and i'm going to define another function
called hello as you can see i have not
used any decorator like at uh class
method so this is going to be an
instance method and it's going to be
invoked by the particular instance so in
this case it's going to print hello from
and it's going to basically say the name
of the class again so i create my
instance called my instance1 and it's an
instance of this class and then i'm
going to invoke the instance method by
using this.operator and the instance
name and the result will be basically
this string over here as you can see now
finally we have another type of method
called the static method which is
declared using the add static method
decorator so a static method does not
know its class and is just attached to
the class for convenience it does not
depend on the state of the object and
could be from a separate function of a
module a static method can be invoked
via a class object or an instance object
so if you look at this example over here
i have defined a static method
i've defined hello and it basically says
print hello world so it's going to
basically just print this so if you can
see here i've created my instance and
i'm going to say dot hello it should
basically pre-print print hello world
that's all in this video we will
continue the discussion on oop with
inheritance inheritance is used to
describe the relationship between two
classes wherein one class takes the
methods and properties from another
class in this relationship we have
something called the base class or the
parent class from which we will derive
all our sum of the properties and
methods and the class which actually
derives these properties and methods is
known as the derived class so you can
think of the derived class as a
specialized version of a base class to
explain what inheritance is in a basic
way i will show you
an example where i'm creating a cylinder
class which is going to be a subclass of
the circle class that you might have
encountered in the earlier video on op
so what we're going to do is create a
cylinder class that is a subclass of
circle where we're going to get the
attributes radius and get area from
circle class and we're going to add the
attributes height and get volume to the
cylinder so right off the start you can
see we have our class circle that you
might have seen in the earlier video so
this class circle has the familiar
initialization where we are supposed to
enter a value for a radius that gets
stored in self.radius now we also have a
description string which basically is a
dunder method that returns a string when
we invoke the print command on a
particular instance and we have the get
area method as well now if we move on to
the cylinder class you can see that i'm
defining this class with the class
keyword with the cylinder name but you
can see that i have added a parenthesis
and within it i have mentioned the name
of the superclass that i want the
cylinder class to be a subclass of so
this is how we actually define a
subclass in the most basic way you enter
the name that you want and you enter the
name of the superclass that you want the
subclass to be if a subclass of in
parenthesis right after the name now
next if you move on to the dunder
initialization
the initialization is very familiar
familiar except now we have another
attribute for height which has a default
value of 1 just like the radius so this
basically means that we have an option
of entering two different attributes for
our cylinder instances now if you see
here there's a line which says super dot
init now this is like um this is a
command which we use to invoke the super
classes initializer so any time we
create an instance for cylinder we also
want an initialization for the circle
method as well as a part of our cylinder
instance next you can see that um much
like how we stored self uh i mean the
radius attribute in self dot radius
we're also storing the height attribute
in self.height now even this uh cylinder
class has an str
method to return a particular string if
we use this print function and finally
we get on to a more
a new method that we have defined only
for the cylinder class called get volume
now
if you see the get volume it returns as
basically the volume of
the cylinder that is being described in
the particular instance for which we
enter the height and the radius so if
you can see here what we basically added
extra is an a height attribute and
another method called get volume and the
other parts of
the circle superclass such as radius and
get area are also going to be a part of
cylinder even though you do not
explicitly see them anywhere here and we
will see how in uh in the form of an
example that's coming up so let me just
execute these classes now that that's
done i'm going to create an instance for
cylinder i'm going to store it in cy1
and i'm going to pass 1.1 for the radius
and 2.2 for the height and once that is
done let's just print um to invoke the
hdr method and as you can see the sdi
method basically tells us the
information that is a cylinder with
radius 1.1 and height 2.2 so now let's
print what is the value we get when we
use the get area method now it's
important to note get area was not
explicitly defined in the cylinder
subclass but it's a method that is a
part of the circle superclass and we can
see that we can actually access methods
that are part of the super class simply
by
accessing any other method so if you use
the dot get area you can see that we get
a value for the area of the cylinder so
this basic this area is basically the
area of the circle face of the cylinder
uh the top or the bottom now let's use
now let's invoke uh the subclass
specific method which is the get volume
method in a similar manner as you can
see just by
doing invoking this method we get the
volume as well now if we want to see
what is the radius and the height we can
just do a simple print statement
followed by cy1 dot radius c11.height
and it gives us both of these values as
you can see here now over here what i'm
going to do is create another instance
of cylinder but i'm not going to pass
anything for radius or height so
basically it's going to take the default
values for radius and height which was
one and one respectively so once i print
um this is this statement is basically
going to print the str method or
whatever we stored in the str which is
basically the description of the object
followed by what is its radius and
height this method will give us the area
and this method will give us the volume
so once i execute this as you can see
here this is what we get and this is
what we expect as well so now in this
example what i'm going to show you is uh
now i'm going to go back and i am going
to create another instance for circle
now this is the superclass of course and
i'm going to give it and since the
superclass has only one option uh one
attribute that we can enter which is for
the radius so i pass 3.3 and i'm gonna
print what what happens when i just
print uh this instance it's going to
basically give us whatever was a part of
the str method after that i'm going to
print is instance this is basically a
check on whether c1 is an instance of
this class circle and x i'm going to
check if c1 is an instance of its
subclass cylinder now when i execute
this you can see that well this is what
we uh this is the str method that gets
printed but if you see here um you can
see that it says c1 is indeed a an
instance of circle when it says true
over here but when we look at the next
line is c1 in instance of cylinder it
says false and this is obviously because
um a superclass object is never
an instance of a subclass object well as
whereas vice versa it would be true now
in the next part of this video what
we're going to do is look at the
different types of inheritances in
python so there are basically five types
of inheritance in python there is the
single inheritance there's multiple
inheritance multi-level inheritance
hierarchical hierarchical and hybrid
inheritance so we will go one by one and
see each of these examples starting off
we have the single inheritance this is
simply where we have one base class and
one derived class from that base class
so this is a simple
single inheritance and in this example
you can see i have a class called
country where i have a method that i've
defined called show country which is
basically going to say print this is
india it's basically going to print this
every time we invoke this show country
method then we have a class called state
which derives uh from the
superclass called country where we have
a method called show state which is
going to say print this state every time
so you can see i created an instance of
the class state and
through that instance i can access the
super class and the subclass methods
over here next we have the multi-level
uh sorry multiple inheritance and this
is when a derived class contains more
than one base class so let's look at an
example to understand this so if you can
see here i have a class called student
with the two methods defined called
method one and method two in method one
we can pass uh two attributes sn sno or
i think is this this is supposed to be
like uh an id i guess like sn number and
we have s name so this is basically two
attributes we can pass that are probably
descriptors for a student and
in the next method you have basically
two print statements which says student
number and then they will print the
student number and it will also print
the student name next we have a class
called marks this is also
so these these two classes are basically
what our super classes are going to be
and we're going to derive a third class
from these two so this second class is a
class called marks and we have two
methods again one method is called set
marks which has um the option of putting
in two attributes m one and m two both
are representative of the two marks and
we store them in self dot mark one self
talk mark two the second method is uh
put marks which is uh going to print the
marks namely mark 1 and then it's going
to tell us how much marks are there in
the first subject for example and
another print statement doing the same
thing for
the second subject or mark 2. finally we
have a third class called a result which
derives from two classes marks and
student as you can see here in my
parenthesis i've passed in marks and
student both are super classes and our
class result is going to derive from
both of them this is an example of
multiple inheritance and within this
class result i have uh two methods uh
specific to this derived class called
calc uh wherein i'm going to basically
calculate the two the total marks of um
uh the the total marks which is
basically the addition of mark one plus
mark 2 and i'm then i'm going to have
any other method called put total which
is going to print me what is the total
so if you can see here i have created an
instance of this derived class called a
result and i'm storing it in r then i'm
going to access method one which is
obviously a method from the first
superclass called student um and i'm
going to store okay so this is a name is
i guess lucky and here's 60 marks
secondly then i'm going to do our set
marks which is the method from the
second super class which is going to set
the marks uh respectively so you have
lucky student and his id is 60 and he
has got 50 and 60 marks respectively
in say the first two subjects and
finally i'm going to access the derived
class method called calc so this is
going to do the sum uh finally i'm going
to also do our method 2 which is
going to print our student number and
student name next we're going to have
put marks which is going to tell us the
what are the individual marks uh for
mark one and mark two and then finally
we're going to print the total marks
with the put total so once i execute
this you can see here it says student
number 60 student name lucky marks one
is 50 as i had written here marks 260 as
i passed here and then total is 110
which is basically 50 plus 60. and the
next type of inheritance is called
multi-level inheritance now multi-level
inheritance can be assumed as where you
take a superclass let's call it a and
you derive a class b from that class a
now what if we derived a class c from b
and we kept doing this so until say our
class e now each of these steps is uh in
its own an inheritance but this whole
relationship can be described as a
multi-level inheritance so let's take an
example again so i've this this time
i've defined a class called student
where i have defined two methods called
set stud and put stud or you can call it
set student and put student in my first
method i have options of adding two
attributes again this is the student
number this is the student name in my
second method i am going to print what
is the student number and what is the
student name finally uh so sorry next we
have another class called marks which
derives from the first
class called student this has two
methods called set marks where i'm going
to again get the option of adding two
integers for m1 and m2
which is going to represent mark 1 and
mark 2 and finally i have put marks the
method which is going to print mark 1
and mark 2. um finally i have another
class called result and this if you see
this derives from marks now if you see
this relationship you'll notice result
derives from marks whereas marks itself
derives from student and this is an
example of multi-level hierarchy and uh
even as a part of this third class we
have its own methods called calc and put
total
calc will calculate the total as we had
seen earlier and put total will
basically print that total and we're
going to do a very similar operation
we're going to create an instance of
this third class
result and store it in r then we're
going to do basically we're going to set
the student details
his student number and his name we're
going to give him his marks 50 and 60.
we're going to calculate what are the
total we're going to say okay now put
the details of um what is the student's
number and name we're going to also
store enter i mean display his marks
mark 1 and mark 2 and finally we're
going to display the total marks so
let's execute this and if you see it's
basically the similar operation that we
did earlier but the only difference is
in the earlier example our
our third class result was derived from
marx and student together so this was an
example of multiple inheritance whereas
in this example the result class derives
from marx and marx itself derives from
students so this is an example of
multi-level inheritance finally we have
um sorry not finally penultimately we
have um as our fourth example of
inheritance called a hierarchical
inheritance a pardon my mispronunciation
it's hierarchical inheritance so in this
case a base class basically will contain
more than one derived class so let's see
a look at an example of what we mean
here so i have a class called one where
i have defined a method called display
where what i'm going to do is i'm going
to store self.x is equal to 1000 and
self.y is equal to 2000. then what i'm
going to do is i'm going to print a
statement saying this is the method in
class 1. and i'm going to say
after that i'm going to print another
statement saying value of x is a self.x
which is going to be 1000 uh then i'm
gonna have another print statement
saying value of y is self dot y which is
going to be two thousand finally uh i
mean next i have another class called
two this this is going to derive from
class one as you can see here and in
this class two i have defined another
method called add and in this method add
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
first print a statement saying this is
the method in class 2 and then i'm going
to actually print the result of x plus y
which is 1 000 2000. finally i have
another class called three and this is
also deriving from one so if you notice
we have one parent class called one and
from this one parent class we're going
to derive two different subclasses
called two and three so this is an
example of hierarchical inheritance now
in this class 3 what i've done is i've
defined a multiplication method what i'm
going to do is print first of all i'm
going to print this when i invoke this
method that this is the method in class
3 finally i'm going to say i'm going to
print the result of x times y which is
one thousand times two thousand so if
you see i am going to create an instance
of two and i'm going to create an
instance of three and i'm going to store
them in t1 and d2 now since uh t2 i mean
t1 is an instance of two so i can access
its methods add and i can access this
methods display so i'm going to use
t1.display and even in 2
t2 i mean since it's a class
it's an instance of class 3 and this
also derives from class 1 i can also
access its method display but now i
cannot access add but i can access
multiply so if you see here i access add
through t1 instance since add is a part
of class 2 whereas multiply
is a method in class 3 so i access it in
its respective instance which is t2 so
if you see here now once i execute this
what you will get is basically um the
results so first of all it will
basically display the method from
class 1 which is a display method it
will display the values of x and y and
since i've done this twice from two
different instances uh it will basically
show a repetition over here finally i've
done the addition and since this is a
method in class two it is going to say
as much that is the method in class two
and then it's going to say x plus y is
three thousand and now multiply is a
method in the third class so it's going
to say this is a method in class 3 and
it's going to tell me what is the
multiplication result finally we have
what is called hybrid inheritance and
this is a combination of multiple plus
multi-level inheritance that you saw
earlier so
let's again understand this through this
example so we have a class called
student where we have a method called
set student
again two attributes we can pass here
for student number and student name next
we have a another method part of the
class student called put student so this
will print us the student number and
student name next we have a class called
marks and this marks inherits from
student so
we have a method in class marks called
cell set marks where we can pass two
attributes for mark 1 and mark 2
respectively and as we have seen earlier
we also have a put marks which will
display the marks for marks 1 and marks
2. we have a class called practical this
spectacle is basically a another super
class if you see here since this does
not derive from anything it is super
class on its own and what it does is it
it has two methods get practical
and we can
pass an attribute for p1 here and we
store that in self.p1 and then we have
an attribute for
put practical which will print us the
practical mark whatever we passed for
this attribute in p1 finally if you see
we have a class called result now in
this result we have we are going to
derive from marks and practical but if
you notice here marks itself is a
subclass of student so this is an
example of multi-level inheritance
whereas since result derived from marx
and practical both it is also an example
of multiple inheritance so if you see
notice here this is an example of
multiple and multiple level inheritance
which is basically what we call hybrid
inheritance and as we had seen earlier
this result class will have a calc
method to um do a total of the marks um
in this case mark 1 plus mark 2 plus the
practical mark b1 and we have a put
total method which is basically going to
print us the total so now we're going to
create an instance of this result and
through this instance of result we're
going to first invoke the parent class
method called set student which is the
the second level parent basically the
student
the student class
set student method so we're going to set
student here we're going to say 60 is a
student id and name is ash then we have
set marks which is again the the second
level parent which is a student class
where we set the marks finally we access
this get practical now if you notice get
practical is part of
the practical uh super class so in this
we store the third subject or the the
practical marks hundred then we
calculate the total and we put uh first
the student details then we put the
individual marks then we put the
practical marks and finally we enter
what is the total so let's execute this
and if you notice you will see here
student number is 60 student name and
all the basically whatever details we
wanted um is shown over here in this
video we will continue our discussion on
object oriented programming with the
topic of polymorphism now the term
polymorphism in oop refers to the
ability of an object to adapt the code
to the type of data it is processing
polymorphism is one of the key concepts
of python and it is also a built-in
feature of python an example to get us
started on polymorphism would be how we
use the plus operator we use the plus
operator not only for arithmetic
additions but we also use the plus
operator for stuff like string
concatenations or joining two lists
together this example where we're able
to use the plus operator for different
different operations is an example of
polymorphism to show you what i mean i
have basically done a simple addition
operation here where i'm adding two
variables number one and number two when
i do it on integers it basically adds
one plus two now when i use it on two
strings str1 and str2 which contains
python and programming two separate
strings and when i use the plus operator
on these you can see what it does here
it forms um one string containing both
of these individual strings so this is
basically the plus operator showing
polymorphism and is one of the simplest
occurrences and yet most common
occurrences of polymorphism in python
another example of polymorphism would be
through the lens function the lens
function in python is something that we
use a lot and over multiple data types
depending on the data type that we use
the length function for we get a
different value or a different
sort of information from the length
function now if you see here from this
diagram when we use the length function
on a string it gives us the length of
the string when we use the length
function on a list it gives us the
number of items whereas if we use the
length function on a dictionary it gives
us the number of keys so this is well
another example of how we have
polymorphism in a function now what
we're going to do is look at the
different techniques through which we
can enable polymorphisms in our code our
first example that we are going to look
at is through method overloading now
method overloading in its traditional
sense where we can have a method with
the same name more than one method with
the same name in the same class is
not exactly possible in python so if we
have multiple methods with the same name
in a class in python which may differ in
in types and number of arguments are not
allowed and not supported in python in
fact if we did something like this where
we created a method with um different uh
with different say types and number and
arguments but having the same name um in
the same class then what python will do
is it will only recognize the the last
defined method and it will
not recognize any of the earlier methods
with the same name but we can simulate
polymorphism through method overloading
by using default arguments in a method
now for example what i'm going to show
you here is an example where i have a
method called sum now by default uh it
has three attributes that you can pass
through this method a does not have a
default value b does not have a default
value but if you notice c has a default
value 0. so this is a simple example
where i'm going to show you that the sum
method is
going to be used in two different cases
in one case we're going to simply add
two digits uh i mean two numbers and in
another case we're going to use the sum
method to add three different numbers so
we have this class overload demo within
it a method sum and i have three
attributes a and b are
have uh are supposed to be given by the
user since they don't have a since they
do not have any default values whereas c
has a default value of zero so if you
see here in my first case i have uh i
first of all created a an instance
called over uh an instance called od for
the class overload demo and i have what
i'm going to do is i'm going to store
the value of the sum of 7 and 8 in the
variable sum now if you see here i have
not passed a third argument so what this
method is going to do is it's going to
take the value of c as zero by default
so it's basically going to do uh seven
plus eight and it's going to give us the
sum for seven plus eight and in the next
instance i'm going to give three
arguments seven eight and nine so now c
will be replaced by nine instead of zero
and then i'm going to get the sum of
seven eight and nine so in this this is
a not a very used uh not a very commonly
used thing uh but it's basically a
method just to show you that we can
actually simulate method overloading in
python by using default arguments so
i've basically shown you how the same
how the same method sum has been used to
do the addition of two digits and then
in another instance is doing the
addition of three digits it might look
very similar but
you'll basically notice that by having
this third attribute c i have a default
value of zero i have induced some form
of polymorphism through method
overloading now the next way that we can
induce polymorphism is through
inheritance which is called method
overriding as well now method overriding
gives us the ability to change the way
or the change the implementation of a
method in a child class which is defined
already
in one of its superclasses now if there
is a method in a superclass the method
having the same name and same number of
arguments in a child class
then the child class method is going to
override the method in the parent class
so what we do is when a method is called
with the parent class object the method
of the parent class will be executed
whereas if we call the method using the
child class object the method of the
child class will be executed executed
and it will override the method in the
parent class so the appropriate overhead
in method is called uh is called based
on the object type which is an example
of polymorphism so let's look at an
example to understand this so we have a
class called person and we have defined
what we're going to define the
initializer is two attributes which we
have to pass called name and age and
we're going to store them in self.name
and self.h now we have a user defined
method called displaydata where we are
going to print if this display data has
been called through the parent called
person if it's going to be called
through the parent class object then
we're going to print in parent class
display method and then we're going to
print the name and age that we have
entered now we have another
class called employee which is going to
be a derived class 1 person so it's
going to um so it's also going to have
an
initializer and this constructor will
basically um what what this initializer
will have is it'll have an uh
constructor for the superclass where
we're going to do this uh the same
initialization that we do in the super
class but we're also going to store
another attribute called id in
self.employeeid and if you see here we
also have another method called
displaydata which is the same named
method from person but now if you see in
display data i have every i have all the
same almost the same information i'm
going to print the name i'm going to
print the age but if you see the first
statement i'm going to say if i'm going
to call this method from the employee
object then i'm going to say in child
class display data method instead of in
parent class display data method to say
that basically i'm invoking this method
from the child class object and i'm also
going to print on top of the whatever
i'm printing before i'm also going to
print the employee id so if you see here
i have created an object called person
which is
an object of the class person with the
information of name john and age 40 and
then i'm going to display this now next
i'm going to create an object called emp
which is the child class employee object
which is going to uh now have the same
information of john for the name and age
40 but now is going to have an employee
id and then i'm going to store this
in amp and i'm going to display the data
for this child class object and we will
see the difference in how the display
data is differing from the earlier
earlier case so when i execute this you
see the in the first case it says in
parent class display data method so this
display data has been called through the
parent class object and i'm only going
to show the information of name and age
whereas when i invoke this method from
the employee class object it's going to
say it's going to specifically say that
it's a in child class display method and
then i'm going to say the name is and
also the employee id over here so this
is the difference between how display
data has been used in its parent and its
child class and this is basically the
example of method overriding now our
next example of polymorphism
is going to be through operator
overloading an operator overloading is
the ability to overload the operator to
provide extra functionality in
additional to its real or core operation
and operator overloading is also an
example of polymorphism as the same
operator can perform different actions
the earlier example of where we use the
plus operator for different operations
is an example of operator overloading
polymorphism now when um when when is
operator overloading required well
anytime you want an operator to perform
a different function for you in your
custom objects you would basically do
operator overloading now an example of
this would be what i'm going to show you
below so if you see this class called
point it has an initializer where i'm
going to store two attributes x and y in
sub dot x and y and septa uh instep.x
and self.y now i'm going to create one
object called p1 where i'm going to
create point one and two so you can
think of this object as basically like a
coordinate x coordinate one y coordinate
two this is one point and another point
called uh x coordinate three x one four
i'm gonna call that p two now i want to
print p one plus p two all right now if
i try to execute this you will notice an
error it says unsupported operand types
for plus point and point this basically
means that plus does not know what to do
when it's given an object of this type
it has no idea what to do whereas what
we wanted to do is add the the the x
coordinate from this point and the x
coordinate from this point so we wanted
to do one plus three and we also wanted
to do this y coordinate plus this y
coordinate or two plus four and then we
want to print basically like something
like four comma six or the addition of
the two points
or the the vector addition of these two
points so this is what we want this plus
operator to do but the python does not
have any inbuilt feature for the plus
operator and we are going to have to
basically do some operator overloading
to create a polymorphism on this so
let's see how we can do that so to do
that first of all we have to understand
that all operators in python have
internally defined methods to provide
functionality for these operators the
operator or the special method to
provide functionality for the plus
operator in python is the add method and
whenever the plus operator is used we
are basically internally internally
invoking the add method so uh these
these sort of internal methods that
provide functionality for the operators
are part of a big a bigger class of
methods known as magic methods and these
magic methods are automatically invoked
whenever its corresponding operators are
used so we want to change the or the
operation for
the plus operator in this example we are
going to have to use the the add method
in this case and since it's a magic
method uh magic methods are also
are basically what we saw earlier in the
in the form of dunder methods so magic
methods are going to be invoked using a
double underscore uh a prefix and suffix
to it so similarly to how we defined an
init of an init method or an hdr method
we are going to also invoke the add
method using the same double underscore
before and after its name so now let's
see how we're going to do this so if you
see this class i have now my class point
and i have the same initializer when i'm
going to store x and y now i am going to
define on
this this add magic method i am going to
override the the normal functionality of
plus and i'm going to give it a very
specific function where i'm going to say
um for two two different objects you're
going to add its
the first part the first part or its so
called x coordinate with the other x
coordinate and it the y coordinate with
the other y coordinate and you need to
return return this to me in the form of
a similar object so now when i pass one
and two and three and four it should
return me four and six as you can see
here i have basically done what i wanted
to do by operator overloading i have
changed or i have overloaded this add
this plus operator using this add magic
method and i have created a new
functionality for this add function for
these two points one and two three and
four now i'm able to add one comma two
three comma four in the way i want it to
so now that you saw how we did operator
overloading i'm just going to show you
a list of similar magic methods for
different operators that we are familiar
with so the plus operator already we've
seen has the add method then we have the
minus operator with the sub method and
similarly we have for all of these
operations such as multiplication
division we have its respective magic
methods these magic methods are again
prefixed with two underscores and suffix
with two underscores and they are
basically they are also called uh
dunder's in python so this is how we
would do operator overloading in python
for whatever operator we want similarly
we can do this for like comparison
operators and for unary operators as
well so look at this example now where
i'm going to overload the multiplication
or the asterisk operator so i've again
defined a point i mean a class called
point i'm going to define an initializer
but i'm going to store some attribute x
and self.x now what i'm going to do is
i'm going to overload the multiplication
operator where i'm going to basically
allow the uh this asterix operator to
multiply two objects uh from like for
example 12 and five usually i can just
do a normal 12 times five but in this
case my object is slightly different my
12 is being passed through an object of
a class called point and five as well in
another uh instance of the same class
now when i want to multiply these class
instances like the the multiplication
operator does not perceive these class
instances to be integer so by default it
would not be able to multiply what we
want to multiply but when we define um
or we overload the multiplication
operator within our class it's now able
to understand what to do um using the
attributes of these classes in its
respective uh class instances so it's
able to say okay so i want this
attribute from this particular instance
p1 12 and i'm going to multiply it with
the attribute 5 from instance p2
whenever i say p1 times p2 or p2 p1
astrix p2 so when i execute it it will
give me 12 times 5. similarly i can also
do this for the greater than operator
over here so i have a class called
person where i'm going to define an
initializer where i'm going to pass name
and salary and store them in sub.name
server.salary the
gt method is basically the greater than
method magic method and it's going to uh
we're going to use this to overload the
greater than operator and now again
using this greater than operator i'm
able to basically say object one greater
than object two and i'm basically able
to check through this and if object one
is greater than object two it will
basically tell us if it is true or false
or uh basically whatever like we want to
know so basically the print statement
will check for object one dot name and
it will say earns more than object two
dot name if in case object one is indeed
greater than object two so when i
execute this you can see here my first
information says john has is earning 4
500 some units natasha is earning 6000
of some units so it will say uh john
earns more than natasha well it's false
because object one is not greater than
object two so
since 4500 is not actually greater than
6000 and this is the check that i'm
doing by overloading the gt operator
over here where i'm so where i'm
returning the boolean value of uh what
is greater self.salary or other dot
salary self being the first
object in any comparison so in the if
i'm basically any comparison if i'm
doing say if i'm doing 5 greater than 5
greater than 6 so what the gt will do is
this will be the self object and this
will be the other object so this is what
i'm doing over here i'm checking
self.salary with other dot salary in in
the form of these objects and it's
basically the same same way that we we
are able to do five plus five through
these class instance objects that you
saw earlier or 12 times five that you
saw earlier so this is
all examples of operator overloading in
python in this video we will be taking a
brief introduction into what is a
function so a function in python is a
group of related statements that
performs a specific task or tasks now
functions help break our program into
smaller and modular pieces of code and
it's very good and very
convenient to use functions to make
our code organized and manageable
especially as our overall program grows
larger it also helps us to avoid
repetition and makes the code reusable
so let's look at the basic way of
defining a function so this is a basic
function that i'm calling fun
underscored name all right
now the rest of the function or whatever
the task is going to be performed by
this function will be my written over
here within indent of course as a
standard when it comes to python so i'm
going to define this one
something in triple uh double quotes so
don't worry about what this is right now
this is
a doc string don't worry about what this
means and i'll explain it to you just in
a short bit all right
now now the rest of the statement the
rest of it
will obviously be what this function
will do let's include a simple print
statement all right that's uh
done here let's call this
so of course now once you define the
statement function to call the function
you just have to use its name like this
this is how you call a function so as
you can see when i call this function it
should print the statement hello now
let's go let's uh look at some of the uh
like what happened over here so we've
used the keyword def to define a
function we give it a unique name which
makes it uh which with which we uniquely
identify this function
and also once we've done this we
we can give it we can give this function
a particular header
it's called a docstring so what this
docstring is basically something that we
include in triple quotes over here just
after the
def keyword and um this is like a brief
we can use this to give a brief uh and
give brief information into whatever
function is doing so we can say this is
this function performs addition this
performs um
subtraction or whatever like some basic
information as to what our function does
so we can use a dog string for that um
of course this is an optional thing this
does not have to be we don't have to
include this as well all right but for
the sake of this let's just keep it here
after that of course rest of the
function uh will contain whatever tasks
we want to do with it and that will be
indented
finally we can also include a return
keyword and what the return keyword does
is
at any point you find the return keyword
in a function you immediately leave the
function you go back to where this
function was called okay so
now let's see
now there's also one more important
component of defining a function and
that's parameter now if you noticed over
here within these parentheses i did not
include anything this is like an empty
parenthesis opening and closing what if
i said a if i included some a and b over
here so what this means is whenever i
call this function i need to pass two
parameters a and b these can be like
strings or numbers or whatever um but
now it becomes almost mandatory that i
pass these two things for my function to
uh to work so let's define a function
where i'm going to add a and b so
instead of this print statement let's do
this i create a variable c and in that
i'm storing a plus b all right and then
i return c so you can use a return and
you can you you can return certain like
variables along with the return
statement so i'm saying not only return
from this function but also give an
output or return an output called c
which is the addition of a and b now how
do we use this well now instead of just
calling the function like this i'm going
to add better i'm going to include
parameters so i'm saying pass 2 and 3 to
function name where 2 will take the
place of a and 3 will take the place of
b all right what will happen now is
addition will take place and we will get
return the result so let's see what
happens now as you can see two plus
three and i got the written the addition
of two plus three and it returned me
five so yeah this was like a basic uh
usage of a function and parameters so
of course uh we can if you want to know
like what a what the
doc string of a particular function does
or or cells uh you can use this uh
particular you can use this like
statement so let's say if so uh it's
very important to like just keep a note
in your uh
while you're going through this so while
you're learning that uh whenever we use
some sort of a function which has double
uh underscore right this is like a built
in a built-in command provided by python
um within the python library itself so
these are like built-in commands to
check certain details so i want to check
what is the docs string and this is how
i do it so let's do print let's print
what is the docs string over here this
is a dock string so this is basically
what i wrote over here i can change this
to this
like this does
addition for example all right now this
will say this does addition when i
execute this line so this is the way to
check what is a dog string anyways so
now that you have seen a basic
basic function or two basic functions
that i defined for you and how we use
them what a parameter is let's look at
another concept that we call scope and
lifetime of variables so scope of
variable is the portion of the program
where the variable is recognized all
right now a parameter and a variable
that are
defined inside a function are not
visible from outside the function this
is a very key thing so if we define
something within the function we can
only use it within this function and we
cannot like we cannot use it once the
function has already been executed so as
to speak um
these variables and these parameters uh
have what we call as local scope since
they are only um recognized within a
particular function now the lifetime of
a variable is the period throughout
which the variable exists in the memory
itself and it's very important to note
that lifetime of variables that are
defined inside a function um are as long
as the function executes um once we
return from a function
whatever we have defined within it are
destroyed so when we use a function it
will not remember the values of a
variable from a previous iteration of a
function call so let's uh try to
understand this example or this concept
using certain examples so
out here i have defined a function where
i'm going to create a variable my
underscore var my variable and i am
going to store the value 10 in this and
then i'm going to print so whenever i
call this function i will always create
this variable i will store 10 and i will
print the value of this all right now
what i'm going to do is i'm not only
going to create this myvar inside this
function i'm also going to create a
variable outside so you see there now
you might be confused as to okay how is
the behavior going to be because outside
the function i have created my var with
a value 20 but inside the function i
will always define my virus 10 okay now
i'm going to print so my first what i'm
going to first do is i'm going to
execute this function that i created
initially where i store the value of 10
in my bar and then i'm going to pray and
print the value of my wire that was
present outside the function let's see
what happens you can see two different
things happening so when i execute this
function it prints the value inside the
function as 10 but when i print the next
line which says
ok now get the value of my var
it actually prints a value of 20. and
this is a very key concept because
what's happening here is when i
initially call my function within this
function it creates a variable called
myvar and it prints the value as 10 and
the moment my function has been executed
it destroys this variable and
the variable which contain the value 10
is of course now destroyed and all we
have is the my wire that contains 20
from the outside and when we print that
we get its respective value as 20. so
you can also think of it like this the
my wire that is present inside this
function is different to the mywad that
we create outside so the scope of the
mywire within this function is local
only to this function and once the
function is executed that variable is
destroyed all right now let's look at a
another case or the other side of this
case where um say we're dealing with
variables that have a global scope how
do we deal with them so let's create a
variable called mywear all right and i
say i stored 100 in this all right now
if i define a function i've stored my
let's say i define a function define
underscore say again same name where
what i'm going to do in this is i am
going to print the value of whatever is
there in my where okay so let's do print
um
value of
variable is value stored in variable
is
okay that's
my where so let's see what happens when
we do this let's call this function
underscore name see what happens here so
as you can see the value i stored a
value of 100 in y where and i've called
it inside the function and this is
because since i've defined it outside i
can use it inside as well now what if i
try to change the value of
this variable inside the function though
so let's see
if i did this and now if i try to print
let's see do is this allowed no it's not
allowed in fact i get an error it says
local variable myvar reference
before assignment
and without going too much into detail
what it's saying is that the variable
inside over here is still local to this
function and i have not defined this
myware as a global variable so i cannot
make changes to it within this function
right now and uh to change that i can
use the global keyword what if i did
global over here so if i did global and
now if i said okay global mywear and i
declare this variable as a global
variable now if i do this now if i do
the same incrementation now let's see
what happens when i'm trying to do this
you see i get the value 101 it's exactly
what i wanted and that is because i've
defined my variable to be a global
variable within this function so i can
in fact make changes to it within this
function so this is how we use the
global keyword and global variable
also just to make a quick note um there
are three types of functions uh the
three types of categories in which we
can divide functions first one being
built-in functions these are the ones
that are built into the standard library
of python the other is user defined
function that is the ones which we
define ourselves and the third type is
called anonymous functions they're also
known as lambda functions and this is
something that we're going to cover in a
separate video now let's talk about the
arguments that we pass in python so
there are four types of arguments that
python user defined functions can take
first one being default other one is
required then there is keyword and then
there is variable number of arguments so
the default argument is when say um if i
define the function where underscore
sorry fun underscore name and i'm saying
a comma b right but what if um the user
has not um like say i i want a default
value of a and b each time when i use
this function so in the case where if
say i don't pass a value for a and b
like this will always be used so i can
just say a is equal to 2 by default and
b is equal to 3 by default and then
within this function i will say c is
equal to a plus b and then return c
so i do this and if i say found
underscore name and in case i don't pass
any arguments here let's see what
happens by default i get the answer 5
because by default a is 2 and b is 3 but
this is not fixed and i can always
change this by passing my own values
here 5 and 6 and in this case i should
get 11 as you can see here now the next
type is required arguments and when we
are defining a required argument we just
simply do not use the equal to sign for
the parameters over here and this
basically um it makes it so that now
anytime we call this function we have to
pass something over here now if i try to
pass like this i won't get a oops yeah i
won't get a default value then that's
because um
that's because well there's no default
value and it needs an a and b so i have
to pass it a three and say four now it
should give me seven as you can see the
next type of argument that we'll be
talking about are the variable number of
arguments so let's look at an example
here so what i'm doing in this
particular example is i'm defining a
function called my sum where i'm passing
some parameter called my integers and
i'm doing something out here and what
this does is um it will take the values
of a particular like collection of
objects and that's called my integers
and each value i'm going to keep adding
it to each other and i'm going to result
a particular sum i'm just going to
resolve the sum of whatever is there so
in this case what happens is i'm
creating a list
one two and three which contains one two
and three and then i'm going to print
the summation of whatever is there so it
should give me six now the problem in
this case is that each time when i'm
going to perform this function i have to
create a separate list where i'm going
to store these objects but what if i
didn't i do not know like what exactly
i'm going to pass here what if i don't
know if it's going to be a list of
objects or like what is it going to be
exactly well in that case i can use a
variable uh variable uh key variable
number of arguments so it's like a
variable keyword argument so what we use
here is um
a specific way of passing
keywords and we do it like this so i say
define my under underscore name and i
use an asterisk now i give it any name
this can be args this can be integers it
doesn't really matter what this is but
it's just this is the key the asterisk
here and this tells us that whatever we
pass here is now if we're supposed to
create an iterable out of this and then
we can perform whatever task we want so
let's just uh since i have already
created one here let's see how i'm going
to use it in this case
so as you can see i'm doing uh i'm
creating a particular
variable argument function over here and
i'm doing the same task i'm just going
to keep performing edit uh i'm going to
add whatever i pass over here but now
when i'm calling this function i don't
need to create a separate list as i did
over here i'm just passing all the
numbers that i want to in the form of
like it's pretty much like a tuple so
i'm just passing these numbers here and
what this function is going to do is is
going to create an iterable out of this
and then we're going to iterate over it
as you can see that's happening over
here and i can keep uh i don't need i i
can just keep like
so since i've done it for 1 2 3 and 7
the summation should be 13 in this case
i can add another number here just
explicitly just like this and you can
see the value will change and that's
because this is a variable uh this is a
variable argument uh method of uh
perform creating a function now the
fourth type of function arguments is the
variable keyword uh
argument so let's look at what is the
keyword argument now so i have defined a
function here called the concatenate
function and let's see what i'm going to
do with this so in this i have passed a
keyword argument i've said that okay
this is going to be a keyword argument
function and what i'm going to do in
this is i'm going to create a blank
string and what i'm going to do is i'm
going to add
or i'm going to concatenate certain
strings that i'm going to pass to this
function so i
in this example i have passed python and
is and cool and an exclamation mark all
separate strings and what i'm going to
do in this function is i'm going to join
them together um and i'm going to create
one whole string out of it let's see
what's the result python is cool so this
is so of course like uh if i had to add
some something else like python is say
cool and say i just wanted to say hello
and say one more string i can add i can
add it just like this i don't have to
like define a fixed number of arguments
i can pass any number of arguments i
want and this works exactly the same as
variable and
only differences instead of positional
arguments we're using keyword arguments
over here hello bye like this doesn't
really make sense but just to show you
as you can see so this is how we use
keyword arguments in this video we will
be learning about exceptions exceptions
uh errors that are raised during the
execution of a program when an
error occurs python generates this
exception that can be handled uh which
avoids our program from crashing python
has many built-in exceptions
however we can create many uh
defined errors or exceptions as well to
catch whatever errors we're looking for
in our program so when an error occurs
python interpreter raises an
exception and stops the current process
and it passes it to a calling process
until the exception is handled and if
this is not handled the program will
crash
some of the
built-in exceptions are like io error in
the case when a file cannot be opened or
import error python cannot find the
particular module being imported and
there are so many similar uh so many
exceptions that are built in python for
the appropriate cases now before we move
on and see how we raise these exceptions
um let's look at the difference between
an exception and a syntax error so for
that i will be using an example where i
will be dividing something by the number
zero of course this is not possible so
let's see how python handles this
particular problem well it raises
something that it raises what we call a
zero division error and this is an
exception that is built in in python
whenever we try to divide something by
zero now let's look at the difference
between this exception and a syntax
error so this is the same statement
except i'm going to add this extra
bracket which does not make sense
syntactically in this now if i try to
execute this as you can see we get a
different type of error known as the
syntax error and it says unmatched
closing bracket so this is what a syntax
error looks like like an extra bracket
or a comma
that basically makes the line unreadable
to the interpreter in the first place so
the the interpreter doesn't even get to
the point where it needs to figure out
uh that there's something being divided
by zero it doesn't even get to that
point because it finds this extra
bracket and it cannot execute this line
at all so that is like the difference
between an
exception and a syntax error all right
now for our first case of how we raise
or how we handle exceptions let's look
at
the keyword raise so for this example
what i will be doing is i'm going to
take this variable x all right and i'm
going to store a value 10 and what i'm
going to do is i'm going to check for a
condition if x is greater than 5 then
i'm going to raise this exception using
the raised keyword like this and in case
this condition is met if x is actually
greater than 5 i want this particular
message to play out in my
exception so let's see what happens when
i execute this as you can see the
exception is raised because x is indeed
greater than 5 its value is 10 and the
mirror message says so that x should not
exceed 5 the value of x was 10. so this
is an example of how we can raise an
exception and as you can see when a
condition was met the program comes to a
halt and an exception was raised now
let's look at another type of handling
exception where we use the assert
statement so when we use the raise
command we waited until an error
occurred and our program crashed midway
right what if we want to check if a
condition is met and if this condition
is met then then the program can
continue but if the condition turns out
to be false then we want a particular
error namely the assertion error
exception to be thrown to us so we can
use the assert command in such a case so
in our example we will be checking um
whether the system that we are working
on is actually linux or windows 32 so
let's see first of all let's import a
library called sys this is the it's a
library which where we can access system
information one of the modules and that
is uh one of the functions and that is
the platform it basically tells us what
system are we working on so we're
working on a win32 system okay so um
let's now let's use the assert keyword
all right now we're going to check if
linux is what we are working on and in
case it is not then we want an error
message and this will be the error the
error will obviously be an assertion
error because we are using the assert
keyword
so this is uh how we use the assert
statement and if we execute this as you
can see we get the assertion error
because systor platform contains win32
and not linux and so we got this
assertion error so if we change this to
check for windows system we won't have
any error when we execute this as you
can see so this is the example where we
use the assert statement
another way of handling exceptions is by
using the try and accept block so this
is probably one of the most common ways
of handling exceptions in python
where we
use a try keyword and an accept keyword
now within the try keyword as you can
see here we have a chunk of code which
we're going to check and if everything
is fine in the try keyword then this is
perfect so we don't need to move on to
what we call the accept part of the
try and accept block but if say there
was an error in the try block then we
move on to the accept block where we're
going to run the
part of the code in the case we find an
error in the try block so first we check
the
part of the code that is under the try
block and if if there is an error we
move on to the accept block and we run
that part of the code over there and
where we and in the except block where
we that is where we handle our whatever
error that might get thrown our way in
the try block okay let's look at an
example at how to uh use this technique
so i have a basic function out here all
right it's defining a function called
linux interaction what this is uh
basically doing is that when i call this
function i want to do an assert check
i'm going to check if linux is the
system i'm working on and if it is not
then i want this error to be thrown okay
and
so yeah let's see what happens in the
case and if if this search statement is
actually passed then we will move on to
the statement so you could look at it
like this if whenever i mean when i call
this function it will first check for
this search statement in case something
wrong happens and we get an assert error
then we do not move on to this line so
we only get this printed but if this
assert statement passes then we move on
to this line and we get print doing
something okay so let's see now i'm
going to call this function out here
let's see what happens here as you can
see i get an assertion error because
obviously this is a window system and
not a linux system and i get this
message okay now let's see what happens
when we use it in a try and accept block
all right so now i have a try block over
here in which i am going to try the same
this function linux underscore
interaction if in case i find an error i
immediately jump from the try block into
the accept block now you see the slight
difference in how we handle this like
what happens so as you can see when we
use the function explicitly we directly
went to what we call an assertion error
but when we use a try and accept block
we will not use the assertion error
because we are leaving the try block
immediately and we are going to go into
the accept block where the only thing
we're doing is printing the statement as
you can see we are not on linux found
some error okay now what if we wanted to
catch the error within uh this function
itself which was the assertion error and
we can do that explicit layer like this
so now what i'm doing is i'm going to
try all right and it's going to catch an
error in this slide so now in the accept
block i'm going to say the assertion
error that we found in this function in
the try block we're going to use that in
our accept block so as you can see we're
going to print that assertion error it
will basically print this statement
function can only run on linux systems
as you can see here function can only
run on linux systems function can only
run on linux systems and
the next part of the thing was the linux
interaction function was not executed
okay so this is um a very this is like
um this is a key there's a key something
very important happening here when we
use this assert statement the whole
program is actually getting executed
right but when we're using the try and
accept block we are immediately jumping
on like the moment we catch an error we
are immediately jumping onto the accept
statement and uh however and all the
handling of the exception is done in the
accept block and not in the try block
anymore so we do uh think of it like
this that the try block is only to check
if a particular piece of code is uh like
does it have any errors or not and in
case it does then every uh like all the
handling that we do is uh in the accept
block of this particular statement now
let's look at another example in this
example i'm going to try opening a
particular file now this file does not
exist so i will be i will get a file not
found error and this is a built-in
exception and i'm going to catch that
and i'm going to print that error over
here in the accept block all right so as
you can see file not found and whatever
like error i have i printed over here
all right so this is another like this
is a file not found error that we are
going to that we we caught in our try
block and we're handling it in the
except block now let's use let's combine
both of the examples where we use this
linux interaction and we also try to
open a particular file and we try to do
both things in the try block and since
both of these contain errors let's see
what happens when we try to what happens
when we have like multiple errors in a
try block so as you can see in my try
block i'm not only doing this linux
interaction i'm also trying to open a
particular file that does not exist
obviously so now you might think will i
get two exceptions well let's see what
happens when we try to uh execute this
so uh it's important to note that in our
accept we have an except for uh catching
a file not found error and we also have
an except for finding
the assertion error that that is part of
this linux interaction function so so
since both of these
are erroneous statements or they will
throw exceptions so now the question is
will we get both of these except blocks
or will we get both of these exceptions
will we get only one of them that we get
the first one so let's see what happens
so as you can see my error statement is
is very much like the assertion error
that i had that we had done as part of
this linux underscore interaction
function function can only run on linux
systems the linux function was not
executed as you can see that that is the
one that has been caught and for some
reason the file not found error has not
been caught and this is because this is
a very important feature of the try
block the moment we find the first error
in our try block we immediately leave
and we do not execute any of the further
statements and we jump into the
exceptions and we handle it using the
accept blocks so the moment an error was
found in this function we did not
execute this part of the statement and
we directly jumped into the respective
exception that was the assertion error
exception so this is a key takeaway so
some of the some of the other key
takeaways when it comes to exceptions is
a try clause is executed up until the
point where the first exception is
encountered and in the accept clause or
the exception handler we determine how
the program responds to this exception
we can have multiple exceptions and we
can differentiate how the program uh
responds to each of these and it's also
very important to not use uh accept
clause on its own it's very important
not to use a bear accept clause now
finally before we conclude this topic of
exceptions let's look at the else and
the finally clause so the else clause is
used when we want to execute a
particular piece of code in the case
where we have no exceptions or no errors
found so let's look at this just like we
have the linux interaction function i'm
going to define a win under underscore
interaction and this is going to check
whether our system is windows or not in
case it is not then we get this error
message all right and in case it is a
windows of uh in the window system we
print this in the case of when we call
this function so let's again use our try
and accept statement only in this case
we will be using an extra else clause so
we first try this function in case
there's an error we catch it as an
assertion error and we print that error
but if there is no exception then we
move on to the else statement and we
print this so as you can see our
we have actually moved on to the else
statement and we print this line
executing the else clause and that is
because we have found no exceptions over
here so again it's key to remember that
the else clause is used whenever we want
to execute a particular statement in the
case where we do not find any exceptions
in the try block the finally clause is
used when we want to execute something
regardless of
whether we have an error or an exception
or not so no matter if an exception
happens i mean is raised or if it's not
raised we want this finally block to
always get executed and let's look at
how it's let's look at an example of it
being used so i have this block where
i'm doing a lot of things the first
thing that i'm doing is i'm going to
check for this linux interaction
function which is going to check of
course whether it's a linear system or
not this is i'm doing the try block now
if i catch an error i want to be i want
to handle it by simply printing the
error over here and in the event that uh
there is no error then i will move on to
the else statement and i will try uh
this particular block of my statement
which is again that when i'm trying to
read a particular file that does not
exist and it's very uh it's very
important
that you note that within the else block
i have another try and accept block and
this is perfectly legal and is perfectly
valid in our program we can do this so
think of it like this i'm first trying
this if i have an error then i do this
and i don't
execute this but if i don't have an
error then i execute this whole
statement which contains its own try and
accept block all right but regardless of
whether i get an error here or not
i will always execute this portion of my
statement or under the finally clause
let's execute this as you can see of
course the error is raised in this try
this try block so we move on to the
exception and that is what is printed
over here and after the exception is
done we move on to the finally we of
course skip this else block because the
exception was actually raised so after
that is done we move on to the finally
block where we print this
particular statement well that was it
for an introduction into exceptions in
python i hope you learned something from
this and um of course this is just the
beginning exceptions are something that
you will be that you would probably
encounter a lot especially when you're
beginning and it's something that you
will learn to extensively work with and
that will also help you improve in your
programming in this video we will be
covering the topic of iterators now an
iterator in python is an object that
contains a countable number of values or
it's a larger object that contains a
countable number of sub-objects an
iterator is an object that can be
iterated upon and what that means is we
can traverse from each value and we can
manipulate or perform certain functions
or operations and tasks using each of
the
sub objects or values within this larger
collection called iterator now
when we're looking at it technically an
iterator is an object which implements
the iterator protocol in python which
consists of the methods eter and the
method next so to begin with let's look
at a simple iterator we're going to see
the example of a list where we're going
to traverse through
the objects of a list using the for loop
so we have objects one two three four
and i'm going to print each of these
values one by one as you can see here
similarly we can also do the same thing
for another iterable known as the string
where we can go character by character
again using the for loop as you can see
here
another example of
an iterable in python is
the dictionary so let's say i have a
dictionary where i have two values two
key value pairs uh key x which contains
the value 1 and key y which corresponds
to the value 2. now when i'm going to do
a for loop through this by default i
will be traversing through the keys x
and y as you can see over here and of
course
the other types of weight troubles in
python are like sets and tuples as well
all right now let's look at um
what this iterating protocol is in
python so first of all we take an
iterable it's an object that contains uh
it's a collection of objects that
contain sub-objects and when we use the
eater function it creates an iterator
out of it so we can one by one we can
traverse through
each of the objects and we can
manipulate each of the objects that is
contained in this and anytime we want to
move to the next object we use the next
function and when we have finally
completed all of the or we've
manipulated or traversed through each of
the sub objects we encountered the stop
iteration exception which tells us okay
there are no more objects to be
manipulated or
iterated upon so and as an example i
will create a list where
i will store the values
some simple values integers one two
three four one three four five okay um
i'm going to create an iterator out of
this where i will use the iter function
and i'm going to say this is let's say
this is called my
my editor okay
and
i'm going to use iter function as i had
mentioned and i'm going to pass my list
in this
now if you see what is my iter
it should say it should be a list
iterator at a particular memory location
now let's use the next function to keep
going through whatever is there in this
so of course the first object should be
one as you can see
now when i look at the next it should be
three then i should get four and now i
should get five as i use the next uh
successively now since i've reached the
last of my objects in this collection
now the next time i use this next
function i should get a stop
stop iteration exception that is raised
as you can see here so this is the basic
iteration protocol in python now you
might have uh already gone through the
for loop video and in that i have spoken
in quite a bit of detail as to how a for
loop performs this um this iterator
protocol and how it creates an iterative
iterable object out of say a list or a
tuple and how we how it internally
performs the next function and it um
breaks out of the for loop once it
encounters the stop iteration exception
so
um for loops are like they're very very
similar to your standard iterator and
they use pretty much the same protocol
for its functioning now um let's do a
basic comparison of what is a a basic
comparison between a generator and an
iterator in python so in generator we
use a function we use like we define it
using the def keyword and we define it
under one function to create a generator
whereas in the case of iterators we use
two separate functions the iter function
and the next function
the generator makes use of the yield
keyword whereas the python iterator does
not
in generators we save the states of the
local variables each time we use the
yield keyword and we pause the loop
temporarily whereas in iterators we do
not make use of any local variables all
we need is an iterable like a list
to iterate upon
we may use any number of yield
statements in generators and we do not
use yield statements any educators
generators are not memory efficient
whereas iterators are very memory
efficient so this is like basic
comparison between generators and
iterators in this video we will be
covering the topic of modules in python
now a module in python to put it simply
is basically a python file that has
functions and classes written into it
and is saved with the dot py extension
to specify that it is indeed a python
file a python program can use one or
more modules and modules can have one or
more functions they basically help us
organize our code and instead of having
one like one long python file we can
have several files for several modules
now my modular programming is the
process of breaking a large
a large event or task into smaller and
more manageable subtasks and we call
these sub tasks basically modules now
individual modules can be grouped
together like building blocks to create
a larger optic application there are
several advantages to modulizing code in
a large application and we will be going
through them right now so first of all
there is simplicity because instead of
focusing on a big big problem a big task
we can break down the problem into
smaller smaller portions or modules now
maintainability of code is much better
through modules because they are
designed to create these sort of
boundaries or
clear demarcations between different
problem domains um there is usability
usability uh in the sense that once we
create a module we can use it in
different parts of the code or even
different different applications itself
there is also scoping and what this
means is modules typically define a
separate namespace and this helps us
avoid collisions between identifiers in
different areas of a program functions
modules and packages are basically all
constructs in python that promote code
module modularization you might have
already come across
a gotten an intro into functions in this
video we will be going through modules
in another video we will also cover the
topic of packages to import a module we
use the import keyword and in this
example what i'm going to show you is a
simple function or a simple operation of
importing the os module
this is short for operating system and
as the name suggests we can perform
system tasks through the functions and
methods that are part of this os module
so simply executing the statement will
import this module onto our program for
us to use now if we wanted to see all
the functions that are present in a
module what we have to do is use the dir
function so if we print the dir os
function it will print us basically a
directory of all the functions that are
present in the os module as you can see
here that like all of these are
basically uh names to different
functions that are part of the os module
finally moving on another function
commonly used with modules is the get
cwd function and what this does is it
will give us the current working uh
directory that we are working upon right
now so if i execute this it will tell me
what is the directory that i am
currently working upon right now as you
can see seed notebook dir slash 10. if
we wanted to see all the files in a
particular directory what we can do is
use the list dir function followed by
giving a path by default if we do not
enter a path inside the parenthesis it
will basically give us all the files in
the current working directory which in
our case is temp so if i were to execute
this it gives basically gives me a list
of all the files that are presently uh
there in the directory that i am
currently working upon now a basic step
is um creating a python module the
simplest way to create a python module
is basically creating a python script
with whatever functions and tasks that
we want and methods that we want inside
uh whatever module and saving it with a
dot py extension um so in in my example
what i'm going to do is i have already
created a script in notepad and i've
stored it with a dot py extension that
contains these four functions add
subtract
product and division um i have basically
copied i basically use this code and
i've stored it in a dot py script and
i'm going to be using this as my uh as
as a test module for this particular
example now how do we import a module
now once that i have created a script uh
in my example will be called mycalc.py
and we've stated stored in our directory
to import the module all we have to do
is use the import statement so if i had
to import my calc all i have to do is
say import my underscore calc and now my
calc has been imported
so we can use the import statement or if
we want to import something particular
from mycalc we can do from my calc
import uh now we can whatever like for
example if we wanted the add uh the add
function we can basically just say only
add or if we wanted add and subtract we
can say add and subtract for example so
this is basically by using from we can
say that we want something from
something but only parts of it we don't
want everything we can also use from
mycalc import and we can say asterix to
basically say uh import everything that
exists in my calc
right now so this is another way of
importing something from a module now to
access contents in a module we have to
use the dot operator and i will show you
how right now so what i'm going to do is
in my example i'm going to import my
calc as calc so now what this is this is
the original folder or the original
module but i'm going to give it a
shorthand name so that i can easily use
it in my code and i don't have to type
out my underscore calc every time so now
i'm going to import this as calc so
anytime i have to refer to a particular
method or function inside this script or
this module i will just use this uh this
placeholder this variable name so now i
have two variables a and b and i'm
storing 20 and 30 on them so my first
funk what i'm going to do is basically
four operations i'm going to print the
addition of a and b then the subtraction
multiplication and the division of these
two numbers and each time to do this
operation i am going to use the add
function that is present in the my calc
module so to do that i have already
imported my characters calc all i'm
going to do now is invoke these
functions using the dot operator that
we're already familiar with so i'm going
to say calc.add and then i'm going to
pass these two arguments or these two
variables to say that i want to add
these two and similarly i'm going to do
it for subtraction
multiplication and division as you can
see these are the results of my tasks
now if i had to do a directory uh
operation on the module calc it will
basically give me a bunch of inbuilt or
dunder methods that are already a part
of any
python script by default such as
built-ins so if i execute this just to
show you what happens when i use the dir
function it will basically give me all
the functions that are part of this
python script so these double
underscores that you see are basically
uh denoting uh magic methods or dunder
methods and these are like inbuilt
methods as a part of the script and if
you see here add division prod and sub
these are the methods that we have
defined earlier on in our script
ourselves now to go slightly deeper or
in more detail into what happens when we
do a module search um let's let's
actually look at what happens so what
happens is when for example we execute
the statement import mycalc as calc as
we did over here so the first the steps
that actually take place are the
interpreter executes the above statement
and it searches for this python script
in a list of directories assembled from
these following sources that you see
here so it takes the directory from
which the input script was run or the
current directory if the interpreter is
being run interactively which is the
case right now uh secondly it will list
all the directories contained in the
python path environment that you set up
uh that you can set up or you can change
later on as well and this format for
python path is os dependent of course
but it should mimic the path environment
variable that we see in
windows systems then the other source or
the other directories is basically an
installation dependent list of
categories configured at the time python
is installed now the resulting search
path that is accessible in the python
variable system.path um this is
basically obtained from a module named
sys so if i imported the sys and edit
sys.path now these are all the
directories that we are going to look
for when we want to search for any
particular module so if i am doing uh
import my kayak or import os it's not
only going to look at the current
directory that i am working on it's also
going to look at all of these
directories that have been set up as
you could say directories or
paths in the
system.path in this video we will be
covering the topic of packages now what
if we developed a
very large application in python that
contains many different modules and we
have so many different modules that have
similar names and functionalities and
they're all kept in like or dumped in
the same location that it becomes very
difficult to track these modules what if
there was a way to organize and access
these in a much simpler and more
organized manner well packages allow us
to do just that packages are a
hierarchical structuring of the module
name space using dot notation and this
is the same dot notation that we use
when we want to access methods or
functions that are part of other classes
or modules so let's try to uh let's look
at certain examples to understand what
we mean so i have a directory called pkg
this can be basically treated as what we
call a package now in our package we
have two modules mod one dot py and mod
two dot p by and what we're going to
store in mod 1 and mod 2 dot p y are the
follows so i'm going to define a
function called foo and i'm going to
print
this particular statement mod 1 and then
i'm going to basically say foo
and then i'm going to say in class 4 i'm
going to
have an empty pass command similarly i'm
going to define a function called bar in
mod 2 dot py where i'm going to print
this statement so basically mod 1 dot py
has a simple function where i'm going to
print this statement and mod 2 dot py
has a simple function then i'm going to
print this statement um and i'm going to
store them in mod 1 and mod 2 dot py
respectively and these two modules i'm
going to store in the directory pkg in
my local folder now i've already done
this so we can already get uh to working
with this now if i wanted to access
these particular modules from the pkg
folder i can simply use the import
command and use the dot notation so i
can say pkg.mod1 so this will inward
this will
import the mod1 module from pkg folder
similarly i can do the same thing for
the mod 2 uh module from the pkg folder
in the same line so now that it's been
imported just simply execute this and
this imports whatever you needed now if
we wanted to
perform a function that was a part of
mod1 or py we can just extend the dot
notation and use the function as over
here as you can see it performs this
print command whatever it was supposed
to do similarly i can invoke the
function that was part of the mod 2
module
by extending the dot notation to it in
the same way now another way that i can
invoke
i can import a package is by directly
importing the package itself by using
import pkg and uh not accessing any of
the specific modules within it now let's
see what happens when we do this so just
for this example what i'm going to do is
i'm going to restart the kernel so that
the pkg
modules that were already imported get
cleaned away so we see what happens when
we execute this on its own now if you
see i haven't imported this now let's
see if i can access
my mod 1 and mod 2. now if you see here
it's throwing me an error and this is
because using simply using the import
command on a particular package only
imports um you could say the package
namespace but it does not actually
import any of the modules and files that
were part of this package so if i wanted
mod 1
from this package i would have to
actually say import pkg.mod1 directly
and i cannot simply say import pkg and
python will not import everything that
is part of a package on its own i have
to specify it myself
specifically now i'm going to create and
i'm going to i mean i'm going to show
you another type of importing from a
package using the star operator so i
have this package pkg once again now i'm
going to store um three i mean four
different modules within this package
mod one one one dot p by mod two two two
dot py and i've already done this so you
don't need to bother about
seeing me doing it right now because
i've already created these files and
what i've done is within mod111.py i've
defined
i've written this statement and i've
stored it in the python script similarly
i've created another python script
script called mod 222.py and i have
basically written this in the code and
i've similarly done this for mod 333 dot
py and i've done another for mod 4 dot
py now once i have done this i've stored
these python scripts into my uh into my
package or pkg
package so now what i'm going to do is
i'm going to create i'm going to execute
this command if you see this from pkg
dot mod 333 import start so once i
execute this now i'm going to say print
directory and print directory basically
will tell me all the functions that
exist in my current directory if you see
here there's this bias function that was
a part of mod 333 module now if i change
this and
if i imported mod 111 and if i did the
same thing you will see foo has now been
added as a part of this direction
directory and these are all functions
that were part of these different
modules where i am importing from and
that is what the star function does what
the star function will do is it will
basically tell python okay so the
statement is sync from
pkg.mod111 so it's saying that
okay look into this directory or this uh
package and find this module and in this
module import everything that exists
inside it up until this point so this is
another
another way of basically importing
files or functions from a particular
package and a particular specific module
within that package so yeah this was a
very brief video on packages in python
the conclusion being that packages are
basically a an organized way of storing
many different modules that we might
have created in a very large application
and these modules can be accessed using
the familiar dot notation that we have
used in other examples such as methods
when we were working with classes and
objects in this video we will be taking
an introduction into the concept of
generators so python provides a
generator which is like a function
where we can create our own iterator in
a generator function we use the yield
statement instead of the return
statement that we use for standard
functions
so let's look at a simple generator
first of all so out here i have defined
a generator called my generator where
i'm doing uh like there are three uh
like three
functions or three tasks that i'm doing
uh first one is when i'm printing the
first item and i'm yielding a value 10
then i'm printing second item yielding
20 then i'm printing last item using 30.
so let's see how do we use this
now since we know my generator is the
function it uses the yield keyword
every time we use the next keyword we
will keep getting what is next in this
function so let's store
the generator in my gen
so now
we have stored the iterator in this
function variable called gen or gen now
let's see when we do next
and we use gen
what happens so the first
task is performed or the first
iteration is performed where we get this
the first yield command is done
all right let's see what happens when we
do next again
next gen
now
as you can see we get second item and we
get 20.
let's do it for the next let's do it
once more since there is one more task
there's one more iterable inside
you can see this now a valid question is
what will happen if we do next gen again
since
there is nothing after this
well let's see what happens
we should get an error
as you can see stop iteration error this
is another
built-in
exception
that happens when we
have
like reached the last
object of an iterable
so we get a stop iteration error
so
now a key difference between a generator
and a function is that when we execute a
function the moment we hit the return
statement in a function or when we
execute a function like whatever
variables that were stored inside are
lost and they are destroyed unless they
were defined as global
and the function is completely done
executing and we leave the function
completely whereas when it comes to a
generator when we hit the yield function
we don't actually completely leave this
function so the first time the yield is
found we get 10
but
the generator remembers its position
inside this function
so the next time we use the next we
actually move on to the next iterable
and then we move on to the next iterable
so you can think of a generator as it
sort of has memory if that makes sense
it's a way to like create iterables in
python or create iterators in python
so to understand a what the difference
between the yield command and the return
commanders let's take the same function
all right
and let's put a return over here
after this particular
the second yield
okay let's do the same thing we say gen
is equal to
my
generator
and
let's start uh yeah let's start
doing next gen and seeing what is there
so the first deal will be standard first
item 10
the next one is again is going to say
second item and then 20 but now if you
notice there was a return i put over
here
so
technically when i did the second next
it's not only yielded 20 but it's also
executed this return function or this
return statement so let's see what
happens if i do next again
as you see i have gotten the stop
iteration seemingly earlier than i did
before and that's because i have used
the return function and return statement
and what that's done is that um
if we've completely left this function
so as to speak and there is
nothing next so as to speak so we get
these top iteration and that's uh the
difference between yield and return
now in the next example i'm going to
show you how we use a generator function
in place of the for loop or for a for
loop so let's take this whatever over
here and i have defined a function
called get sequence up to x
and
what this will do is basically
it will keep printing the printing
numbers up until uh whatever we have
entered in place of x over here so if i
said
say sequence is equal to
that's uh
copy this
all right and say i want um i want
sequentially i want every number up
until 10 but not including 10 of course
because python starts with 0 right
so let's do this
and
now let's see so the first number will
yield zero
and now if i
did this again
it should give me one
two and i can keep going
until
i
will stop at the value 9
as you can see here
so 8
9
now i should get the stop iteration
error because that we have reached the
end of our iteration so this is a way of
using generator functions for for loops
so another neat example where we're
going to use a generator
is
in the case of fibonacci numbers so
let's use it
let's uh see how we can generate a
fibonacci series using um generator so
i've defined a fibonacci function called
fibonacci where i'm passing max so max
is basically the max value that i want
um
like up until where i want the sequence
right so
uh this is basically the code which will
give return me the subsequent values of
my fibonacci sequence so
let's um pass this to fib
and see i want all the fibonacci numbers
until 10
so and i will pass 10 over here
let's see what happens when we do next
fib
well it should start with zero
then when we
do this again we get one
then we do zero plus one it should be
one
next number should be one plus one which
is 2 then we should have 2 plus 1
3
and then 3 plus 2 5 then 3 plus 5 should
be 8. now 8 plus 5 is 13 and since 13 is
greater than what we passed for our max
value here now when we try this we
should get the stop iteration error as
you can see
in this video we will be learning about
the concept of list comprehension
now list comprehension is it's a neat
way of creating a new list based on
values that are already there in an
existing list so you can think of it
like
creating a new list
using a much shorter and cleaner syntax
compared to what you might traditionally
be thinking
so let's go through some examples and
through those examples we will see how
list comprehension makes
creating these new this much simpler
much easier for us
so in our first example we will be
creating a new list
which will contain fruits that contain
the letter a in their name so we already
have a list of
fruits over here as you can see
it has apple it has banana cherry kiwi
and mango now we want to create a new
list which has only the fruits that have
the letter a inside them so apple would
be one of them banana would be one of
them and mango would be one of them so
traditionally
if you look at this piece of code
this would do what we want to do but
this contains a few
extra lines but yeah it does it does do
what we want to do now what if there was
a way of doing the same thing by just
writing one simple line of code and that
exists as you can see here
so i take the same
list
now
this is where you need to follow so now
my new list is equal to so i'm creating
a list over here as you can see now
within this list you have this line this
is what we call a list comprehension so
as you can see it says each fruit
for each fruit in fruits if
now it's checking for the letter or the
character a
inside
each fruit and what this each fruit is
that we're checking each
object in this list one by one so first
in the first iteration each fruit will
contain the string apple then in the
next iteration it will contain banana
and in each
each iteration we are going to check if
it contains the character a and if it
does then we store that each fruit in
the new list
as you can see here
so if i execute this line you see
my my result is the same i have my
whatever i wanted and this was a much
cleaner way of writing
or creating this new list let's look at
some other examples now
so my next example what i'm going to do
is i am going to iterate through a
string so i have a string it can be
anything in this case i am using a
string called human
all right so i have a string called
human right now i want to store each
character of this string into a
list that we call h underscore letters
so if i use the for loop this is how we
would do it if i execute this as you can
see the list contains h and then u m a
and then n now what if i wanted to do
the same thing but
by using list comprehension
so what i would do is
let's create
a list over here let's underscore
letters
and
um
so as we know let's com so a list
comprehension will uh it's it's a so you
just basically need one line in this
case it'll just be like this
now this is my string
now let's see when i check what's in
edge letters
let's see what is the output so as you
can see i have the output as uh what i
needed so this is a much cleaner way
let's go through some more examples now
now we can do more list comprehensions
um we can even use so we have already
seen uh
one case where we checked for the
character a we've seen a case where we
uh went through where we we did a sort
of a loop through a string we can also
use this comprehensions in conditionals
so let's uh look at an example where we
use the
this comprehension with an if statement
so what if i wanted to store say the
first
10 even numbers so this would so this is
an example that i'll be using
so in my list i want to store
the first 10 even numbers so this would
be a way to do it
so i have in range 20 so what this is
going to do is x is going to take the
value of 1 2 3 4 and so on until ninety
eight actually take it from zero one two
three four until nineteen so when we do
range twenty we're creating an iterate
in iterable
where uh
we're going to
look through our iterate through the
value of zero to nineteen
so
if i if i do this and this what this
statement does is basically it checks if
it's divisible by 2.
so
if this is equal to equal to 0 that
means we have an even number
and if this condition is met if this
condition is met that means we store uh
the x into our number list so let's see
what happens when we execute this
it should contain
uh 0 2 4 6 until 18 so this is the first
and even numbers as you can see
so this is a neat way of using if
statement we can also use an if else
statement
so what if i i'm checking um
each
okay so i'm going to create another list
and in this list i'm going to basically
see if um
each of my uh num numbers are the even
or odd the first let's say 10 natural
numbers
so let's write this statement down
so i want it to be even
in case
the i that i'm checking
i being every number between so
like say the first 10 natural numbers as
i said
let's check if
if it is divisible by 2.
well if it divides by 2 of course it's
going to be even right
else
we say that it is odd
and then we check for i in say the first
let's say the first 20
okay
so now when we do this let me check
oh we check what's in the list so as you
can see the list contains like even or
even orders basically saying the number
zero is even then the number 1 is odd
then number 2 is even and so on and so
forth so this is a an example where we
used the
list comprehension with fs statements
so another neat thing that we can do
with the
list comprehensions is that we can use
it along with functions so let's look at
this function
in this example we have a function
called double x where we define this
double x
this double function to take an input to
take an argument x and what we return is
the square of the argument so
let's use this in our lifts this
comprehension so what we do over here is
that we are
we're checking what we're doing is for
every x
within range 10 so we're taking the
value of 0 1 2 3 until 9 and we're
passing it to this function double x
and
we're going to get the square of them
and we're going to store that in a in a
list as you can see here let's call this
list uh x i just call this list uh it's
called y so now let's see what's in y
when we check
uh it should be 0 1 4 9 and so on so
wait this let's check again does this
square no this is actually 2 times so
let's make it square
as you can see
so you can see 0 1 4 9
for the first
10 numbers 10 natural numbers now what
i've shown you is obviously list
comprehension
but we can also do set and dictionary
comprehensions in fact set
comprehensions work exactly the same way
as
list comprehensions
the only difference is the
set comprehension will make sure that
there are no duplicates inside the set
so you can't have like duplicate items
uh which you can in the case of
list comprehensions so let's uh let's
say let's take a look at an example so
here in this example what we're doing is
we're going to check so we have this
string that we're storing in the
variable text and the string is
something like live finds away so
whatever this is
now what we're going to do is we're
going to
uh
iterate through this string uh character
by character and we're going to check if
uh there are we're going to check for
wobbles essentially so
uh we're going to see if the character a
e i o or u is present in the string and
if it is we will pass it into our set
now if you if you look you will find
there are multiple i's right and there
are multiple a's as well so
if we did this through a list
comprehension each time that we
found find a vowel it would be added to
our list but since this is a set and
sets do not allow duplicates so you will
only have one copy or one particular
object for each of the
vowels so
of course now uh set comprehension is
defined using curly braces so let's keep
that in mind so now if i check what's in
this i will see a e i and u even though
there are multiple a's or multiple e's
or i's and u's since this is a set we
don't have duplicate copies of any
copies of any of these
so this was just a small example for uh
showing you set comprehensions similarly
we can do the same thing uh this this
comprehension uh for dictionaries and
they will call the discrete dictionary
comprehensions the only thing that we
have to worry about when it comes to
dictionary comprehensions is that we
have to define a key when it comes to
this so let's let's look at an example
in this what we're doing is
again dictionary comprehensions are also
defined using curly braces just like
sets except uh in this case
we will define a key and that separates
it from a set comprehension
so in this case what we're doing is that
i'm checking i'm going through the a
list of numbers from 0 to 9 right this
is what the range 10 function does
and
what i'm going to do is
i'm going to create a key which is going
to be like 0 1 2 3 and the value of each
key would be its square as you can see
here
i'm doing i times i
or just to
make a little more clearer
as you can see i'm doing i squared over
here for every value from zero to nine
so what i should get is like a
dictionary where the first key is zero
and the value of that key should be zero
as well because zero
square is zero then for one it will be 1
and then for 2 4 and then 3 9 4 16. so
let's see what happens
as you can see here
this is the
the result that i wanted
so just to summarize let's go through
some key points uh to remember when it
comes to list comprehensions
so it's obviously an elegant way to
define and create lists based on
existing lists
it's more compact and faster than normal
functions and loops but we should also
keep in mind that we shouldn't write
like very complicated
list comprehensions because
the idea of a list comprehension is to
be user friendly and also it's important
to note that every list comprehension
can be written in the form of a loop
but uh every loop cannot be written in
the form of a list comprehension and
that is a probably a very key point to
remember
in this video we will be learning about
the concept of regular expressions
now a regular expression is simply a
sequence of characters that defines a
search pattern for example
if you see this example here you can see
a symbol called the carrot followed by p
and then five periods
then an n and a dollar sign and what
this regex pattern does is it's
searching for a seven letter string that
starts with p ends with n and has five
characters in between
let's look at this example now
this is a regex pattern that is looking
for a five character string that starts
with a ends with s and has three
characters in between
now if we had to match this with this
string with these strings as in as i or
test strings the first one would not
match because it's a three letter string
and we're looking for a five character
string
the second one would match because it's
a five character string that ends with
an s starts with an a and has three
characters in between this will not
match because whatever pattern would do
is it would find the first s
and it would find that it the string
itself starts with an a and it would say
okay there are only two characters
between this first s
and this a and it would assume that this
is actually just a four character string
to actually
identify two consecutive s's we would
have to do something special and what we
would have to do is what we will see
later on so again this is the same
example since this is case insensitive
capital a uh is perfectly fine when
we're searching for this and it will
also match this is
this is obviously two words and it's not
a five character string so this will not
be a match
now the regex pattern or the regular
expression module in python can be
imported using this statement import rd
now once we've done this
we can actually use the our regular
expression tools and methods to do uh
pattern recognition character
recognitions and to identify different
sequence of characters in our strings
let's try to understand a bit more in
depth about regular expressions now so
what you're seeing here is one variable
called pattern which stores
something that looks like a regex
and another variable that stores our
test string called abyss
now what we're going to do is we're
going to use the match method of this
module re and we're going to check
whether this pattern
um or whatever we are trying to search
using this regex is in fact does it
match with our test string and what
we're trying to look for is if you see
here very similar to what i just showed
you a five character string that starts
with a and ends with s
so if you see our test string it indeed
is a match and when we use this uh this
command we should get a perfect match
so we should be basically it should say
that
search is successful if i execute this
and this is what it does
now if i change the test string to this
now you will see that now this is no
longer what we're looking for a five
character string with uh a and starting
with a and ending with s
and you will see that the search will be
unsuccessful
as you can see here
now let's try to understand
what exactly do we mean by uh when we
use these different certain these
special symbols like for example this
carrot or this dollar symbol um these
are by the way known as meta characters
and now we're going to look into all the
or most of the different meta characters
that are used in regex
so to put it simply meta characters are
simply characters that are interpreted
in a special way by the regex search
engine
now here's a list of meta characters
let's go through them one by one
now the square brackets square bracket
simply specify the set of characters
that we wish to match so we want to
match
some combination of a b and c it can be
one a two a's three b's four c's we are
not looking at a specific pattern we
just want to know if a b and c exists in
any form in our string so if we used it
on a the string a simply we would find
one match because the letter a is found
here ac would match twice because we
have a and c
present here in this string hey jude we
will have no matches because a b and c
none of them are found here and in this
weird string we will have actually one
two three
four and five matches so we would have
five matches for this uh this bigger
string because we have five instances of
a b or c
now let's use re.match to
do
to actually search for this and to see
if we have our particular whatever
patterns that we're looking for now in
this input string this is just some
example string
i'm going to test this i'm going to
match whether my pattern that
any of a b and c is it actually found in
this so let's see what happens when i
use re dot match for this
so this is the format uh the syntax is
simply the regex pattern and then comma
whatever test string that we have
so
let's see what object gets created when
we try to do this
as you can see it's none even though you
might be wondering like i can see an a
over here i can see a c over here
re.match actually gives us the result
none
now
if i
try to do it on this test string
which is slightly different instead of
the film titanic was at least 1998 what
i'm saying here is all film titanic was
at least in 1998 now let's see if the r
match
works or not
as you can see it actually does return
when i execute this it returns us an
object called id.match object with a
span01 the span01 is basically telling
us that we have found a match between
the zeroth and the first character which
is basically this character a which is
what it has found and it's saying that
the match is indeed the character a
uh from amongst these options
so what this is basically telling us and
uh what this means actually is that the
re.match method will only find matches
if they occur at the start of the string
being searched once there is a space in
in our bigger string it will not search
for whatever comes after it so
what happened in the first instance was
it was actually only searching for
matches in this particular word in my
largest string and since it found no
match it basically gave us the result
none which was not the case in the
second example because it found a match
immediately in the first letter a
now if we want to actually check the
whole thing what we would be using is
the re.search
as you can see here the re.search method
will actually check the whole string and
it will return us the first instance
where it finds a match now let's see
this is the test string now and we're
searching again for
our uh we're searching for a b and c any
any of these
in our test string but we're going to
use re.search and not match so now if
you see it returns us when i execute
this it returns us a match object again
but this time it's saying the span of
nine and ten now the spine panel nine
and ten actually exists over here this
is the ninth character and a itself is
the tenth character over here so what
this basically is telling us that the
tenth character is where we found a
match
which was the letter a which was the
first instance of either a or b or c in
this whole string and this is basically
how re.search works it will not only
search the beginning of the string but
it will search the whole string and
return us the first instance or wherever
we find now what if we wanted to find
out all the instances wherever a b and c
were found and not just the first
instance well in that case we would be
using the method find all over here so
when we use find all it will actually
return us each and every case where it
found a b or c and uh you might not it
won't tell you the exact position
but it will tell you like um so if i
execute this you can see it gives us a a
list with a c a and a and what this
basically means is it was looking for
the characters a or b or c and it found
a first and hence this for the first
item in the list and then it found a c
and then it found two is successfully so
this is exact this is actually how find
all works where it will actually find
all the instances of our regex pattern
now that you've seen how the square
brackets work and how the re dot search
and re dot uh match and re.find all
methods work now we're going to go
through all the other meta characters
that we saw above so the period now
period matches any single character
except the new line new line is
basically slash n or a break now if you
look at this picture what it's going to
do is
um
this expression basically saying that uh
do we have um two characters like sets
of two characters in our string so this
is a single character string
and obviously a single character string
is not a double character string and
this expression this double dot is
basically asking us do we have two
characters present in our string
so if i had to match it with this a it
will obviously be a no match because a
is one character if we checked it with
ac it is a match because a and c are two
characters a c and d will also give us
only one match because it will find a c
and then it will leave d as a single
character but when we check a c d and e
or this string in particular it will
find two matches because it will
consider a and c as one of the matches
and d and e as one of the matches
so below is basically what we're doing
basically the same thing we're just
using rd dot search for each of these
different examples
so if i if you see when i use find all
on acde and when i'm searching for a two
character match you will see that it
will return me ac and de as you can see
here and similarly for something like
this it will return me again
whatever like two character patterns it
finds successively
so the next symbol the next meta
character is the carrot symbol that
you've seen earlier then the carrick
symbol is basically used to check if a
string starts with a certain character
so if you look at these two this picture
if you have two two expressions that
we're going to check over here one is
the
one is checking if a
is the beginning of a string and the
other one will check if a
is the beginning of the string but is it
followed by b or not
so when we check this what you can see
is the first string will be a match
because it's the only the character a
and it will match here as well because
this string starts with a but it will
not match here because the string starts
with b
now if i look at this
particular expression you can see that
um
this is going to search for if the
string starts with a and is followed by
a b so it will match in this case
because it does start with a and is
followed by a b but it will not match in
this case even though it starts with an
a because it's not followed by a b
so out here is basically us using the
ie.search to basically find these
patterns
the next symbol that we will come across
is the dollar symbol so the dollar
symbol that you can see here is used to
check if a string ends with a certain
character and we've already seen how
this is used in one of the uh one of the
earlier examples
so this is going to check basically if
so this expression will check if the
string ends with a so this this string
is basically the character a so it will
match this also ends with a so it will
match and this particular string does
not end with a so it will not match and
we are going to do that using the re dot
search over here so as you can see it
finds a match
in the first character itself here in
this case it finds a match in the last
character but in cab there is no match
so it returns us a none another example
is
of the meta characters is star so this
is the symbol for star and uh this what
the star basically is used is for
checking if there are zero or more
occurrences of the pattern to the left
of it so now if you see here what this
will check for is
is there any form of
m and a
that occurs before n and it's very
important to note that
the n has to follow the a in this case
so let's look at these examples and what
will happen so if i checked it with m
and n this is actually a match because
n is followed by zero occurrences of m
and a which is if it might seem a little
weird but it is technically the truth
because
uh the the star symbol checks for not
doesn't check for the existence it just
checks for if n
occurs it must occur
after an a
or the a should not be there itself in
this particular string so as you can see
here the n occurs after an m and it's
fine because there is no a
now you will see when it will not work
so m a and n is obviously fine m a
m triple a n is also fine because n
follows an a and there's an m here
this however main will not match now why
even though we have m and a and we have
an n you see the n is immediately
followed by an i
is n follows an i immediately or the n
is preceded by an i immediately and this
is a no match because our the strict
condition in the search is that n
must
uh proceed in a if the a exists
again in women it will match because n
follows an a over here we're just going
to use the id dot search for these
examples that we saw over here in terms
of code using the re dot search
as you can see here finally we have the
next meta character which is the plus
symbol yes so the plus symbol matches
one or more occurrences of the pattern
left to it now this is very similar to
what we saw earlier in terms of the star
except now in the plus the key
difference is we're looking for one or
more occurrences instead of
zero or more occurrences that we were
looking for in the case of star
so when we say one or more occurrences
now
we need what is there to the left of the
plus sign a zero uh no occurrence of it
will not be allowed or will not cause a
match so let's see now what we're going
to do here we're going to use the same
expression except we're going to replace
the star with the plus sign so now what
we're going to say is okay we need m and
a at least one occurrence followed by an
n the all of these conditions have to be
met so again if you took the first
example m and n this time it will be a
no match because there is no occurrence
of an a over here for preceding the n so
it's a no match m a and n is a match
because well this is per this is
perfectly fine m triple a and n is also
perfectly fine but if you look at m a i
and n much like earlier the n
is uh preceded by an i and not an a so
there is no match and again women is
perfectly fine and we basically execute
the same thing through the search
function in this piece of code the next
meta character is the question mark the
question mark symbol matches 0 or 1
occurrences of the pattern to the left
of it
so let's see what this does so now
we saw the star
the star which was zero or more
occurrences of the pattern to the left
of it we saw the plus which is one or
more occurrences of the pattern to the
left of it now we will see the question
mark which is zero or one only zero or
only one and not zero or more or one or
more which was the previous cases only
zero and one or one occurrences of the
pattern to the left of it again we're
going to see the same expression except
we're going to replace the meta
character with the question mark so now
let's see what what happens when we
match so if you see here m and n is a
match because there is zero occurrence
of a and one occurrence of m preceding n
so this is fine
this is also fine because there is one a
occurrence of a and m and then it is
followed by an n
this will not be fine because now we
have three occurrences of a
which is followed by an n we're only
looking for zero or one
this again main will be a no match for
the same reasons that we have already
gone through and women will be a match
again for the same reasons
and we'll read through the same things
using the search function in this piece
of code the next meta character is the
braces character now the braces
character is interesting because what
we're going to do is we're going to see
if there are
so uh that is the typical syntax for the
braces is n a brace followed by some
integer n comma integer m and then
closed braces so what this means is
we're looking for at least n and at most
m repetitions of the pattern left of the
braces let's see through an example
if you see this expression we're looking
for at least two
and at most three occurrences of this
the character a in our test strings so
let's see what happens in the first case
we have no matches in this case because
this part of the string contains only
one a and even this part of the string
only contains one a we're looking for at
least two and at most three
this part will contain one match the
second the second example because the
second part of the string actually
contains
two a's for one uh two uh repetitions of
ace con consecutively
but this uh in the end and in the third
example you can see both the strings
actually contain matches so we get two
matches because as you can see here
there's two a's here followed by three
a's here
now when we look at this particular
string let's look at what happens now
so what we're going to find is that this
thing is perfectly fine so we have two
occurrences of a but now we have four
occurrences of a but what the search
engine is going to recognize is this
first three is and is going to see okay
so there are three occurrences of a and
i already have a match it's not going to
consider this fourth a and the search it
will just look at the first three and
say okay there are
three a's and my my match is fine so
again there are two matches in this case
again we're going to use the search
function initially and you can see each
in each of the cases there is a match
except for the first case which is this
case now let's see the find all option
and see what happens when we do the same
thing using find all
so when we use find all it basically
gives us each of the instances where the
match has occurred
in each of these lists
now let's try to use a slightly more
complicated example where we combine
different let's say different meta
characters and we create a a more
sophisticated expression that we want to
search in our test strings so if you
look at this expression what we're
looking for is 0-9 now a dash symbol is
valid in python using regex because what
this basically tells it is that it's
looking for either 0 1 2 three four so
on until nine basically any of the
digits you're looking for any of the
digits from zero to nine
and we're going to uh check if at least
two and at most four occurrences of
digits if they are there or not in our
particular code so let's see what are
the matches that happens when we use it
on test strings so if you use it on this
string you can see it will find one
match this basically this particular
part of the string where it says one two
three so this is uh
three occurrences of digits so it's fine
now when we look at this whole string 12
and whatever this is
you will see this will not find a match
here this obviously will not because
these are characters but if you look at
over this part it will find matches in
terms of the first four and then seven
and three the next two
one and two again there are no matches
because there's only single occurrences
of digits we're looking for it at at
least two and at most four so if i use
the find all
you will see like what all it will
return so for the first test string what
is going to return me is it's going to
return me 1 2 and 3 as you can see here
but now if you look at this test string
it's going to return me 12 it's going to
return me 3 4 5 and 6 is going to return
me 3 4 1 and two but not seven because
we're looking for at least two and then
it's going to return me four five six
and seven followed by eight and eight as
you can see in this list over here
now if we use curly braces with only one
digit it's basically telling the search
engine that we want exactly so many
repetitions of the preceding uh whatever
kind of expression that we have
so when we do this example for uh for
example we're basically saying that we
want
x
followed by a dash and the dash has to
occur at least three times
in our particular expression and then it
should be followed by an x again which
will not match in this case because
there are only two dashes and it will
match in this case because there are
exactly three dashes and it will again
not not match in this case because there
are four dashes
as you can see here none followed by an
object match followed by none
next we move on to the alternation
um the alternation meta character and as
the word suggests
is basically looking for some alternate
form of a and b so a should be followed
by a b
and uh basically this pattern has to
keep going on so in the first string
over here this pattern will not match in
the second string over here
we will have a match because we at least
find an a even though there is no b but
this is to consider match because we did
find an a at least over here we'll have
uh three matches because we have a
followed by a b followed by an a again
so uh if we did a reg expression for
this we would basically find these many
matches for each of these examples
the next meta character is the group now
a parenthesis is basically used to group
sub patterns so let's look at an example
to understand what we mean now if you
look at this complicated expression what
this means is that i want some form of x
and z the x and z have to occur together
but before that what i want is some form
of a following b following c
some sort of alternation between a b and
c
so this part as you can see here is kept
in a parenthesis because i want this
whole condition to basically occur
before i find in x and z so let's look
at what happens here
in the first case we don't have a match
because
uh the this basically this parenthesis
condition is not being met the x and z
is preceded by a space
or basically the a and b is preceded is
followed by a space so if the space
didn't occur we would actually find a
match as you can see in the next example
here you can see a and b occur basically
this uh initial condition is met
followed by x and z so there is a one
match so it's fine for us now if you
look at this slightly more a trickier
one what you can see is we have two
matches in this case first in a followed
by x and z and then we have
c a and b now
this is perfectly fine because we we are
looking for a b
followed by an x and z we're looking for
either of these things we're looking for
some form of alternation of these things
followed by an x and z and we can get
that over here we get b followed by an x
and z so you'll get two matches in this
case now let's go through the concept of
grouping constructs now that you've seen
many meta characters you've seen how
parenthesis works let's look at grouping
constructs so grouping constructs break
up a regex in python into sub
expressions or groups and this serves
two purposes one is a grouping part
which basically says that a group
represents a single syntactic entity and
any additional meta characters apply to
the entire group as a unit and then
there is a capturing part which
basically tells us that some grouping
constructs also capture the portion of
the search string that matches the sub
expression in the group you can retrieve
captured matches later through several
different mechanisms so let's look at
basically what we mean by this example
over here so if you see this this
expression has a plus sign so we're
looking for
as you know a plus looks for one or more
occurrence so this will basically check
for one or more occurrence of the
character r only because there's no
parenthesis as in this example so this
plus is
next to an r and it's going to check for
basically
whether one or more currents of r
happens
preceding b and a but if we actually put
b a and r in a parent thesis followed by
plus it will actually check for the
entire string bar and it will check one
or more occurrences of bar together so
if you look at these two examples when
we use this uh on these examples you can
see that these are fine like these
matches are fine but if i used this
parenthesis then these would be the
acceptable matches and like ba triple r
would not be a match if i use
parenthesis
as you can see here
so this is how grouping constructs work
and how parenthesis work
so let's look at some other examples so
what this will do is f o o has to be
optionally followed by bar and bar must
exist together
and
this is because we have a question mark
here this question mark symbol tells us
that there should be zero or one
occurrences
similarly this particular complicated
expression is checking for one or more
occurrences of whatever we saw earlier
basically this whole thing
is followed by a plus so we're looking
for this whole sequence for one or more
occurrences of it cow is simply just cow
we're looking for this pattern and this
is going to check for
zero or one occurrence of c or w
because of the existence of the question
mark for uh preceded by the parenthesis
in this video we're going to continue
our discussion on regular expressions
now that you know the basics of regular
expressions
let's continue our discussion with
special sequences now in an earlier
video on strings you might have
encountered what is an escape sequence
and how we use the backslash character
to generate these escape sequences and
an escape sequence is basically if you
remember
something that we use to either
give certain special meaning to
characters that are otherwise ordinary
or it is used to remove the special
meaning that are inherently present in
certain characters that we call meta
characters so let's look at what special
sequences are in relation to regular
expressions
so the first one we're going to look at
is the backslash capital a which is used
to match if specified characters are at
the present are present at the start of
a string so out here if you can see we
are checking if the word
d is present in these two strings so we
would get a match in the first case over
here because this starts with the word
the but in the second case we won't get
a match
and this is how we're going to check it
for the same thing using the find all
function
so if you see in the first case it gives
us it returns us an object because we do
find d in the beginning of the string in
the second case we get us empties list
because this string does not start with
the word t
now the next one that we'll look at is
backslash b
small b now this is used to match if
specified characters at the beginning or
at the end of a word so when you use
backslash small b
and then you follow it up with whatever
you're looking for it would look for the
that particular those particular
characters or that pattern if it exists
in the beginning of a word in a string
so if you look at the first example it
starts with f double o and in the second
example you see this portion of the
string or this word is actually also
starting with f double o so it will also
match
however in this string which is very
similar to the second one we don't have
a space between a and f
and it's basically one word so this does
not start with f double o but it
actually starts with afo and it won't
match as you can see here
now similarly if we wanted to check if
something exists in the back of a string
at the end of a string we type what we
want to search for first and then we
follow it with a backslash small b and
then if you see here it will match in
this first case it will match in the
second case because this part of the
string ends with f double o but it will
not match in this case because well we
removed the space so now this whole
thing becomes a
the string that we're looking for and it
does not end with fw anymore and this is
basically us just checking in through
the find all function
now the next sk the next special
sequence that we will be looking at is
the slash capital b which is basically
the opposite of what we just saw this
matches only if the specified characters
are not at the beginning or the end of a
word so if you see here this is checking
if f double o is not at the beginning of
these strings so in this case there will
be a no match in this case also it will
be a no match in this third case there
will be a match similarly if we wanted
to see if something does not end with a
particular string we would type that
whatever pattern we're looking for
followed by a backslash capital b
and then we can use the find all
function to generate us lists wherever
we find such objects
find such matches in our particular test
strings like we have done over here so
the next one that we're going to look at
is the backslash small d and this
matches any decimal digit which is
equivalent to doing a square brackets
0-9
as you've seen you must have seen
earlier so if we did a square bracket
0-9 and if we did a search or a find all
or a match it would look for any of the
digits between 0 and 9. so a similar
thing can be done using a special
sequence backslash small d so as you can
see there will be three matches in this
case because one two and three digits
exist whereas in this case uh for the
word python there will be no matches
so these are certain examples where we
are doing the same thing using the
backslash d
now we have another one which is the
backslash capital d and this is just
basically the opposite it matches for
any non-decimal digits it's also
equivalent to typing a caret inside
square brackets with 0-9 which if you
remember from the previous video is
basically asking us to check for
anything that is not
the digit zero to nine
so
this is basically we're going to check
in these two strings if there is no
digits and no non-decimal digits so if
you see here we will we will find three
matches a b and the uh double double
inverted commas and in the second string
we will find no matches because this is
fully just digits next we have backslash
small s now this matches where a string
contains any white space character so
this is equal to doing a
check for all of these so this is like
backslash small t is a check for tab
space backslash small n is a check for
break line and then backslash r black
slash f backslash b uh are their own uh
checks for uh different sorts of white
space characters that you can see by
just looking it up honestly but yeah so
if you simply do a backslash s it would
actually be the equivalent of searching
for any of these
white space white space characters that
we generate
so if you see here when we do a
backslash s on this string you can see
that there is one space over here so it
will match it will give us one match
because there is one white space which
is just the normal space here and in the
second example there is no match because
there is no white space here
similarly slash capital s now as you
might have noticed is basically checking
for a string which does not matches in a
string wherever there is no white space
characters so it's basically the same as
doing carrot slash t slash n slash r
slash f slash v in a square brackets so
this is basically a simpler way of doing
uh the same thing using square brackets
and a carrot symbol so if you see this
expression backslash capital s now we're
looking at uh a space b so over here if
you see it will match for all the non
spaces so it's going to match for a and
b so we're going to get two matches here
whereas an empty string does not contain
well it does not contain any non-white
space character since an empty string is
basically a white space character on its
own so this would be this will give us a
no match so the next special sequence
that we're going to look at is the
backslash small w
this matches any alphanumeric character
which is the equivalent of doing a to z
in small and then capital a to z and
zero to nine for and also an underscore
check in square brackets
it's important to note that the
underscore is considered an alpha minor
character hence why we include it over
here but yeah this is this uh backslash
w uh small w which basically checks for
uh any alphanumeric character and
matches it in a string so if you see in
this first case um it will find three
matches at one two and also at the
letter c these others are not
alphanumeric characters uh whereas in
this string none of these are
alphanumeric characters so we will get
no match again much like the other
examples there is a capital there's a
backslash capital w which will check for
any non-alphanumeric character and it's
the equivalent of doing whatever we did
before in uh in the square brackets just
with a
preceded by a carrot sign so if you see
here we have the string where we have a
bunch of characters well yeah only one
of them this uh percentage symbol is a
non-alphanumeric character so we will
get one match over here but in this case
in the string python we will get no
matches because they are all
alphanumeric characters which is doing
the same thing here with a bunch of
different examples using the find all
function now the backslash capital z
matches if the specified characters are
at the end of a string now don't confuse
this with
backslash
small b plus the backslash small b
checks for a string and it checks each
and every word in the string
individually and checks if so if any of
the words ends with a particular thing
or or starts with a particular thing but
it checks each word individually but in
this case the backslash capital z will
check the string only and not each word
so if you see the difference here in an
um when you use capital backslash
capital z um it will match in this first
example but it won't match for the next
two but if you used a
backslash small b over here it would
actually match not only the first
example here but it will also match in
the second example because it would
check this word individually and it will
find out that yeah there is a match here
as well so it would actually match in
the second example as well
in this video we will be covering the
topic of closures now before we
understand what a closure is we have to
understand what is a nested function and
non-local variables now a function which
is inside another function is known as a
nested function
nested functions are able to access
variables of the enclosing scope
so if i define this function called
outer function where i pass some
argument called text and i store that in
a variable called text again and if i
create a function within this call in a
function and i want to print whatever
the variable is in text
when i execute this
it will be able to access this variable
because it's within the enclosing scope
so if i set outer function hey this gets
stored in the variable text and then the
inner function will print that variable
which is basically the string here
as you can see here
now inner function can easily be
accessed inside the outer function body
but not outside of its body so here our
inner function is treated as a nested
function which uses text
this this variable text as the non-local
variable now a closure is a function
object that remembers values in
enclosing scopes even if they are not
present in memory it is a record that
stores a function together with an
environment it's a mapping basically
that associates each free variable of
the function which are basically
variables that are used locally
but are defined in an enclosing scope
with the value or reference to which the
name was bound when the closure was
created a closure which is uh which
unlike a plane function allows the
function to access those captured
variables through the closures copies of
their values or references even when the
function is invoked outside the scope so
let's look at an example to emphasize on
what what was just said so again i've
created i've defined this function out a
function where i'm doing the same thing
now i've defined the same inner function
where i'm going to print the same thing
now it's very important that when i
return over here what i'm going to
return is inner function but it's not
going to be a function call this is
important to
create a closure so we return in our
function but with without
using the call as we do over here
and what this return will do is
basically to create the enclosure sorry
the closure
um where the inner function will
remember the values of the variables
stored in the enclosing scope so now i'm
going to store this
outer function in an object called my in
a variable called my function now when i
call this my function um you can see
there there'll be two things that are
happening here so once i've defined this
and i've executed this
what happens out here is this function
has already executed and then i'm
storing edit to this
but because i've done return inner
function without parent thesis i've
created a closure basically and this
closure allows the inner function to
remember the values that were stored in
text at any point
and at every point even after the
execution of this one time so when i
execute this again for the second time
over here it will remember the value
that was stored in the variable text
which is hey which was which was given
over here
that's why you see when i execute it for
the second time over here the first time
being in this line when i'm storing it
in my function when i execute in the
second time again it would give me the
result of hey
as you can see the closures have to
invoke functions outside the scope the
function error function has a scope only
inside the outer function but with the
user closures we can extend its scope to
invoke a function outside the scope so
now let's look at this code so this code
don't worry about what's going on here
just know that what we are doing here is
we have two functions which we defined
called add x and y which will return x
plus y and the subtract function which
will subtract x and y
so now we're going to execute these once
we're going to execute the add over here
and add logger and we're going to
execute the
subtract function and we're going to
store it in sub logger so technically we
have already executed these two
functions
but now
uh since i've created an x an enclosure
basically uh if you see here this is the
enclosure that i have created now what
happens is
when i
access this function from outside its
initial scope which is basically over
here this was the initial scope when i
access it outside you will see that it
is it still has access to these
variables x and y so if you see here i
i first of all i've allowed this uh this
the enclosing function to accept uh
arguments of any numbers so
uh i can pass xy i can pass x y z also
but if you see here i i only have a
thing for x and y so
when i want to access any value of x and
y even after the execution of this code
initially
i have access to these variables x and y
and that is because i've created a
closure out of
that so if you see if i do add logger 3
and 3 over here i'm able to get the
result 6. if i do add logger 4 and 5 i'm
able to get the result 9. similarly for
subtraction logger 10 and 5 i will get 5
here and 20 and 10 i'll get 10 here and
i can keep doing this i can keep saying
add logger in fact if i say 4 and 7 so
if i executed this
and now i'm going to say let's say for
example add logger if i set four and
seven here
so this still has access to my variables
x and y because i've created the closure
and it should give me 11. similarly if i
did sub logger say 30 and 15 it should
give me 15 because 30 minus 15. so let's
say 30 minus 16 right so it should give
me 14 because again i have created the
closure and it has access to these
variables already in this video we will
be learning about the concept of lambda
functions now a lambda function in
python is an anonymous function without
a name
we usually use lambda functions whenever
we want to create a
a function type object for for a short
period of time a lambda function is
defined using the lambda keyword like a
normal function is defined using the def
keyword we define a lambda function
using the lambda keyword also the lambda
function can take any number of
arguments but it can only accept one
expression as a part of it so think of a
lambda function like um a sort of a a
temporary function object that you
create whenever you want to perform a
particular task or object but you don't
want to give it a name or you don't want
to define a full a full-blown function
and give it a name letter
so over here i'm going to give you an
example of a lambda function let's say
that this lambda function takes in
let's call it x
and
so you define the function let's call it
x let's call it a lambda function using
this keyword
now we won't say two parameters right
we're saying say a and b or two
arguments a and b so we're gonna pass
two arguments a and b whenever we call
use this function and we're gonna
perform some sort of an expression now
let's write down a simple arithmetic
expression for this once you've defined
your arguments
just use the colon now over here we have
our expression so let's call it a plus b
so now we've created a lambda function
called x
where we will pass two arguments and the
result will be the expression a plus b a
plus a and b being the arguments we pass
so now let's print
the result
of
let's say we pass one and three so now
we should get the result four right
because a plus b is equal to four so
we've passed a as one b is three now
let's execute this as you can see the
result is four similarly you can pass
any number of arguments so you want to
call some function x
may say lambda function
maybe say
a
b and c this time and we want to do the
product of these three arguments
so now when we do uh when we check the
result let's say we're doing the product
of two four and six
so this should be 48
and
when you execute this
you get 48 as you can see here so these
are two simple examples of a lambda
function
now i could have done this
in a different way where i could have
defined some function x
and over here i defined that it takes in
three parameters and then you can define
some say return the function basically
returns you a product b product c but
many a times you don't need to define a
full function called x you don't you
don't want to
assign some function with this name you
just want to create a temporary or a
short time anonymous function with some
name just to perform a simple expression
and in that case we can use lambda
functions uh that's an example by the
way you can use lambda functions in
multiple places so let's uh move on now
now for the sake of this video what i'm
going to do is i'm going to show you how
the sorted function works and we're
going to learn how the lambda function
uses this sorted function how they work
together so this will give you a clearer
understanding of how we use the lambda
function in our code so to start off
sorted function returns a sorted list
from the items in an interval so you can
have a bunch of for example numbers and
the sorted function by default will give
you
will return you the list of numbers in
an ascending order of course you can
also um using a parameter called reverse
you can you can you can return a list of
numbers in the descending order um you
can also do this for strings uh i mean
characters so if you give it a bunch of
characters
say a e f g in the in the alphabet it
will give you if you use a sorted
function it will give you the characters
it will return it in an ascending or
descending order depending on the
parameter you give so basically this uh
the sorted function the syntax is uh you
use the keyword sorted then you pass the
iterable which is basically some some
list or some
tuple then you give it a key so this key
sometimes we don't need to give by
default if the iterable is does not
contain um
multiple uh multiple items per object
for
like if it's not a tuple of multiple
objects um if it's not a list of tuples
for example you don't need to give it a
key if it's a simple list of numbers you
don't necessarily need to give a key if
you want to sort it but yeah a key is
basically the parameter which we use to
tell the sorted function that we want to
sort based on something which is going
to be the key in this case finally the
third parameter is reverse which
basically just tells us that if you want
to sort in the default ascending order
or if we say reverse true then we will
sort in the descending order now let's
look at some examples so i have this
list
over here
and
i'm going to print this list
so
this list is obviously a bunch of vowels
e a u o i and this is not in the
ascending order of the
the alphabet right like you we know it
as a e i o u if i print the sorted form
of this list it should give me a e i o u
a list with a e i o in the ascending
order
sorry yeah
so now as you can see
um it's given me this list as you can
see here similarly if um i gave it a
string a string as you know is an
iterable it's a collection of characters
so if i use a sorted function on this
interestingly it will give me a list of
these um individual characters like p y
d h o and n
but in the order that we want it to be
in
which is the ascending order of course
so
if i print this you can see it returns
me the list with each character in the
order that we wanted it to be in
now you might notice why does p come
before h that's because this is in
uppercase so what this does is first it
sorts all the uppercase characters since
there's only one so it just places in
the first
object of this list and then it sorts
all the lowercase characters that you
see here so yeah moving on now now what
if we wanted to say sort this in
descending order so
we have this list and now we want to
sort this in a descending order so in
that case we have to give the parameter
reverse and we have to assign the value
true
so once we do this now when we execute
this you can see we have the return as
the same list but in the opposite order
so that's how the reverse parameter
works now let's uh try to understand how
we use the key function or the key
parameter in the sorted function
now of course if you if we want to sort
something based on some key that we want
to define
we use the key parameter so let's take
an example now
so in this example what we have done is
i've defined this function
called take second so what this does is
it it simply
it takes the second element of a list of
tuples so what is this list of tuples
well this random you can see this random
this is a list of tuples so this is one
tuple this is the next tuple and what
i'm going to do is in this example i'm
going to create a key out of every
second element
in
each tuple so i'm going to create a key
out of 20 40 10 and 13 and based on
these in an ascending order i will sort
this whole list so my what my result
should be is that since the smallest of
the uh every second object in these
tuples is 10 so this will be my first
object in the my sorted list then it
should be the one with 13 because this
is the next highest number so then this
will be the next object similarly this
will be the next object then this will
be the whole next object so you see i'm
using every second element of the tuple
as my key and for that to create a key
basically um i'm creating this function
which will basically return every um
it will iterate through all of these and
return
each of the second elements
so
let's actually uh let's actually do this
now so what i have here is
i am going to create a sorted list which
is going to use a sorted function on
this iterable which is a bunch which is
a list of tuples it's called random now
my key is going to be take second so
this sorted function is actually very
dynamic in the sense um i don't i don't
exactly have to create a list directly
each of these objects present in the
tuples i just have to define if i can
even pass a function
in the parameter for key and it will
apply this function on the interval that
we pass over here which is random namely
and it will use this function to
generate keys uh generate a key out of
each second element and based on that it
will do the sorted it will perform the
sorted function so now
if i check
what's my
sorted list
you will see
that as i had mentioned now it's using
the second object so the second uh each
each second object of the tuple as the
key so since 10 is the smallest this
whole object is the first object then 13
so we have this object here and then so
on and so forth so this is how we have
used a key to do the sorting function a
key that we've defined on our on our own
now similarly we can use multiple keys
as well so just to quickly go over
through this
we have this
some some list where a bunch of names a
bunch of tuples you can see right tuples
with three objects each within it each
first one is always a string denoting
someone's name some student's name um
the second is the marks out of hundred
and the third is their age so
what we have here is what we want to do
is we want to sort this these tuples
in the order of first marks and in case
the marks are clashing or they are the
same basically
we will sort by the age so what we want
to do is we want to first sort by these
marks as you can see here but in case
they clash for example like say this 75
and 75 they're the same marks in that
case we want to sort it by the age which
is 12 and 20 which is different so in
this case we're going to use two keys
one for the first key will be given the
highest priority and then if there is a
clash then we use the second key so how
do we do this
now let's define some function like uh
how we defined this take second function
here this will be our function that we
will pass to the key this function
basically what it does is it gives us
who has the highest marks now since we
are creating and since the key works in
an ascending order so um the smallest
object in a key is the first object that
gets returned right so what we're going
to do is we're going to return the error
which is basically the difference
between um 100 which is the total marks
and the marks that student gets so this
is how we obtain a ascending order in
our
list which is what we which which
basically is what we want because we
want um the highest marks to be first
so we do 100 minus item one item one is
basically the first object or whatever
iterable we pass in this case it would
be the the first objects of each tuple
which is the marks secondly we bond age
age is the item 2 which is
yeah each second object of each tuple
now
what we return in this function is uh
like this is going to be our key now a
list of errors and the list of age error
being the marks error the difference
between 100 and the marks you obtain so
now what it's going to do is it's going
to take the marks as the first key and
the age as the second key when we pass
this to a sorting function
so if you skip this you don't have to
look at this but if you look at this now
we have the sorted list which is going
to be the result of the sorted function
on top of what we pass which is the
participant list now we're going to use
the key we're going to use the key as
the sorter function so we're going to
use this order function as a key and
when we print
if you see
we get
let me just execute all of this
so if you see here in this section what
you can see is
we have the highest marks first then the
second and the third but if you see here
there's a clash this guy and this guy
have the same mark 75. so now what we
want to do is the guy who at the younger
age should be in the first in the object
so that is how this has happened because
we've passed two keys error and the age
so when the clash in error key happened
we went to the h key and then we did
ascending order on that and then finally
the rest of the objects that you can see
here so now that we have seen how the
sorted function works now let's look at
how the lambda function works using this
sorted function which was the main goal
of this video right so let's see
so it now some of you might have figured
out where this lambda function will be
used right so
whenever we were using the key in the
sorted function we had to define a
function and then we would pass that
function as the key so as some of you
may have figured this out
what we're going to do using the lambda
function is we're going to skip that
process of defining a function with a
new name and all that and we're going to
pass a lambda function or going to use a
lambda function
as the key so let's see how we do it so
initially what we've done is we've
created this list this list is a list of
dictionaries that you can see so this
first object is a dictionary second
object to the dictionary each dictionary
contains two keys um the name and the
age and the values are something like
nandini the values for age is like 20 20
and 19 so we have three dictionaries in
a list
so what we're going to do
is we want to print what we what we want
to do with this we want to print
the these objects or these dictionaries
in an ascending order of age so we want
obviously we want this to be first and
then this and this because 19 is smaller
than 20. so let's see how we do this
so if you go here
what we're going to do is we're going to
print the sorted the sorted function or
the uh the result of the sorted function
being applied on this list so this is
our iterable now if you see here in the
key the key parameter we don't we don't
predefine a function and pass it over
here instead we use the lambda and this
lambda function is defined in such a way
so we say lambda
it will take one argument i
and then it will return basically the
age
index
for some i and this i is we're going to
presume an i to be some sort of an
iterable which has an index called age
and which is uh which is the case in our
case right we have a bunch of
dictionaries where there is a key in
each of these dictionaries called age so
we're going to use that and now you're
going to ask like what is i well when we
use the lambda function in the sorted
function this i will basically be each
object that we get when we iterate upon
this list so we're going to iterate
first on this so it's going to take this
dictionary and it's going to search for
the age then it's going to take this
it's going to search for the age then
it's going to take this and it's going
to search for the age and each of the
time it will pull out what is the value
for each of these age keywords or these
age indexes or h keys and out of these
objects so 20 20 and 19 or these values
we're going to create a key with which
we're going to sort each object in this
whole list okay so this is how the
lambda function will work here so let's
do it
so as you can see
our sorted list now contains this object
first because a19 is smallest h and then
this and this now you might see that
there are two 20s so how do we control
which one comes first well by default it
will um
that it will just uh give us the result
in the way we passed it in the original
list so since nandini came before manjit
in the result also nandini will come
before manjeet but what if we wanted to
sort it even more what if we want to
sort it in such a way that first we go
by age and the second key will tell us
that if there is a clash in ages we have
to go alphabetically by the name so in
this case we will create a second key
and how we do that
well if you go to this step
over here what we're doing is we're
doing the same sorted function but now
the lambda will again take one parameter
which is i which is going to be each
itera which which is going to be each
object in this uh iterable list and
we're going to take two keys so the
first key will be the h key
and the second key will be the name so
it will first sort on age and then on
name so now if you see um the result
should be that manjit will come before
nandini even though the ages are 20
because m comes before n in the alphabet
as you can see this is the result
now if we wanted to do the same thing
but uh in a descending order all we have
to do is after this key parameter we
have to give another parameter called
reverse
and we have to give it true
so if we did this now you see this this
uh or if we do it on this one
to be more clear
now if i execute this basically this
whole uh whatever result we get will be
backwards now
oh wait i did not enter it in the sorted
function
so this should come within the sorted
function over here
so now if we
execute this you will see nandhani comes
first manjit comes second and then
nickel comes third
because we've done the reverse i will
use the reverse keyword as true reverse
parameter is true in this video we will
be covering the topics of map filter and
reduce functions in python now python
provides several functions that enable
functional approach to programming and
since functional programming is all
about expressions
some of these expression oriented
functions of python are
lambda functions list comprehensions map
filter
map filter and reduce now we've already
covered the topic of lambda and list
comprehensions
now let's cover the topics of map filter
and reduce
so to start off let's look at the map
function the map function takes in two
attributes a function and a sequence um
a function is basically
some defined some user defined function
or any function
a sequence is basically an iterable
object like a list or a tuple for
example or a bunch of lists and tuples
as well so let's look at an example so
one of the most common operations that
we do with something like a list is
doing an operation on each of the
elements in the list and then outputting
a new list with
the the values as whatever we have
modified to the original items of the uh
list
so we do what if we did the square of
all of these items in this list and we
you want to create a list based on that
so we can basically iterate through it
and we can do a square function and then
append those values to a new list called
squared and when we do this
for example
over here
you can see when we print squared
we should get the list of whatever
square values we have
for the original list but this is uh
slightly a bit tedious and what if we
had a method
that or a what if we had a technique
wherein we could
basically pass a function that we have
that we want to do and a sequence on
which we want to apply this and we pass
it to a function and this function
basically takes care of
applying whatever operations we want to
do on each element of a sequence so as
this is where the map function comes in
use so let's look at
how we use the map function over here
so if you look at this
i've defined a square function so the
square function basically returns uh
takes an argument x and it returns the
square of it and i have a map function
which takes the square
function as one of the arguments and uh
the i the list or an iterable as the
second
argument so this map function creates a
map object if you see here so let's just
do it one by one so i'm creating my list
and i'm going to create my function
called square
and i'm going to
send this to the map function so i'm
sending this
the first argument as the function that
i want to do and the second argument as
the list that i want to apply it on now
let's list out all the items that are in
this map object
if you see it creates me a list with
basically the squared items and this is
exactly what we needed and another way
of doing the same thing would be just
going through a for loop in each of the
map objects and printing each which
would give me the same results so if you
see here i found a very neat way of
passing a function and an iterable and
using the map function to apply each
operation that is part of the function
or applying the function on each item in
the iterable
so as you've seen we basically passed in
a user defined function and we applied
it to each item in the list then the map
calls the square function on each list
item and collects all the return values
into a new list and because map expects
a function to be passed in it also
happens to be one of the places where
lambda functions are
appearing a lot so let's look at the
an example where we do the same
operation using a lambda function so if
you see here i have a lambda function
where
i'm passing it as the function argument
and what this lambda function takes is
some variable x or some argument x it
does its square and it returns that x
and this x is basically going to come
from each element that is present in
this list called items and when we list
down these you will see it basically
does the same thing for us it creates us
list with squared items
now we can also pass instead of passing
an interval itself we can actually pass
a sequence of functions and use the
lambda function to perform
a sequence of functions on particular
items so let's look at a new example a
slightly different one so we're going to
use a numpy module for this don't worry
we're just using it to use the square
root function that is present in the
numpy power module um we will be
learning about number in a later section
so um we're going to import this first
and now i'm going to define three
functions for square cube and square
root
so once i've defined these basically
they're returning the square the cube
root uh the cube and the square root of
some integer x
and now i'm going to create a list of
these functions that you've just seen um
and we're going to
use a for loop and we're going to
iterate through a range from zero to
four
so and we're going to pass this
and we're going to say that we want to
apply
some some function we want to apply some
function x and we want to return that
using the snapdraft function now what
values this x will take is based on
whatever functions we've stored in this
variable called fu ncs or funcs and in
fu ncs we have a bunch of functions
called square cube and square root that
we have defined earlier so what we're
going to do is we're going to apply each
of these functions to r and r will take
the value 0 to 4 and now let's see when
we print this what values we get so if
you see here we get a list of
square root squares cubes and square
roots for integers 0
1
2
3 and 4. so this is another way of using
the map function and lambda functions
together to apply multiple different
operations to a bunch of intervals
now for our next example what we're
going to do is we're going to create a
function that basically
what it does is it creates the upper
case of some string that we passed to it
right so that's what we've done here in
this function called two upper case so
we've let's define this function now we
have a print function basically which is
going to print each object in a
particular um it's going to prevent each
element of a particular object and it's
going to at the end of it and the end of
printing we're going to give a small
space for printing a new line basically
so let's create this also this print
iterator object now what we're going to
do is we're going to pass a string with
the letters a b and c to this function
and we're going to map and we're going
to apply the upper case function to this
string now if you remember string is
also an iterable where it's a sequence
of one character strings so this whole
string is basically a sequence of one
character string a one character string
b and c
so we're going to so
we can pass a string as a as an iterable
to the map function because it will
apply the operations on each of these
characters so let's see what happens
when we do the upper case function uh we
apply the upper case function using the
map
using mapping to the string a b and c
so if you see it's created me a list
with capital a capital b and capital c
as we had expected because we have
applied the list function to the map
object
now
in the next step what we're going to do
is we're going to do a very similar
thing we're just going to instead of
simply mapping and creating a list out
of it we're going to store the map
object in a variable called map iterator
we're going to print
what type of object it is and then we're
going to print out each of the elements
using the print iterator function that
we defined here
so let's do this now if you see the
class the type of object is of class map
and the objects elements inside the
object are a b and c moving on let's uh
let's look at now an example where we're
going to pass multiple arguments um so
instead of one iterable we're going to
pass multiple iterables now and we're
going to apply some sort of an operation
so if you see here what we have done is
we've created two uh two two sequences
one is a list of some numbers and
another is a tuple of some numbers so
just to show you let me first copy this
here um yeah so if you see here i have a
list and a tuple and i'm passing both of
these if you see to this map function
and before that i have defined a lambda
function as the operation that i'm going
to apply and what this does is it takes
two arguments x and y and it returns the
product of both of these uh where does
it get x and y from so the x it gets
from this uh
this sequence which is a list and it
takes y from this sequence which is a
tuple so what it's going to do is going
to take x as 1 and then y is 5 in the
first step and it's going to return the
product as five then the next step is
going to take 2 as x and then y as 6 and
it's going to return the product of that
and we're going to get 12 and so on
we're going to get 21 and then 32 um
when we and this is these values are
going to be stored in the map iterator
which is a map type object and when we
use the print iterator function it's
basically going to print out whatever
results we got
through this mapping so let's execute
this and as you can see this is a result
we got 5 12 21 and 32 which is what we
wanted so the next part the next
function that we're going to discuss is
the filter function now now a filter
function is basically again it takes two
two arguments a function and a sequence
and a function
basically tests if each element of a
sequence is true or not now a sequence
the sequence
um so this filter function will
basically take two arguments so one is
the function and this function is
basically going to test if each element
of a sequence is true or not and it's
going to take another argument called
sequence and uh this argument sequence
is the list or the tuple or basically
any sequence and or iterable that needs
to be filtered and it can be
as i mentioned it can be sets list
tuples or containers of more iterators
and what this function will return is an
iterator that is already filtered um so
let's look at an example now so we have
this list r which you've generated which
is basically numbers from minus five to
four so if i
create this list here you can see it
will create a list of minus five to four
now
if i wanted to extract only the values
that are lesser than zero well i can use
a for loop and use a if condition to
check this right so if i did this over
here
you can see it gives me it returns me
some list called result which contains
only the values
lesser than zero which is basically
checked through this condition what if
there was a
neat or a more convenient or a more
organized approach to doing the same
thing instead of creating a loop
ourselves what if we defined a function
where we are going to do the test or we
are going to create the condition and we
are going to
pass this to a particular function and
then apply that particular operation on
every object of some sequence well just
like mapping we have a filter function
to do this and in this example what
we're going to use is the lambda
function which takes an argument x and
it checks for some condition x lesser
than zero and where it's going to get
the x from is some sequence r
which which in our case is the numbers
from minus five to four and the filter
will basically create a filter object
type which contains uh only the objects
from r that meet this condition that is
x is lesser than zero and when we use
the list operation on top of it you will
see it creates it results in a list with
the values that have met my condition so
for a second example what we're going to
do is we're going to create
a list which
contains a bunch of letters and we're
going to only extract the vowels from
these bunch of letters so let's look at
what we have here we have some letters d
a t j k o p l and we only want the
vowels from this so we want to filter
only the vowels so we can use that using
the filter function by first of all
defining a function that returns true if
a check is met that um
one of er the letter matches one of
these letters in this list called
letters
and if it doesn't it returns false so
this is our condition that we've created
once we create this condition uh this
function that checks this we can pass
this function and the sequence into the
filter function and then we can list out
whatever we get so you can see our
filtered list contains only a and o
which is basically the only vowels that
are present in our original list
finally we have the reduce function
this reduced function is basically a
func tools it's in the functo's module
of python 3.0 and what the reduce
function does is it applies a function
of two arguments cumulatively to the
elements of an interval and it
optionally it starts with an initial
argument and it returns a single result
so let's first import this function
and once we've imported it let's use it
in this example that we have here so in
this example what we're going to do is
we have some lists called numbers right
what if we wanted to take care to get
the sum of each element in this list
well we can iterate over it and store it
in some variable called total in each
step right
this is what we would typically do and
in this step what you can see is the
loop basically iterates over every
valuable in numbers and accumulates them
in total the final result is the sum of
all the values which is the value of 10
over here in this example the variable
total is what we call an accumulator and
we can apply the reduce function to do
the same
task so how do we do it let's first of
all create a function called my add
where we're going to take two variables
uh two arguments and we're going to
return the sum of it okay so let's uh
define this function and
now we have we have a list called
numbers right which contains one two
three and four now let's do reduce my
add to numbers
now when i do this when i use this
function what it will do is it will
apply the function of my ad it will take
basically
each and every element
in a sequence so it will take one and
two then add them together and then it
will create basically what it will do is
it will take one and two add them
together then we'll have three so it'll
take three and then the next element
which is three again so it'll create the
sum which is six and then it will take
six and then it will take the value four
and it will give us the result ten so
this is how the reduce function would
work so this is how it will give us a
result of 10
as you can see here i've simply used
i've passed this function where i've
defined that i want two
arguments to be passed to a function and
then the return should be basically the
sum and then i've passed a whole list of
like four numbers and i've used the
reduce function to basically do this
process for four numbers in a
step-by-step manner by taking two at a
time subsequently and my result is as
you can see is correct as you can see
here
so let's use the lambda function now to
do the same topic just do the same task
so what i'm doing now is i'm going to
define a lambda function and that's the
function i'm going to pass to this
reduce so when i pass this lambda
function which basically takes two two
arguments x and y and it's going to
return the sum of that
as x plus y now where it's going to get
x and y from is in a very in a very neat
manner so it will take first the first
two elements one and two it will then do
the sum and we get three then it will
take that same three and then take the
next object which is three again and
then give us six then it will take six
and then the next element which is four
and then give us ten and then the reduce
function will output the the the single
result which is ten to us as you can see
here
in this video we will be covering a sort
of a project side type of scenario which
is basically going to be a problem case
for you and it's going to be slightly
slightly difficult slightly tricky but
what we're going to do is we're going to
tackle a particular problem and we're
going to what i'm going to do is also um
show you a solution to that problem
so let's start with this so this
question that we have is we have this
program
that we have to write where we compute
the frequency of words that exist in
some input okay
the program should output after sorting
the key alpha numerically now this input
can be any it's basically a block of
text right so in our example we have
for example if this was our input right
uh what we want to see is an output
which is basically saying that the word
python has appeared say well in this
example it's appeared five times and
then the word read has appeared one time
and so on and so forth like for each of
these words we want to see um how many
times have they appeared in this
particular block of text so
let's look at a particular example now
where we have done this so let's um
let's see here
so first of all i'm going to create a
dictionary so why am i creating a
dictionary is because i'm going to use
each unique word as a key and the number
of times they have appeared in
a block of text as the value to that key
so
i'm going to use a sample
string which is basically this long
string that you can see here which is
stored in line so this large chunk of
text is what we're going to be analyzing
so how are we going to do this it's
pretty simple so
we have this now what we want to do is
um when we find what we one way of
tackling this problem that we're going
to do here is
we want to
um check word by word first of all we
want to see if it's a unique word and if
this word is
before i encountered it for the first
time then we need to store a new key in
our dictionary called frequent table or
frequency table and if it has already if
there is a key already with that
particular name then we just want to
increment the count or the value by one
so let's see how we do this over here
so if you can see in my this the
solution is as simple as this but if you
see what's happening it's basically what
what it's doing is we're splitting up
this string
using the split function what this will
do is it will split up the string at
every white space so it will take this
as one part and take this part as
another part it will create an iterable
with each word as the um each iterable
object in that container so
it's going to be a list of words like
python is one so on and so forth and
we're going to go one by one so we're
going to say forward in line dot split
now if this word is if it exists in
frequency table as a key then
what we're going to do is we're just
going to increase the count of uh the
value of that key by one but if it does
not exist then we're going to actually
create a key
with the word as that unique word and
we're going to create its value um
initialize its value to one
so when we execute this
now if we
want to once you've done this we can
sort it by the count of the words so
what we're going to do is we're going to
create a another tuple called 40 tuples
where we're going to use the lambda
function out here
to sort the dictionary in terms of its
values so what we're going to do is
we're going to take the key the key
being the lambda item item
with index one index one is basically
the value um so a a particular
key has a value so the word python
appears so many times the word
say scientist appears so many times so
we're going to check which words have
the highest number of occurrences and
we're going to sort it in a descending
order so that that is basically what the
reverse is equal to true does so when
we're going to sort this when we're
going to use a sorted function when we
say reverse true
it tells the sorting function to sort
this dictionary this dictionary
frequency table uh in terms of value
by the the descending order so whichever
word appears highest that would be the
first word in our
sorted tuple
so that's what we do in this line and
once we execute this we're also going to
print so if you see the result
of this
activity that we've done you can see
that the word machine appears six times
learning appears six times then python
appears 510 and so on and so forth so
we've created a sorted tuple where the
first object will be tuple we've created
a list of sorted tuples where the first
object of the tube each tuple is the
unique word the second one is the number
of times it has appeared in this
particular example or this particular
string so yeah this was the first basic
project that we have tackled in this you
might have seen some examples of how we
do list operations and how we use the
lambda function
in sorting the
dictionary
by the values of the key in this video
we will continue with what we started in
terms of our
project number one or what we're going
to do is um we're going to tackle
another slightly complicated
um
a question or a situation
we're going to try to arrive at a
solution so in this what we have is some
sort of a robot a moving robot which
moves on a cartesian plane a two
coordinate plane
is going to move
in terms of up down left and right okay
and each each time it moves up or down
or left or right it takes a certain
number of steps in that direction um
integral steps of course so what we need
to do is uh from a starting position
whatever its starting position is which
we are going to take as 0 comma 0 in
this example
we are going to make it move to a
particular location with the commands up
down left and right followed by certain
steps
and we're going to uh ask what we're
going to do is we're going to calculate
the distance between these two points um
and we're going to calculate different
types of distances so you might be
introduced to new concepts um your
distance concepts in this video as well
so what we're going to be using for
distance calculation is the minkowski
distance and that is we're going to take
so the minkowski distance between two
variables is basically the absolute
difference between these two uh
variables are these two points and we
take it to the power of something so if
we want to say uh calculate the
minkowski distance with in terms of the
quadratic mean cause the distance with
basically p2 so we are going to do x i
minus y i absolute difference to the
power 2 and then we're going to take the
second root of it after summing each and
every point so when we take p is equal
to 2 we we say the minkowski distance
behaves like the euclidean distance so
this is probably one of the most common
distances uh in case you've done basic
cartesian geometry when you're asked to
find the distance between two points on
a plane um we can also take the absolute
distance where we take p is equal to one
so in this case we're just basically
summing the
absolute distances between each point no
roots no powers nothing basically p is
equal to one and we call that the
manhattan distance so we're going to
take p is equal to one two and three in
each case and we're going to find the
distance between two points uh based on
these
measures
so
this is just a visual representation
this is basically the euclidean the
distance basically the
estimate of the value between these two
points if um
since this is a two coordinate system
whereas the manhattan distance would be
the absolute distance in terms of
if we go up and then we go right between
these two like save this first and this
was another point so yeah let's move on
to the problem in this particular
example we're going to start from the
starting position 0 and 0 on a on a
graph and we are going to give the
commands of up 5 down 3 left 3 and right
2. so first of all what we want to do is
we initialize the starting position as 0
and 0 and we also just for the sake of
this example we initialize the end
position as 0 and 0.
so what we're going to do first of all
is
let's execute this much now we have this
list list of tuples um it's we're going
to call this actions and this is the
actions that we're performing
so the this the each tuple contains an
action and the number of steps in that
direction so it contains four actions up
by five steps down by three steps left
by three steps right by two steps so now
we're going to iterate over this each
tuple and we're going to get the
direction first of all in this line
um for each step
and we're going to calculate the number
of steps it takes so for each action
it's going to first tell um it's going
to check what is the direction which is
done by this line
and we're going to find out the number
of steps in that direction which is
stored in this line so
once you've gotten this for each action
we have to uh update the end position
right
so
what happens is if you go up
by a particular direction so you are
basically changing the y y axis right
the uh the y axis so we're going to
change end position and the first index
which is basically this part of the
end position
coordinate point so we're going to say
if it's moving by up then we're going to
uh update
by adding
the y-axis by the number of steps so
um and and if the direction was down
we're going to do the same thing for the
y-axis but we're going to decrement it
similarly if we move left or right we're
moving the x-axis right so we take end
position in the first index
so we take the x-axis and if you're
moving left it's a negative uh it's a
decrement and if you're moving right
it's an increment so
if there's any other like action like
any other action for example that was
given here we say pass so basically the
only valid
actions that we can pass is um up down
left and right otherwise we we um just
skip that particular action so this is
what the this particular loop will do it
will update our final position
so once we've done this uh if we if i
execute this
what will get stored in the end position
is basically my end position so
now that i have my starting position and
my end position
um just to show you what the end
position will look like right now
let's
just do this so if you see here after
i've moved up by five steps down by
three steps left by three steps and then
right by two steps my final end position
is minus one and two um my start
position on the other hand
was
as you remember it should be zero and
zero
it is zero and zero so now we're going
to find the distance between zero and
zero and minus one and two so we're
going to first of all create a function
called minkowski distance which which
does a basic function of just calculate
the uh
the difference between the
what do you say
the end position x coordinate and the n
position y coordinate times uh or to the
power of a root and uh we're basically
going to do this operation that
you saw here we're going to do this
and
we're going to use this root variable to
specify to like p is equal to one two or
three like what p value we want to take
for this minkowski distance so once
we've done this what this function will
do is basically store uh this much and
it will wait for us to uh it will
basically wait for us to give us a root
so when we give root one it will create
these it will check the distance between
the end and starting points um with the
p value of one if we give it two it will
calculate euclidean distance with p
value 2 similarly for 3 and we can
calculate for any roots so we're going
to calculate for 1 2 and 3 roots
and we're going to see what values we
get in each case
so when root is equal to 1 i print a
statement saying minkowski distance with
root 1 is something and then root 2 is
something root 3 something let's see
what results we get
so if you see here the minkowski
distance with root 1 is actually 1.0 but
the euclidean distance between these two
points is 2.23 whereas the um
the cubic minkowski distance with
basically the with root 3 is 1.91 so you
see these three different uh distance
measures for the same distance between
two points so in this video you
basically so in this basically by doing
this activity you might must have you
will learn how to um
basically how to iterate through loops
um and perform these uh distance
calculations which you'll find pretty
handy in many activities related to data
science and machine learning in this
video we will be continuing tackling
different problems and
problem cases in terms of a project
called project 3 where we're going to be
using regular expressions to
validate whether certain passwords that
have been entered or do they match
certain criterias or not so let's look
into
our particular question we have a
website that requires users to input
username and password to register now we
have to write a program to check the
validity of passwords input by the users
now the criterias that the passwords
have to follow are that there's at least
one letter between a and z and one
number between 0 and 9.
the third criteria is that there's at
least one letter between capital a and
capital z so this first and third point
basically is saying that there should be
one lowercase letter and there should be
one uppercase letter now there should be
at least one character from dollar sign
hash or the at symbol um it should have
a minimum length of 6 and the maximum
length of 12. so when we whatever
passwords that we enter into our
example they must be comma separated so
if we're going to have an input they're
going to ask us for an input where we're
going to have to input the different
passwords in a comma separated way so
let's look let's look at
how do we tackle this so for my example
i'm going to use these
examples in terms of these are my
password examples if you're going to
check if these are valid passwords or
not so let's copy this first of all
and now let's import the re this import
rd is basically the regular expression
module
now in this step is going to ask us to
input the passwords as you can see here
so i will just control v so since this
is comma separated what it will do is it
will split up each of these
by the comma and it will store them in a
list so it will take this as one
password this has another password this
has another password and this has
another password once i press enter
now if i want to check what's in list i
mean what's in items
what i can do is
just check over here what's in items
it's a list of whatever password i had
entered
each object is separately treated now in
this list
now i'm going to create a an empty list
called value first of all once i've done
that i'm going to move on to the next
step
so once i've created my list called
value what i'm going to do is now i'm
going to search and i'm going to check
for each condition using regular
expressions for whatever criteria that
we have
initially so
if you see here what i'm going to do is
first iterate by each item in this to
check for each password now my first
check will be a basic check
for the length of the password if it's
lesser than 6 or greater than 12 then
our basically our password is illegal so
we can't be using this and we will just
continue and we won't check for anything
else but if it is within 6 and 12 the
length 6 and 12 then we can
continue with our check so we can do
we'll do an statement for pass which
basically moves on to this
next block
now
once you've done this
what we will do is
this this first statement what this is
going to do is it's going to do an re
dot search an re dot search as you know
is going to look for at least one
instance of
a letter occurring between
a and z so this ire.search
followed by this now this is the regular
expression that we have passed and what
this tells us is basically the square in
the square brackets we're looking for
anything between
a and z in terms of small letters so if
this condition is not met then again we
continue and we leave this particular
search because one of our criterias is
not met
all right but if it is met then this if
not statement will not uh like we we
won't enter this block and we can move
on to the next check
so
now now we move to l if not now again
we're using if not statement so this is
basically checking for uh a negative
case so anytime one of these cases have
been met it basically means
that our password has been invalid
because these conditions are not being
met so we're trying to eliminate all
conditions all of these conditions so
that we get a valid password so again we
move on to the next statement which is
basically going to do the search for
numbers once again if we find a case
a password without any numbers we
continue and we don't um
check this password no more because we
already know it's a it's a an illegal
password now next check will be for
capital letters a to z and the next
check again will be for
these particular symbols the dollar the
hash and the at one of these three
symbols
uh we're going to search for a white
space character so if we actually do
find a white space character in our
password
that's an illegal password and we're not
going to continue checking for those
cases
so
so this is basically all our cases
lowercase letters
numbers capital letters these one of
these three symbols and the existence of
a white space so once we've done all
these checks if none of these have been
passed we move on to this else statement
where we just pass and what we can do is
we append the value p to the the list
called value
so basically what happens is
just to go through it again
if this condition is not met and this
condition is not met this is not met
this is not met this is not met and if
this is
also not met then we're fine so
basically as long as we have small
letters as long as we have a number as
long as we have a capital letter as long
as we have one of these three symbols
and as long as we don't have
any uh white space characters we can
append e to this otherwise it will
continue and it will break out of this
for loop completely that's what the
continued thing the continue statement
at the end of each of these blocks
checks um anytime this condition is met
this if not condition is met then we
break through we break through this
whole for loop and we don't append p to
the value but uh if we actually get to
this stage then what we can do is simply
append uh p to value
now finally what we are going to do is
we are going to print out all the valid
passwords so just by a quick look you
can see here this is a valid password
right so let's execute this and let's
see uh
what we get if you see here we only get
one valid password and let's look at why
some of these did not turn out to be
valid so if you look here all of the
conditions are met it has a capital
letter it has a small letter it has at
least one number and it has one of the
symbols either dollar sign or the hash
sign or the add sign in this case we
have two white spaces one over here and
one over here so this is an illegal
password similarly in this case also we
have an illegal password because it
begins with a space
in this case it's the same thing we
begin with a space and also it does not
have any of those symbols that we were
looking for the dollar or the hash or
the at so again so these three are
illegal passwords and they do not get
appended to value however this does get
appended to value and that's why we get
the result for only one password which
is the only legal password welcome to
web scraping with python my name is
richard kirchner with the simplylearn
team certainly there are many reasons to
be able to go online and scrape
different websites they range everything
from pulling out different links
to pulling data off of websites as a
data scientist you might need to get
some information off a website that
doesn't have a direct api to pull that
information and in python we have a
wonderful tool when you talk python and
utah web scraping we're talking
beautiful suit which is a package you
add into your python that you're running
and we can come over here to the website
www.crummy.com
software slash beautiful soup you can
actually read a little bit about it
currently beautiful soup 4 is the
current version if you don't remember
the full website for it you can always
do what i do which is go over and do a
search for beautiful soup official site
it almost always comes up right at the
top and you click on there and it'll
take you to the crummy.com software site
for beautiful soup now we're going to
use our whatever python interface you
want ide i'm going to use jupiter lab
which is built on jupiter notebook
through anaconda so when i open up my
anaconda navigator you'll see that i
have my different tools available again
you might be using a different editor
and that's okay you might be in pycharm
or something like that we don't need to
do this and
jupiter lab is jupiter notebook with
added tabs and some added features it's
basically in beta testing so it's got a
few little glitches when you're saving
things and moving between projects but
for the most part it's a great upgrade
to the jupiter notebook and you can use
them together so you don't have to i
mean it's built on jupiter notebooks
anything you do in jupyter notebook you
can open up in jupiter lab and the first
thing we need to do is we need to go
ahead in this case i'm going under my
environments since it partitions the
environments out and i'm going to open
up a terminal window we have to install
some packages in here to work with now
there's a lot of choices on this i
because of the simplicity we'll be using
conda install now you can use pip
install for the same thing and we're
going to install our beautiful soup four
and you have to type out the whole thing
beautiful soup for and use a pip install
if you're using a different environment
and i am using python version
3.6 although according to beautiful soup
they also work on 3 7 all the way from
27 through olive 3x now according to the
beautiful soup website the beautiful
soup 4 works on anything you can install
on anything from python 27 all the way
through any of the python 3 versions now
this just happens to be python 36
because i do there's a lot of other
packages that don't work on three seven
yet and we'll go ahead and run this
install on here and let it go through
its environmental setup and of course
with conda it goes in there and finds
all the dependencies pip doesn't do as
much as far as finding dependencies but
you know exactly what's on there with
pip so if you're doing a huge
distribution you probably want to use
your pip install so you can track what's
going on there with the
conda i like to just let it take over
since this isn't a major distributed
package going out another quick note
between pip and conda is that if you
start on a project in one of these
environments and you're using pip in
there stick with pip if you're using
conda stick with conda they track the
packages and you can run into some
issues where they're not tracking the
same packages and something gets
overwritten so it's important to stay
very consistent with your install on
your environments and we'll also need to
go ahead and install our numpy
environment and our pandas on here so go
ahead and do that if you haven't added
those packages in go ahead and install
those into your
environment that you're working in and
of course pandas is just simply uh
install pandas and let's just install a
couple more packages in this case let's
get our install our map plot library
because we're going to plot at the end
since we're going to be collecting data
and for this project that will be all
the packages we'll need so we can go and
close out of our installer or whatever
setup you have and we'll go back to home
and we'll just launch our jupyter lab
and that will open up in our browser
window now if you're coming from jupiter
notebooks and first time in lab we can
go ahead and just create our first
notebook python3 you can also do it
under a file launcher and you'll see new
notebook it automatically opens up and
we just click right on there it'll pop
open on the left and i'll right click
this and we'll rename this we'll rename
it just beautiful and it is a i i in b
file on there so that should look
familiar because that's the jupyter
notebook file this is a new one now i
have more tabs in the past i usually hid
this on the other computer all my notes
for the lesson today but this is my
notes going down and we'll go ahead and
just start going through this and see
what it looks like to do a data poll
from front to end and see how that works
as a data scientist pulling that
information in from the website and the
first thing i want to do is i want to go
ahead and close this side window that
way it looks get the nice full screen
and we can also up the size a little bit
one of the wonderful things about
working in a browser window just do that
control plus thing the packages we
talked about is pandas so we imported
our pandas if you haven't already that's
our data frame if you haven't done our
pandas tutorial definitely worthy of the
time to go through there and understand
pandas because it's such a powerful tool
this basically turns your data into a
spreadsheet data frame our numpy is our
number array uh so it kind of works with
pandas very closely as far as
manipulating data in arrays matplot we
want to go ahead and bring that in our
plt so that we can plot the data at the
end and this line right here that says
matplot library inline is for the
jupyter notebook specifically it tells
it to print that on this page a lot of
the newer versions don't actually
require to have that line they'll still
print it on the page but you should
still include that if you're in the
jupiter lab setup and then we have our
url library.request we're going to
import url open for opening up the
website and then we have our bs4 that's
your beautiful soup four we're going to
import beautiful soup and then our last
one is our re that is for manipulating
our regular expressions so we get to
that part of importing our data we have
to do a lot of reformatting so it's
something we can use and the re is one
of those tools we'll go ahead and run
this and just bring all that in so this
is all imported all these packages are
now into our web scraping program we're
going to run now if we're going to dive
in and pull data we should have a nice
website to pull from and let's go ahead
and we'll use the
upper timing.com results for the 2018
martin luther king race and if we take
this you can actually just take this
where did we get this from well you can
go in here and find the website you're
going to scrape from and you'll see
right here it says you just copy that
link right in there that http and this
is a website that we're looking at you
can see right here all the information
that we're looking at let's say we
wanted to run some statistics on this it
sure would be nice to be able to pull it
off of here and if they don't have a
direct api that means we need to pull it
from their website some of these will
have a download although if you've ever
done a we have a download click and
maybe you're paging through a hundred
websites in one case i was uh polling
all the different united states bills
that are passed to track who voted on
them for a project and you can imagine
that there's you know hundreds and
hundreds of those thousands of these
documents that they voted on who voted
on it goes through the senate goes back
to the congress so i opened up a website
pull all the links off of there that
match a certain criteria and we'll look
at that in just a minute how we go
through the html and then i had to
reformat them or i could hand download
each one one at a time which would just
be a nightmare so it's nice to automate
it in this case we're going to be
pulling up this chart we want to figure
out how to pull this chart off of this
website and so we go back into our
jupiter notebook i've got my url just
our name for it and it's just a string
that's all this is nothing fancy there
you'll notice that on the slashes we now
have forward forward slash you can do a
single forward and http is a double
forward this is just how you have to
switch it to match setup in there and
then it's going to go ahead and use the
html equals url open url and that's from
our url library request so it's opening
a link to that website or at least
pointing to it and if we run this this
just sets it up so this is all set up
and then once we've done our setup let's
go ahead and create an object called
soup this will be and if you remember up
here here's our beautiful soup that we
imported from the bs4 and this is the
package that we're working with and so
we're going to do our beautiful soup on
here and on this we need to go ahead and
send it our html so it knows what it's
opening and then the second part is we
have to tell it how the format is coming
in and the most common one for your html
polls is an lxml
setup and so almost all of them you'll
end up using the lxml there's a few
other options and because this is so
common uh in the newer versions a lot of
times they just leave it out just
because it's already on the default
we'll go ahead and leave it in here just
to remind us that it's there we'll go
ahead and run that and on the newer
versions uh they actually default it to
the xml setup in the html we'll just
leave it out and call it html so it's
just gonna pull from this url and when
we run that on here we've now created an
object soup that has pulled the website
into it so soup contains the information
along with information on that website
and what's going on so let's just go
over what we did real quick before we
start digging into the actual soup
before we start scooping out stuff we
imported our different
modules that we're going to use with our
package specifically the beautiful soup
we did install the beautiful soup if you
remember correctly you have to call it
beautiful soup 4 specifically so it
knows what you're bringing in and this
line right here is very key from bs4
because that's how it installs the
module we're importing our beautiful
soup and then we found our url in this
case we're going to go pull information
from the martin luther king dream run
and then we set our html to our url open
url and you can see right here we
imported that so here's our url.request
import url open so we're requesting a
connection and once we send that
connection into the beautiful soup it
creates an object called soup and then
this one of course we chose soup just
because it goes with beautiful soup i
guess we could have chosen beautiful and
now we can start extracting information
from our website because we pulled it
down onto our computer under soup now we
can start by looking at the title of the
website soup dot title and if we print
title dot text you'll see this a lot in
beautiful suit because title contains
all kinds of information and if we want
just the text from that title you add
the dot text on the end and you can see
right here we have our 2018 mlk dream
run 5k race results if you look at the
tab that's the actual title up here uh
2018 mlk dream run 5k race that's what
the title is on the website and then you
might be curious what's in title what's
the whole title that it's storing up
there well let's go ahead and print it
out here's print title and print
title.txt and we run that you can see it
has the html tags title on it and then
the forward slash title to end it and so
we're really just pulling off this piece
of the html code and then we look at the
text inside that particular part of the
html and earlier i mentioned links what
if you want to get all the links off
this page well that would be fun uh we
could do soup dot and we'll do find
underscore all put this in bracket and
then quotation marks we're going to put
a a is the
key find and you'll start seeing a div
and all the different options you have
for finding these entities in a website
and then let's go ahead and just print
our links and you can see here that it
now shows all the different links in
here that are marked by eggs we did a
find all a and then we can also because
this is a little bit hard to pull off
the h reference so we can also add in
our find all fine tune that in this case
the h reference equals true we'll
actually filter that out and then
finally we might do a four link in links
and we can simply do something like this
for each link we want to actually find
the h reference because we know there's
an h reference in it and if i run this
you can see it just comes through and
prints them out one at a time some of
these are really useful so you might be
looking for something that has https in
it and you know that's a link running to
something else or you might be looking
for the mail to tags you know that's all
the mail addresses but either way you
can easily find all the links in your
html document that you're paging through
and of course
any packages that have evolved over time
you can also do link dot get h reference
which should do the same thing as our
other format and you can see it
certainly does we get the same printout
up here in this particular case we
really want to get the data off the page
uh so let's go ahead and do that let's
see what that looks like and in data
let's call it all rows there we go
equals and then we have our soup dot
find underscore all there's our brackets
and then if we're looking for each row
in a database you'll remember your html
code we're looking for the tag tr so we
want to find all tr and we can take this
and let's go ahead and just take all our
rows and do a print all rows and about
this time you're going to guess that
we're going to get a huge amount of
information just dumped onto our page
and sure enough we do if you look at
this it just kind of goes on forever but
this is an array each row is considered
an array so because of that we can do
something simply as putting brackets and
just print the first let's do the first
five rows so uh from beginning to five
and you can see here's our first five
rows on here i sometimes like to just do
let's just do row zero and we see that
row zero is finishers finishers 191 and
just out of curiosity what's if that's
zero what's row one male okay so we're
starting to see titles going across here
so if we come up here and we do rows we
did what up to 10. let's just take a
look and see what 10 does again and just
take a look at that information that
comes across place
bib name gender age city state chip chip
pace gender and so on so it comes all
the way down here we kind of have an
ending right here and then we have one
and then we actually it looks like we
start to have information so we have our
one or one 1191 max randolph that must
be the name male 29 and so on you start
seeing how the information starts
getting displayed going down so the next
thing we want to do with this i'll go
back up here and just edit the space
we're in so it starts to make a little
bit more sense keep it all together and
so we want to do for each row in all
rows we're looking at what information
are we looking at well we have our th up
here that's a header our td down here
which looks like the individual
information and we really are looking
for
the actual data so we're looking for td
tags in the rows and we can do that
because when you remember when it stores
the row it also stores the tags
underneath that so all rows have all the
different tags in it and you can see
right here as you print each one of
those out and so we look at each row we
can create another variable we'll call
it row list and we'll set this equal to
in this case row because we've already
pulled all the rows out of soup so now
we want to find for each row and in
there we want to find our td and if we
go ahead and just print i'm going to do
it if you notice i changed the indent so
i'm just going to print row list what
this does is the last value to go into
row list our last row is going to print
now and of course make sure you have an
underscore instead of a period when
you're typing so row dot find underscore
all td and if we print the last row you
can see i have all the data coming
across here we have our 191 our 1216
zuma ochoa i hope i said that right
female i believe that's age 40 and so on
and then we can take our row list and
there's a lot of things we can do with
the row list what we'll do for let's do
object or let's just do cell in row list
and so we're going to look at each cell
because this is if you look at this they
have commas separated between the
different objects and then we're going
to go ahead and print cell dot text
let's just take a look and see what that
looks like and we can see here for each
row we get 191 there's our 191 there's
our 12 16 12 16
a individual who's in the race and so
forth all the way down for those
different settings let's go ahead and
create a new variable up here uh we'll
call this all let's just call it data
we'll keep it simple uh so here's our
data and then we have our row we take
our row we break it up into individual
cells so we'll call this
data row and we'll set this empty to an
empty row and we're going to take our
cells tab this we know that each cell
generates a text and so what we want to
do is i want to take my data row let's
just replace that let's take our data
row and let's append our cell dot text
so i'm going to add the each row is
going to be a row of the different text
on here and then once i create each row
i want my data which is going to be
everything to append each row and here's
our data row and then if we go ahead and
come down here and let's just print data
now if we were lurking with large data
we'd be very careful about just throwing
all our date on the page but you can see
here we throw the date on the page and
we get uh finishers 199 male 78 female
113 one and so on and if you look at
this this is the headers on the file we
have finishers
male females just like some general
statistics on the first one and then we
have actually uh
an empty data set and then we have our
data that continues which actually the
actual information we're looking for so
we have one 1191 max randolph mill 29
washington dc runtime uh one of 78 and
so on on here so we could really quickly
get rid of that number of different ways
to do that one of them is just to do
we're going to set if we do data 2 on we
should get rid of everything but we want
to keep randolph so make sure randolph
is in there oh we lost randolph let's
try one on there we go there's max
randolph on there uh so we can just
simply do redo our date on here and we
can do data probably want to do it in
all rows from one on but i'm just going
to do my data equals data one on down
here and there's reasons to split it
this way in data science sometimes you
don't want to touch the original data in
case you need it in case we do need the
first row so we'll put it down here and
maybe we'll just call this titles titles
equals data of zero and so we could do
something here where we print we'll
print up our titles and we'll print our
data in this case instead of one on
let's go minus
two let's look at the last two rows of
data so here we have our titles and for
some reason just put in finishers of 191
as expecting a little bit more up there
and we have our last couple people and
they look like the data on these looks
just fine on here turns out this is just
some generic statistics up here so we'll
get rid of titles completely it doesn't
really do us any good but we know that
data comes in here and we can look at
our data and look at the very end of the
data to the minus two to the end and we
can see it pulls the data in pretty good
we don't have anything too funky in here
we're looking at it looks pretty clean
now you got to be a little careful
because at some point we might have to
come back here and clean up the data if
we get an error for running a data
analysis we might find out there's some
unusual characters or something is
missed in the data itself and you also
notice that everything is a string so
when we're bringing it in we might have
to do some conversions to test it out
and convert them to whatever kind of
data format we're working with so at
this time we want to go ahead and bring
in our pandas um and let's go ahead and
call this idea for data frame we'll set
it equal to and if you remember
correctly we imported pandas as pd and
that's standard you'll see that in most
code examples where they call the import
pandas as pd
and it is capital d
capital f for data frame and we're just
going to bring in our data that's what
we called it on here and let's uh take
this and we'll print now when you're
working with data frames you're usually
talking large amounts of data and so you
almost never want to print the whole
data frame out we're going to go ahead
and do that anyway just so we can see
what that looks like and you can see in
here brings in our data frame coming in
here we just have a mess of information
this is our data let's go ahead and
print df and see what that looks like in
the data frame and this is nice because
it organizes it into a very easy to read
table and we have they set the label 0 1
2 3 4 5 6 and so on and then we have
each row we have mel
78
going across when we get all the way
down here we'll see max randall about
number three and the first thing this
does is this flags me that i brought in
a bunch of information up here that we
really didn't want
it's from three on that we want and we
can clean this up in one of two ways we
can try to clean it up under the data or
we can clean it up under the data frame
depending on what it is we're trying to
do and so to fix this
i want to go ahead and just change it up
here in the actual data pull in we don't
need that information so i'll rerun it
reload our data from foreon and then
when i run this we see we have max
randolph is right at the top of the list
like he should be and we have all the
data going down now with the data frame
remember i said we don't usually print
the whole data frame we'll go ahead and
do df.head and this prints the first
five rows and you can see that we have
13 columns here's max randall all the
way to theo kinmin and i usually also
print df
tail and the reason i like to do these
particular two setups i'm going to
change it just to two rows because you
can do that you can put as many rows as
you want is this good to look at the
first part and the end because those are
usually where you have extra data
brought in uh something's messed up and
you can also see that we have 190 rows
in here and it comes in with our zuma
lisha and they're both on here on the
list so now we have a nice data frame
columns and rows we can easily look at
it we can see the setup on here and we
can look at the names and everything now
at some point you might be looking at
these individual columns and find
different information that needs to be
re-edited if you can you try to do it
with the whole column under pandas you
can up in the upper part of the code
where you went from cell to cell or row
to row you could look at individual
cells maybe find a marker in that cell
that's something specific like remove
all colons or semicolons or something
and there are brackets there's a lot of
options in there but you'll find that
this one actually comes in pretty clean
on here all the way down and the next
thing we really want to do is we want to
look at the headers i don't know about
you but doesn't make any sense to me
when i have column one i don't know what
1191 is or 1080 need name kaiser runner
i'm guessing that's column two is names
third one looks like male or female
probably age but i don't want to guess i
want this to bring in my column so i
know exactly what i'm looking at so how
can we make beautiful soup do that for
us well let's take our column headers
we're going to set that equal to our
soup find underscore all and then we're
going to look for our headers our th
files and since we're in jupiter lab in
this case jupiter notebook i can just
type out column headers if it's the last
variable i have listed it will
automatically print it so it's kind of a
shorthand and we can see right here we
have place i'm guessing that's bib name
gender age city state chip time chip
pace and so on so we have all our
headers right there i shouldn't have to
type them all in and we'll go ahead and
do it before we'll go ahead and do a
header list equals our empty array and
then we can do for a column in column
headers and we can take our header list
and just append and what do we want we
want the text from the column so we'll
just do column.text and then if we come
down here and we print
our header list let's see what that
looks like if we did it right we should
get a nice list of all the different
column headings we want so we have place
bib name and so on and then pandas just
because pandas is so cool we can simply
do df columns equals our header from our
header list we simply said df column set
to df headers and then if i print
df.head we'll take a look at that and
we'll see right here it has nicely
placed our values on here place bib name
gender age and so on so very quickly
we've created this nice data frame we
have the data displayed in nice rows and
columns and easy to read and then as a
data scientist the first thing we want
to know is the info what is in these
columns and rows and headers and you see
right here they all come up with
non-null object there's a big flag so if
i want to do anything with this these
are all coming through as strings or an
object i usually mean strings in this
case that they're a string variable and
we have you can quickly read through
this 191 entries date columns total 14
columns there's a total of 14 columns in
the data and it shows you all the
different names and what type of column
they are and it's probably good also to
look at the shape of the data df.shape
we'll go ahead and just run that you see
it's 191 by 14 14 columns 191 entries
this is more like a we look at a numpy
array 191 by 14 for the shape and
remember this is a variable so if i put
it on if it's a last variable or last
value in the set of cells jupiter
automatically prints it out so if you're
in a different ide you want to go ahead
and use the print statement on here
then one of the things you'd want to
also go through we'll create a second
one df2 equals df dot drop in a now the
axis is automatically equal to zero so a
lot of times you'll see something like
axes equal zero comma how equals any
axis equals zero is default that means
we're looking at going down the rows you
could look at the column going across
let's remove the how any that's just
going to confuse you the axis is is
whether you're going down the columns or
if you're looking at a row by row by row
by row or you could be looking at it by
column by column by column this would
drop any column and it would drop off
the n a in any column and how equals and
we want any i always confuse all in any
they both start with a all means that
all of them have to be non-value where
any means that any of them can be there
to drop it so this would drop any column
with a null value in it but we want 0
and it'll drop any value with a null
value and then because 0 is always the
default we'll just leave it out and then
it's curious as to what the shape is now
did we lose anything was there any null
values in our df2 that we dropped from
the df and we'll go ahead and run that
and we see 191 and 14. so we didn't
really drop anything but it's always
good to check there's other ways you can
also do are there let's see any n a's
you can detect n a's in here no values
infinite values that's another one you
got to watch out for we're working with
data that we're going to do something
with here in a minute so you've got to
be a little careful also in the
convergence are you going to convert
something where people typed in weird
characters to describe the data a
certain way so now we've got to this
point where we have all our different
columns we have our different data and
at this point maybe you're asking or
maybe the shareholder the company is
asking hey can we look at the
based on the chip time here's our chip
time can we plot that versus gender how
does gender versus chip time compare and
so we can do that we can take that and
the first thing we look at is we say hey
well chip time came in as a string and
that's going to be an issue now there's
a number of ways you can change this one
of them is we could go all the way back
up here where we created the data and
find a way to tag it and say hey
whenever this cell text maybe instead of
appending this i notice that any time
there's two colons in it that's probably
a time signature and let's uh convert
all the time signatures to date time
filled or whatever a lot of times you
don't get that you don't get that option
and that's always a question in bringing
in data whether you convert the data
coming in at the beginning or do you
wait till you have it open it up and
then convert it when you go to use it
we're going to go ahead and convert it
after we got it into our data frame so
we have our df2 here we've dropped all
of our n a's we dropped our we have a
shape in fact let's do this since
there's no difference between df and df2
well we'll just go ahead and use df2 so
let's go ahead and take our df2 and we
want to take those that specific field
and convert it into some kind of
numerical value we can use and let's add
another column a lot of times this is
something you want to do is where you
want to go ahead and keep all the
original columns and just add a new
column in there and this new column is
going to be based on the if remember
correctly we had chip time that's what
we're going to look at okay we want chip
time versus gender if we go into our
pandas we find out we have pandas 2
delta and this is actually time delta
and then we just want to take our df2
and we're going to use the chip time
column so this is going to say hey let's
look at let's convert everything in df2
chip time into a time delta format
that's the data type we're going to put
it as let me go ahead and just run this
and if we go in here and we do info df2
and we'll keep our we're going to look
at this particular column but we want to
keep it as a data frame uh so this is a
list of all the columns we want to look
at we'll just do that info on here and
run that and we do an info on that you
can see it's now a
time delta 64 nanoseconds uh well we
really don't want nanoseconds we
actually probably want to do it in
minutes uh so let's take a look at that
and let's take this whole thing tf2
let's just set the df2 we have our df2
this is a column we're working with here
and we can use the as type property in
pandas and so we can set this equal to
df2 we'll take our same
column in here and we'll set it as type
time delta seconds so it's still a delta
time here so if i run this you'll see
that it still comes up as where is it
hopefully it turns it into a float so
we're now at a float 64 so it's the
number of seconds in that delta time and
then finally uh we want to go ahead and
turn that from seconds to say minutes
and you know there's 60 seconds and
minutes and so now we divide by 60 we
still have a float we have our info that
shows us it's a float and then we can go
ahead and just do a print df2 and let's
just keep it small we don't want to look
at all our data we just want to do the
head of it and we run this and you can
see right here where we go to it'll be
the last one here's our chip time in
minutes a lot of times uh just to make
life easy for viewing since we're only
looking at this particular element we
can do chip time in minutes and now we
just see that oops we take off we'll go
ahead and take off our info done with
that and we'll run this and you can see
we have our minutes 16.8 minutes 17.51
minutes and so on it's a float number
now keep in mind this is 0.8 that's not
a 16 minutes and 80 seconds that they
can always throw you if you're going
through so many numbers you forget so
important to remember that and we're
also going to look at the other one
we're looking at is what gender you want
to look at gender to
chip time in minutes and so we can see
here under the head we get male male
male and a number of different setups
and let's switch this to tail real quick
and just look at the end of it and here
we have female female male female female
so we have two different genders and we
have our chip time in minutes and if you
remember we brought in our plt if you
haven't used the plot library the
matplot library you have a drawing place
you're putting stuff on so we have our
plt we're going to do a bar graph and we
just want to simply use our df2 gender
and df2
chip time in minutes so that's going to
plot the two bars and to make it pretty
we'll go ahead and give it the x label
gender the y label chip time minutes and
that simply is remember it always plots
x in the plots y we have our gender our
chip time give it a nice title uh
comparison of average minutes run by
male and female uh and if we go ahead
and run this with the correct titles in
here and everything matches you'll get a
nice graph we can see here the
comparison of average minutes run by
male and female here's our chip time in
minutes the men seem to be slackers in
this particular case and it's actually
uh there's a number of studies that show
that women team tend to have as far as
doing cross-country there's a lot of
women who have a longer endurance than
men so it's not too surprising uh we can
see here the average chip time around 70
and for women over 100 minutes and then
another really cool thing we can do is
we can describe the data so
df2.describe this again is a pandas
function just like info is and we're
going to include uh np number the numpy
number and if we run that you'll see
here comes up and says chip time in
minutes a count it gives you the average
or the mean standard deviation the
minimum the maximum all the different
descriptive information you're going to
want from your data set on there and
just because there's all kinds of fun
ways let's do a box plot to display your
information uh we can do a box plot
where the column equals chip time in
minutes and let's go ahead and run that
keep mistaking my chip time in minutes
you can see it puts out a nice box plot
showing you the information we have our
different values and floaters this is
always interesting because this is a
nice way of seeing where we have these
uh floaters one up here and there's two
up above and of course here they're a
nice spread on the box plot and we can
also modify this a little bit and we can
add in by equals gender and then we'll
give it we'll just give it a blank title
i don't know why we're giving a blank
title uh we'll just add a y plot y label
on there for run time and if we run this
you can see here box plot grouped by
gender chip time in minutes and now we
have our female and male two different
areas and you can see how they vary you
have your two different uh your outlier
up here and you can also see how there's
such an overlap between the two
different values so if i was looking at
this i'd be like wow you know i really
could not draw a conclusive thing on
this saying that women's run time was
more in general because they overlapped
too much that would be one of the
conclusions i'd have to come up with
done here and then we get to maybe the
partners come in from the company and
say hey we'd like to know the age versus
chip time in minutes that'd be something
worth knowing on the statistics on this
and the first thought is we can simply
plot it and we can do this we can
actually plot the scatter plot chip time
versus df2 of h there's our xy
coordinates but if you remember from df2
when we did the info let's go way back
up here we're looking at a data object
as far as our chip time on this and our
h now we converted the chip time but we
also need to convert the age and if we
do it right here we just plot it and
it'll actually let us plot it it
shouldn't it should give us an error but
it does let us plot it you'll see the
ages come up a mess over here because
they're converting it to weird float
numbers and all kinds of things so we
want to do is we want to take our age
and we'll just call this ah underscore i
so we're going to take our age and we're
going to create another column for df2
age underscore i and the i is just going
to stand for integers our own choice of
values there is a number of ways to do
this but we're going to do pandas 2
merrick is the best way in pandas and
the reason we're doing this is that
numeric creates a float value so right
off the bat we want all our stuff
converted it converts it to the least
common denominator so if they're all
integers already you'll get integers as
you can see from here it's doing some
kind of conversion that converts it to a
float value the other thing that numeric
does is if there is a null value or they
put in like a blank line or a dash to
represent no information it'll convert
it to a
null so it goes from like a string to a
null versus just having some kind of
made up number that python somehow
created for the graph we have below and
then we want to add our df2h because
that's what we're converting to numeric
and then we want to coerce it and
there's a couple different options on
this like you can have it where it just
doesn't process it in pandas but coerce
means that if it gets a weird value that
is a null value now and since we're
dealing with errors this is what happens
when you get an error converting it we
want to coerce it there we go and put
the end bracket on there and then
finally we want to go and round this off
so i'll put brackets around all the way
around it and this rounds off everything
in this series so we've done here is
i've taken df2h which is a d type object
which in this case is mostly strings
with a couple of blank ones in there and
we're going to convert it to a numeric
which will automatically go to float and
then we're going to take wherever
there's an error wherever it says hey
this doesn't convert and usually that's
a blank screen like i said i've worked
with so many databases where they
someone puts down none someone types in
space sometimes in a dash to mean none
and you get this really weird conversion
coming up this covers all of that in
pandas so it's really a nice way of just
coercing it and saying hey if we don't
have a number in there let's make it a
null value and then we're going to round
it off and then finally let's go ahead
and take our df2 here's our df2 and
let's drop those null values drop in a
and we want how how equals any so that
means if there's any null values in the
data set now you can this might get you
in trouble because you might have null
values in a different column and so you
might lose
data that way at this point we could
also do like certain parts of like drop
just certain columns with null values
there's all kinds of other options in
here what we're just going to do how
we're going to just drop any and we want
to do it in line equals true so that
means it's going to reassign it to
df2 so df2 now has a rounded out so it's
rounded to the integer we didn't do any
places the age and it's going to be age
i and then we've dropped all our null
values that way we're not going to get
any errors when we try to plot a null
value and it also makes sure that data
by deleting out the rows because that's
what this does it automatically does
axis0 which is your rows axes one is
your column by doing this it
automatically removes all the rows with
null values so it just cleans out the
rows and then when we go ahead and plot
this we see we have a nice clean data
and we have age all the way up to 70 so
we have our chip time set and then our
age going across and it makes a nice
plot that you can easily show for
display and for the the and you can
easily show that to your shareholders or
whatever group you're working on it
makes a really nice and quick easy
display in this session we will discuss
the top tips and tricks in python that
you can use to solve your problems first
let's understand what python really is
so python is a high level open source
programming language developed in 1989
by guido van rosso
it has simple easy to use syntax
python can run on different platforms
such as windows linux and unix
it has a large collection of libraries
and can be integrated with other
programming languages such as c c plus
and java
companies use python for web development
software development statistical
analysis machine learning and deep
learning
python trips and tricks will help you
optimize the code and reduce your time
and effort while writing codes for
solving problems
these tips and tricks are usually short
snippets of python code with simple
illustrations to tell you
how you can perform a complex task
easily
it can also serve as examples that allow
you to dive deep into understanding and
exploring how each concept works and
where it can be used
so in this video we'll be covering the
tips and tricks based on python lists
tuples sets and dictionaries we'll also
see how to effectively use loops
iterators and collections in python
so let me take you to my jupyter
notebook where i'll show you the
different tips and tricks
so here is my jupyter notebook
so let's begin with our first trick
if you want to initialize a list or a
tuple filled with repetitive strings or
numbers written in the form of a string
we can do that using the multiplication
operator
so let me show you
so first i'll declare a list suppose a
is equal to within square brackets i'll
declare a string suppose
india
and now
if i use the multiplication operator and
suppose i say 10
then i'll print a
so this will print india 10 times
if i hit shift enter it will run that
cell you can see we have printed india
10 times
similarly
let's add another element to our list
or another item to our list
so india and then we have
france
i'll use the multiplication operator and
apply 10
so let me print my list again
if i hit shift enter you can see india
and france have been printed 10 times
also
you can use
an integer
as a string
and print as many times as you want
suppose i am printing 20 five times
i'll use the print statement
you can see we have printed 20 five
times
but
if i pass an integer as my first operand
it will result in the product of the two
numbers so for example if i use c
equal to
20 into 5
and if i print c
it will give me the product of 20 and 5
that is 100
next let's see how we can reverse the
elements in a list for that we'll use
the list slicing method
let me first show you how you can
reverse a string
i'll declare my
list as list 1 is equal to
and inside this list i'll
pass in a few country names such as
india then we have
usa
let's say we have france
and then
germany
and finally we have
spain
now if you want to reverse the order of
this list
you can use the slicing method inside
the print statement so i'll write
print
and i'll pass in my list that is list 1
and i'll use
double colon
followed by -1
so this will read my list from the end
so if i hit shift enter you can see we
have reversed
our original list so now spain comes
first then germany france usn india
likewise you can also reverse
a list of numbers
so
let's reverse a list of numbers
suppose this time i'll use list 2 is
equal to
i'll pass in few integers say 100
200
300
and 400
now if i
print
my list
two
using colon colon minus one
it will reverse list two
you can see we have reversed our
original list two so now four hundred
comes first then three 300 200 and 100
now let me tell you how you can print
the elements in a list in any order that
you prefer
suppose i have a list that has values
like 1 comma 2
3 and 4
then i'll print this list
after that
i'll use four variables
such as e comma b comma c comma d
and assign it to our list
after that let me
go ahead and print
any order that i want for example i use
b comma a comma d comma c
and hit
shift enter you can see we have printed
our list in the order that we wanted
so basically what this cell does is
we have assigned
the value 1 from list to a
2 to b
3 to c and 4 to d
and we are printing in an order b a d c
so this is the result you can see
now suppose you want to print in some
other order like
say i want
c first
then i want b
a
and then d
so this is the output
up next
we will discuss list comprehensions in
python so list comprehension is an
effective way to define and create new
lists based on existing lists
so suppose you want to extract and
separate all the letters from the word
simply learn and add letters as items of
a list ideally you would use a for loop
to do this task
so let's see how you can perform this
task using a for loop i'll assign an
empty list say letters
is equal to
i'll use
square brackets to assign my empty list
then
and declare a for loop
suppose for i in
i'll pass in my string that is
simply learn
and
i'll append the letters
using the append function
now let me go ahead and
print
the letters
if i hit shift enter you can see
this will print all individual letters
present in the word simply learn
but the same job
you can do it easily with the help of
list comprehensions
so let me show you how to do that
first i'll declare a variable say
letters
is equal to inside square brackets i'll
write
i
for
i in my string
simply learn
then i'll just
print the letters
you can see we have extracted all the
letters from the word simply learn
so this is how we use list comprehension
now similarly
if you were to find the square of
numbers you would like to create a user
defined function or use a for loop to do
it so let me show you how you can
proceed
so
before to define a function so first
i'll import
the math module present in python
and then let's say i am defining a
function called
square
and i'll pass in a parameter as a
then i'll write e is equal to
i'll use
the power function
so i'll first
give in my module name that is math and
use the power function that is pow
and i'll pass in my parameter that is a
and since we want to find the square
i'll given 2
and i'll
return my parameter that is a
if i hit shift enter now we have
successfully run our user defined
function
now let me call that function
if i write
square of a
it has given me one by default
now suppose i want to find the square
of integer five
you can see it has given us the square
of 5 that is 25
now to find the square of a number you
can also create an empty list and use a
for loop to iterate through a sequence
of numbers and append the square of
numbers to that empty list
so let me show you how you can do with
this process suppose i
declare an empty list called squares
i'll pass in my empty list
and then i'll use a for loop say for
example for
i
in
range
i'll give 10 as my range
and then
i'll append my square value so i'll
pass in my empty list that is squares
dot
append
so i'll use squares dot append
and pass i
into i
and then
i'll just
call my
empty list squares
if i hit shift enter
you can see
from 0 to 9 that is a range of 10 values
it has printed all the squares of those
integers
now these two methods that we just
discussed need at least three to four
lines of code but by using a list
comprehension you can find the square of
numbers in just a single line of code
so let's use a list comprehension to
find square of 5 whole numbers between 0
and 20 having an interval of 4. so i'll
use
squares
is equal to
i'll say x
double multiplication operator
into 2 for
x
in
say range
i'll pass in my range that is from 0 to
20
with an interval of 4.
now i'll
print
squares
if i hit shift enter
you can see it has printed the square of
values so first
the number is 0 so 0 square is 0 then
the number was 4 so 4 square is 16 8
square is 64
then 12 square is 144 and then 16 square
is 256.
moving ahead
in the next trick
i'll show you how you can keep track of
the index positions and the items in a
list
so for that we will use the enumerate
function to print the item values along
with the index positions
so let's say
i have a list
that has items
say
310
294 i'm taking random integers
450 and say 243
and now
if i
use a print statement suppose
i'll write using the
enumerate function
then i'll use a for loop say for example
for
index
comma
element
in
enumerate
i'll pass in my
list that is list underscore items
after that
i'll use a print statement
i'll pass in
index
and then
i'll give
a list
and that will have my
index
followed by
the value
i'll use another comma and pass in the
element
now if i hit shift enter you can see
we have printed the index position as
well as the item value so at index 0 we
have 310 at index 1 we have 294
similarly for index 2 and 3.
now moving ahead
let us understand how we can convert to
less into a dictionary so a dictionary
as you must be aware comes with a key
value pair
you can use the dictionary method and
pass the zip function
with our list as parameters
so let me define our two lists say item
number and names
so i'll use
item number
and give him some random whole numbers
102
410
and let's say 321
and i'll use my second list
that is names
and let's say this list has
some string values like phone
next is laptop
and then we have say tablet
now
i'll
assign a variable say item
dictionary
is equal to i'll use the
dict function
and then pass in zip
and i'll pass in my parameters item
number and
names
finally i'll print
my newly created dictionary that is item
dictionary
now let me run it
so you can see we have a dictionary
created out of the list
so our keys are 102 410 and 321 and the
item values are phone laptop and tablet
now you can check that in the following
way so i'll
pass in my dictionary
and then i'll use the keys function to
get the keys from the dictionary so you
see
we have all the keys printed similarly
if you want to print the
values from the dictionary
i'll use the values function
so that will print all the values you
can see we have phone laptop and tablet
now we look at how you can find the
common elements in two list
so let me declare my first list as list
underscore a
that will be equal to
davis
then let's say we have
keren
then we have
john
we have frank next
and then let's see we have another
person say
steve and let me declare my list
b
so list underscore b
is equal to i'll take kerin
next we have davis
then suppose we have
jack
up next we have
george
and then say we have steve again
now to find the common elements i'll use
variable let's say common
and i'll again
use a list comprehension say a
for
a
in
list a
then use for
b
in
list
b
then i'll use an if
clause so if
a
equals to equals to b
then
i'll
print the common variable
if i run this you can see we have the
common elements printed from both the
list a and b
so davis kerin and steve are present in
both list a and b
next let's see how you can remove the
duplicate items in a list
such problems you would often come
across while doing data analytics so the
idea is very simple just need to convert
the items in a list into a set
so that will remove all the duplicate
items in a list
so suppose i have a list of
numbers
let me take random whole numbers 20
22
24
so 26
then we have 28 repeated twice
and then again suppose we have 20
and we have 22
and let's say we have 30.
now
let me go ahead and print my list
so i'll say original list
equals to
and then i'll pass in my
list that is list numbers
after that
i'll convert my list that is list
numbers
into a set
so i'll first use the list function and
then inside of that i'll pass in my set
function and then declare
my list
that is list numbers
finally i'll
print my new list
so i'll type
list
after
removing
duplicates
that will be equal to
i'll give a comma and then pass in my
variable
that is list numbers
if i run it
you can see our original list has all
the elements that has duplicate values
and the final list the output you can
see we have only the unique elements
printed
moving on
now let's have a look at how you can
merge two dictionaries
so there are two methods to do this
before that let's see how the code would
have looked like had you merged the
dictionaries using python 2 version or
python 3.4 version and below
so let's see i have two dictionaries say
team a
i'll use curly braces to declare my
dictionary
i'll give my key as one and i'll take
davis
i'll give my
second key
and see i have
andrew in my team
and then let's say i have my
third key
and let's
see i have kerin
similarly let me declare my
team b dictionary
i'll take
the next key as
4
and the next person would be
say john
and then
i'll use my fifth key
we have angela
and let's see i have my final member in
the team
the sixth member
who is suzanne
now
if you do it in python 2 or python 3.4
version and below i have to define a
function so let me say define
merge underscore
teams which will be my function name
and i'll pass in two parameters say
dict 1
and
dict
2
then i have
dict
3
indict 3
i'll use the
copy method so i'll
use dict
1 dot
copy
then
let me go ahead and
use my
dict
3
dot
update
i'll
pass in my
dict
2
and then
see i'll
return
my dict
3
finally
i'll print it so i'll use
merge underscore teams
then pass in my two parameters as team a
comma
team b
if i run it oops there is a mistake i
have made so
this should be
dict 2 actually
so let me run it once again you can see
we have merged both our
dictionaries
now you can see it has around six to
seven lines of code or even more
now if you want to do this task using
python 3.5 version and above you can use
the update method so let's see how we
can do
i have say a
is equal to
i'll pass in my dictionary
as
a
has value of 1
say b has a value of
2
let's say b also has a value of 1
and my
second dictionary would have
key b again
and it has a value of 2
and key c
will have a value of 1.
now if i write a dot
update
b
and if i print a
let me run it you can see we have merged
both the
dictionaries here
now there's one more method which you
can use
let me show you
so i'll copy paste
my team a and team b again
and then
let's say i'll declare
another variable called
final team
that will be equal to
i'll use curly braces and then say
i'll give 2 star and then team e
comma
2 stars again
and then
team
b
then i'll print my
final team if i run it you can see we
have merged both are t m and b and this
is our final team that has
six elements
now before moving to the next trick if
you have enjoyed watching this video so
far then please consider subscribing to
our youtube channel and hit the bell
icon to never miss an update
also if you want to get the source file
i am using in this live session then
please mention your email ids in the
chat section we'll share the source code
with you over email
now let's move on
similar to a list comprehension we can
also create a dictionary comprehension
let me show you the trick
suppose i want to find the square of
numbers so i'll pass in my variable that
is square
and i'll use my dictionary comprehension
say x
comma x
star star 2 this will find the square of
a number
for x in
range
say 5 so i want the square of the first
5 numbers
then let me just
call it
you can see it has
printed
a dictionary that has the square of
numbers from 0 to 4 that is 5 numbers so
0 square is 0 1 square is 1 2 square is
4 3 square is 9 and 4 square is 16.
now let's see the trick to check if all
the elements in a sequence are true or
false based on a condition
you can do this with the help of all
function all function in python returns
true if all the items in an iterable are
true otherwise it returns false
so i'll directly use my
all function
so i'll say all
now let's see i'll use a variable a
percentage 2 if it's equal to equal to 0
and i'll say for a
in
range
between 0 to 10 with an interval of 2
if i run it
it gives me true
because i have defined my range
from 0 to 10 and an interval of 2 so the
numbers will range from 0
2 4 6 8 and so on
so all these numbers are divisible by 2
and the remainder is 0 so it gives us
true
now if i
change the third parameter in my range
function see i'll make it
3
and i run it
it gives me false
up next we look at a common programming
question that you often get to see in
any interview or programming test
that is swapping two numbers
let's see the trick to swap two numbers
in a single line of code
so i'll
declare two numbers see x and y
let's say we have xs10 and ys20
i'll use a print statement
say before
swap
give a comma and i'll declare my
variables x comma y
now to swap two variables i can simply
use x comma y equal to
[Music]
y comma x
and then i'll again use a print
statement say
after swap
and i'll write x
equal to
say
x
and
y
will have the variable
y
if i run it
you see before swap x had 10 and 20
and after swap you can see we have
x as 20 and y is 10.
so we have swapped the values of the two
variables successfully
now moving on
the next trick i am going to show
is how you can concatenate a list
containing strings
so we'll use the join function for this
let's see i have a list
characters
and it has a list of strings
say p
comma
y
comma
t
comma h
comma o
and we have the final string that is n
now if you were to concatenate all the
list elements
i'll declare a variable called word and
double quotation marks
and then i'll use the dot operator and
join function
i'll pass in my list that is
character
then i'll
print my variable
bird
below you can see the resultant output
so we have successfully combined or
concatenated each element or item in the
list character so we have python printed
now let me show you how you can find the
most frequently occurring values in a
list
so
i'll declare a list called test
and suppose it has some random whole
number c one comma two comma three
four
two comma two then we have three comma
one comma
four comma four comma four
i'll use
print statement
and pass in my max function
then i'll convert the list into
a set
give a comma
and then i'll use key is equal to
test dot count
so what it basically does is
it will first
count
the number of times each element is
occurring and then
find the maximum value out of it
if i hit shift enter you can see it has
given me 4 which means
the item 4 has occurred the most number
of times in my list you can see we have
four four times
moving forward the next step is how you
can use the if else statement using
ternary operators
ternary operators are commonly known as
conditional expressions in python these
operators evaluate something based on a
condition being true or false
so i have my two variables a comma b
and it has values
10 and 20 respectively
now if i
use a print statement say both a
and
b
are
equal
if
a equals to equals to b
else
a
is
greater than
b
if
a greater than
b
else b
is
greater
than
a
so first i am evaluating this condition
if a
is equal to equal to b then will print
both a and b are equal
else
if a is greater than b will print a is
greater than b
if both the conditions are false we'll
print b is greater than a
so let me run this
we have the output b is greater than a
because
our b value is 20 and a is 10 so b is
greater than a
now let me create a numpy array and find
the cumulative sum in a sequence of
numbers
for this you can use the cumsum function
first i have to import my numpy library
so i'll write
import
numpy as np
then
i'll declare a variable
say res which is for result
i'll use a list function
and then
pass in my [ __ ] sum function
and let's say i'll give a range of 10
finally i'll print the result
if i run this
you can see we have
calculated the cumulative sum of the
numbers ranging
from 0 to 9
so
the first element is 0 then the next
element is 1 so 0 plus 1 is 1
the next element is 2 so 1 plus 2 is 3
then 3 plus 3 is 6
6 plus 4 is 10 10 plus 5 is 15 and so on
let's now understand how you can use
iter tools in python
iter tool is a module in python that
implements a number of iterator building
blocks
it provides several functions that work
on iterators to produce complex
iterators
we will see an example to find the list
of matches to be played between the
teams in a league here we consider each
team will play against all the other
teams in the league
so to use the item tools i'll first
import it so i'll write import
iter tools
and then let me go ahead and declare a
list say
football
underscore clubs
let me take
a few club names say manchester
united
then we have
real madrid
i'm taking the top clubs from europe
the next club we have is say arsenal
followed by
chelsea
then we have
say liverpool
and finally we have
barcelona
then
i'll use my list function
and
use another function that is present
inside the item tools
library that is
combination
so it will give me all the possible
combinations
i'll pass in my
list
name that is football underscore clubs
and i'll give another parameter that is
r equal to 2.
if i run it
you have all the matches that would be
played in this league
as i mentioned each team will play
against all the other teams
now we will see the trick to print the
total permutations in a given set of
numbers using the item tool and its
functions
now to do this i'll use a
for loop so i'll use for
p
in
iter tools
dot
i'll use permutations function
so
permutations
and then let's see i'll pass in my
list that has values 1 comma 2 comma 3
and 4.
i'll print it
i'll use print
then i'll use the
join function
convert it into a string
for
x in
p
if i run it
you can see below we have all the
permutations listed
up next
let me tell you how you can print all
the false values present in a list
now to do this we can use the filter
false function present in the item tools
module
so i'll use list
and then
use my item tools
dot
filter false function
i'll pass in
bool as my
data type
let's say we have a list containing none
then we have false
we have 1
comma 0 comma
10.
if i run it
it will print all the false values
present in the list so we have none
false and zero
so if you have liked watching this video
so far then please subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell icon to
stay updated with all the trending
technologies
also if you want to get the source file
that i am using in this live session
then please mention your email ids in
the chat section our team will share the
source code with you over email
again if you have any questions related
to the tips and tricks we have discussed
so far
then please put your queries in the chat
section our team will answer it in the
chat
up next
let me show you the trick to perform
certain mathematical operations inside a
list containing pairs of tuples
first we look at how to add elements in
a list of tuples
so for that i'll import my iter tools
you can skip this step because we have
already imported a writer tools module
and then i'll import
operator
we have
a list of tuples say a2 comma 5.
then we have
10 comma 4
we have
another pair says 60 comma
3.
now i'll use
list function
and inside of it i'll use my item tools
module
so i'll write iter tools dot
star map function
and
i'll use my operator
and
add
comma
i'll pass in my list that is a
now if i run it
we have the addition of the pairs of
tuples present in the list so first
pair is 2 comma 5 so the addition
is 7
then 10 plus 4 is 14 and 60 plus 3 is
63.
similarly you can also multiply the
pairs of tuples in a list
and just copy paste this code and here
instead of add
i'll use
mul to multiply
if i run it
we have the output below
so 2 into 5 is 10 then the product of 10
and 4 is 40 and 60 and 3 is 180
now let us explore a bit about the
collections module in python
so the collections module implements
specialized container data types
containing alternatives to python's
general purpose built-in containers such
as list tuple dictionaries and set
i'll show you how to change the order of
the keys inserted in a dictionary using
the ordered dict function
so first i need to import the ordered
dict
function from the collections module
so i'll write from
collections
import
ordered
dict function
then
i'll say d is equal to
ordered
predict
dot
i'll use the from keys
and let's say
i have my key as e b c d e
then i'll
use another function called
move
to
end
and let's say i want to move my key b to
the end
then
i'll use inverted commas
and pass in my join function
and inside that i'll say d dot
keys
if i run it
you can see we have shifted the key b to
the end
now if you want to move the key b to the
beginning
you can do something like this
so let me copy the last two lines of
code from the above cell
i'll paste it now here i can give
another
parameter that is last
and i'll say
false
if i run this
can see we have the key b in the
beginning now
now the final trick i am going to show
you is how to perform mathematical
operations using a lambda function in
python
so lambda is an anonymous function that
does not have a name
it can have any number of arguments but
only one expression
the expression is evaluated and the
result is returned
so let's see how to add and subtract
numbers in one line of code using the
lambda function
so first i'll declare a variable say
function
is equal to
and i'll assign a dictionary
i'll pass in my
sum
and then
use the lambda function
i'll pass in variables x comma y
and i'll add x plus y
similarly
i'll now
subtract
i'll use the lambda function again
pass in my variables x comma y
and i'll write x
minus y
now
let me run it
so if you want to find the sum of two
numbers
so i have to call this first so i'll use
func
and using
square brackets i'll give my sum
and then pass in my values say 10 comma
3 this will add 10 plus 3 and return the
result as 13
similarly
if you want to subtract two numbers
i'll just write
subtract here instead of sum
and it will return the result that is 10
minus 3 that which is seven
i think with that we have covered all
the important tips and tricks that you
should know in python welcome to python
interview questions
certainly the questions we're going to
ask in here are very general with a few
specifics towards data science since
that's the main direction that python's
going in and you'd want to expand your
questions for your interview depending
on the domain that you're using the
python in specifically let's dive in and
get started with some python interview
questions number one what is the
difference between shallow copy and deep
copy and you can see with shallow copy
we have object one which has child one
child two child three and so on and
object two which has child one child two
child three a deep copy creates a
different object and populates it with
the child objects of the original object
therefore changes in the original object
is not reflected in the copy copy.deep
copy creates a deep copy shallow copy
creates a different object and populates
it with the references of the child
objects within the original object
therefore changes in the original object
is reflected in the copy copy.copy
creates a shallow copy and you can look
at this if we make a change to child one
it's only a pointer so if you make it in
object one and change to child one and
object one it will also make that change
in object two number two how is
multi-threading achieved in python oh
this is a good one with multi-processing
and multi-threading this question is
actually asking you do you know the
difference between multi-processing and
multi-threading and how multi-threading
works multi-threading usually implies
that multiple threads are executed
concurrently the python global
interpreter lock doesn't allow more than
one thread to hold the python
interpreter at that particular point of
time so multi-threading in python is
achieved through context switching it's
very different than multi-processing
which actually opens up multiple
processes across multiple threads so
multi-threading discuss the django
architecture so the django architecture
and the first thing to know is that the
django is a web service way to build
your web pages basically and so we look
at the architecture you can see here we
have a nice model drawn out where the
user initiates the django which
initiates the url which indicates the
view what they're going to view and you
have your model and your template so the
model of data whatever data model you're
pulling goes into the template and then
goes back up the pipeline to the user
and the important thing to note is
there's a template the front end of the
web page this is what they're going to
see there's a model the back end where
the data is stored so you can keep the
template and the looks and everything
looks the same but you can swap out the
underlying formation that goes into that
template then you have your view which
interacts with the model and template
and maps it to the url and then the
django serves the page to the user so
your django grabs it and says okay thank
you for the url and here you go user
what advantage does numpy array have
over a nested list so numpy's a module
you import almost always see numpy
import numpy as np
numpy is written in c such that all is
complexities are backed into a simple to
use module lists on the other hand are
dynamically typed therefore python must
check the data type of each element
every time it uses it this make numbi
arrays much faster than lists i would
also add in that numpy has a lot of
additional functionality that you don't
have in lists there's a lot of things
you can automate in the numpy quick flip
over to our jupyter notebook any ide
will work if you're going to do a set of
interview questions taking a quick look
at code is always important we have our
import numpy as np we'll go and import
time here's our list list sub for iron
range of 100 and what we're doing is
we're going to time it so we're going to
create a list then we're going to create
a numpy zeros array and you can see here
look how quick you can create this numpy
zeros array here we are appending one
zero at a time for a regular python list
and here we are with numpy they're all
zeros and they're all of type integer i
believe it's either float or integer on
this i'd have to actually do a type on
it and then so if we take in and we
create a tl1 time equals time and then
we do for i and range of 100 for j and
range of 100 l of i j equals l of i j
plus 5. so we're just doing a simple
calculation on our array and sub arrays
this is an array of rays and we'll do
the same thing with tl2 tl2 time.time
tl1 so here we have our final time on
that and then we'll do this with an
array array op and this is what i really
love a equals a plus 10 and then you can
just print it right out so you can see
right here with a numpy array i'm doing
the same thing if i run this our time is
significantly different here we have
0.09 and 0.003
so you can see that the time drops
significantly when you're running this
on a numpy array versus a list array
also important to note these times
aren't going to be they'll change each
time i run it depending on what i have
running in the background so there we go
number five what is pickling and
unpickling amazes me how many times i
pickle and unpickle something converting
a python object hierarchy to a byte
stream is called pickling pickling is
also referred to as serialization
unpickling converting a byte stream to a
python object hierarchy is also called
unpickling unpickling is also referred
to as deserialization so if you just
created a neural network model you can
now save that model to your hard drive
pickle it and then you can unpickle it
to bring it back into another software
program or to use at a later time how is
memory managed in python number six
python has a private heap space where it
stores all the objects the python memory
manager manages various aspects of this
heap like sharing caching segmentation
and allocation the user has no control
over the heap only the python
interpreter has the access you have a
nice little diagram here here's your
program there's your interpreter we have
our heap memory management on the
garbage collector going off of there
number seven are arguments in python
pass by value or by reference arguments
are passed in python by reference this
means that any change made within a
function is reflected on the original
object so you can see here def function
of l l of 0 equals 3 l equals one two
three four function l print l and you're
gonna get three two three four because
we passed l in there so it's a pointer
here we have def function l l equals
three two three four l equals one two
three four function of l print l because
in this function i have assigned instead
of operating on a piece of l the list
i've consigned a whole new value to that
list or l it then at that point will
create a new object so if i make changes
to the object it's going to change it in
the outside the definition if i use a
variable and i cited a completely new
value like l equals three two three four
that will not show up when you're
outside the function number eight how
would you generate random numbers in
python to generate random numbers in
python you must first import the random
module the random function generates a
random float value between zero and one
the random range function generates a
random number within a given range and
you can see here one is the lower end
tens the upper end and step two so it
would be one three five and so on as far
as the options in the random generation
number nine what does the double forward
slash operator do in python the forward
slash operator performs division and
returns the quotient in float for
example 5 over 2 returns 2.5 to do a
double forward slash operator on the
other hand returns the quotient an
integer for example 5 double slash
returns 2. 5 divided by 2 and you drop
the 0.5 number ten what does the is
operator do the is operator compares the
id of the two objects and you can see in
here where list one equals brackets
round one two three list one equals list
two equals true and you have the double
equals in python of course and you can
do list 1 is list 2 where list 2 equals
1 2 3 is false list 2 is not the
brackets 1 2 3. it equals it but it's
not the brackets and if we do list 3
equals list one then list one is list
three equals true number eleven what is
the purpose of pass statement the pass
statement is used when there's a
syntactic but not an operational
requirement for example the program
below prints a string ignoring the
spaces and so here we have variable
equals simply learn we've added two
spaces in it for i and variable so it
goes through each eye if i equals space
do nothing else print i and then we'll
have the end equals bracket bracket and
they'll print out simply learn now of
course you would probably write this if
i does not equal blank space print but
this would be another way you could do
that if you need a placeholder for that
first logical set or that first area you
can also do a function like this you
could do function whatever your def
function name brackets colon pass so it
goes into the function and does nothing
but it's a placeholder number 12 how
will you check all the characters in a
string are alphanumeric python has an
inbuilt method is all number which
returns true if all characters in the
string are alphanumeric and so you can
see here abcd123
is all number output equals true and the
second line a b c d the at symbol 1 2 3
the pound symbol is all nume output
equals false so really you just want to
know about is all new all numerical
alpha numerical number 12 how will you
check if all characters in a string are
alphanumeric so here we go
if you know is all number which returns
that the characters in the string are
alphanumeric one can also use regex
instead and so we have boolean rematch
what's important about this is to note
your capital a dash to capital z a lower
cost
to z 0 to 9 means that that array
includes all of those the way they have
it written out plus a dollar sign and
then we have what we're comparing it to
the string we're comparing to the
abcd123 and so we can do an re.match and
if it matches if all these things if all
the different entities in that array
matches the first one we get an output
true and if not an output false number
13 how will you merge elements in a
sequence
sequence there are three types of
sequences in python there's lists tuples
and strings python acoustics makes this
easy if we have a list one and list two
and list one is uh square brackets one
comma two comma three list two is four
five and six we can simply do list one
plus list two and our output is one two
three four five six if we have tuples
your tuple is the curved brackets
designates it and again just add them
together same thing with strings we have
simply learn s1 plus s2 equals simply
learn number 14 how will you remove all
leading white space in a string python
provides the inbuilt function l strip to
remove all leading access from a string
and you can see here spacebase base
python.l strip leading strip python and
you can also do strip which release
leading and ending of course there's
also the ending set number 15 how will
you replace all occurrences of a stub
string with a new string the replace
function can be used with strings for
replacing a substring with a given
string syntax string dot replace old
comma new come account replace returns a
new string without modifying the
original string hey john how are you
john question mark replace john with
capital j-o-h-n one and then you can see
right here hey john how are you and
since we designated with the one just
says we're only going to replace one of
these 16 what is the difference between
dell and remove brackets on lists dell
for delete dell removes all elements of
a list within a given range syntax dell
list start to end remove remove brackets
removes the first occurrence of a
particular character syntax list remove
element and we see a nice example over
here if we delete the list one to three
it will delete the first in this case b
one two it doesn't do three remember
that one two so we'll delete b and c and
you end up with a d where if we do
remove b from the list and we have an a
b b d it's only gonna remove the first b
number seventeen how to display the
contents of text file in reverse order
open the file using the open function
store the contents of the file into a
list reverse the contents of the list
run a for loop to iterate through the
list
number 18 differential between append
and extend append adds an element to the
end of the list you can see right here
we have a list one two three four and we
append four we end up with an output one
two three four and extend adds an
element from an interval to the end of
the list and we have here list equals
one two three list dot extend four five
six output is one two three four five
six so if you wanna append an array to
the end of another array you want to use
the extend number 19 what's the output
of the below code justify your answer
this is a great interview question
because these are the kind of things
that come up when you're proofing code
def add to list value and list so we
have value in and a list in or list
equals an empty in this case an empty
list list data pin value return list
list one equals add to list one list two
equals add to list one two three empty
bracket
list three equals add to list a and then
we want to print them list one equals
and you can see the formatting we have
our placeholder list one list two and
list three so when it prints list one we
get one comma a and what you want to
notice here is that list 1 and list 3
are equal why are they equal well when
we passed the information to the add to
list we passed value without passing the
list equals brackets without passing a
second value what this means is that
list as we have it if you don't have a
list it'll start off with empty list
which we append the one to the second
one list two we appended a value to an
empty list so it's only going to be one
two three it doesn't matter what the
list was before we've already assigned
an empty list and then list three here's
the tricky one we're adding a to the
list but because we didn't designate the
list list is a shared value in other
words it doesn't reset it and we end up
with list one equals list three one
comma a default this is created only
once during the function and not during
its call number 20 what is the
difference between a list and a tuple
lists are mutable while tuples are
immutable and you can see an example
down here where i have list equals one
two three square brackets denoted it's a
list list of two equals four and i
printed out i now have one two four if i
do the same thing with the tuple i get
an error because you can't change the
tuple one two three into one two four
you have to completely reassign tuple to
a new value what is doc string in python
dot strings are used in providing
documentation to various python modules
classes functions and methods and so you
can see here we have def for a function
add a b and this is a doc string we have
the triple brackets on there you can add
carriage return in that so that you can
go multiple lines and it says this
function adds two numbers and then sum a
b return sum and so we have down here
two different ways of accessing this
function output accessing docstring
method one this function adds two
numbers accessing docstring method two
help on function add in model main this
function adds two numbers and so you can
see the code down here has two very
different in values the second one is
basically a help menu there's our help
menu number 22 how do you use print
without the new line the solution to
this depends on the python version you
are using in python version 2 you can do
print hi and then you add a comma
afterwards print how are you and you
have hi how are you in version three
print hi comma end equals and it'll add
a space on the end there you can put
different characters in there but you
just want to put a space to put a space
on the end print how are you and now we
get hi how are you number 23 how do you
use the split function in python the
split function splits a string into a
number of strings based on a specific
delimiter so we have string split
delimiter comma max the maximum number
of splits the character based on which
the string is to split by default is
space so here we have an example we have
a variable red blue green orange and we
want to split it by commas and we only
want to do the first two so if we print
the list now you'll find it has red blue
and only spread it split it the first
two times and it gets to the third one
and just groups them all together green
and orange if you leave the two off
you'll split the whole thing number 24
is python object oriented or functional
programming python follows object
oriented paradigm and you should really
know in depth what they mean by
object-oriented paradigm if you're doing
any interview for scripting languages
python allows the creation of objects
and is manipulation through specific
methods it supports most of the features
of oops which has inheritance on a
polymorphism so you have an object and
you can inherit all the traits of that
object and then add new traits in or
alter some of those traits that's what
object oriented means python follows
functional programming paradigm
functions may be used as first class
object python supports lambda functions
which are characteristic of functional
paradigm so you can set a variable to a
function as opposed to setting it to an
object number 25 write a function
prototype that takes variable number of
arguments here we have def function name
list so we could have in this case
whatever the list is def function the
asterisk denotes so we're going to take
multiple arguments of a variable and we
can do for i and var print i so if you
send function of one you'll end up with
a one function one two five six i'll
actually print those out one at a time
the first one just prints out a one
because it only sent one variable the
second one will print one another line
twenty five and the line six number
twenty six what is asterisks args and
asterix korgs args used in function
prototype to accept varying number of
arguments it's an iterable object def
function arcs and you can imagine it's
just a basic list so if i send add the
numbers a comma b or a comma b comma c
it doesn't really matter it will have
that number of objects in it whatever i
send to it and there's other uses for it
but that's very basic korg's i can
actually tell it what i want to send so
using a function prototype and to accept
varying number of keyworded arguments
it's in both are iterable objects so you
can go through them one at a time and
the def function chords you can now set
like color equals red units equal to so
you'll see that especially in machine
learning there's a lot of like they'll
have inline equals true that kind of
thing number 27 in python functions are
first class objects what do you
understand from this
this means i could return a function
from another function i could create a
function and treat it just like an
object i can assign it to a variable i
can pass them as arguments to other
functions number 28 what is the output
of print name underscore underscore name
and justify your answer the double
underscore name double underscore is a
special variable that holds the name of
the current module program execution
starts from main or a code with zero
indentation thus double underscore name
double underscore name has a value
double underscore main double underscore
in the above case if the file is
imported from another module then double
underscore name underscore double
underscore holds the name of this module
number 29 what is a numpy array and we
briefly touched numpy array compared to
a list early in processing speed now
let's go ahead and look at some of the
more specifics a numpy array is a grid
of values all of the same type so if
they're either all float all integer all
string and is indexed by a tuple of
non-negative integers the number of
dimensions is the rank of the array and
the shape of an array is a tuple of
integers giving the size of the ray
along each dimension number 30 what is
the difference between matrices and
arrays a matrix comes from linear
algebra and is a two-dimensional
representation of data it comes with a
powerful set of mathematical operations
that allow you to manipulate the data in
interesting ways now arrays an array is
a sequence of objects of similar data
type an array within another array forms
a matrix like we said here
two-dimensional so if you have an array
of three by four that would be a matrix
number 31 how to get indexes of n
maximum values in a numpy array of
course the first thing to do is to
import your numpy as np you don't
necessarily have to use mp but that is
the most standard use of numpy we create
our array equals an np.array of one two
three four five and then if we want to
get our indexes of n at maximum values
in a numpy array we can do
one way to do it is to take our array
sort it then do minus in colon that
means we're going to do once you've
sorted it you can do minus in n would
equal then the number of entities so
it's not the actual letter n colon and
really this is about understanding this
notation that we can sort it so it goes
from lowest to biggest then we can get
the top values for n indexes and then we
have our final set of brackets with the
minus one on there number 32 how would
you obtain the resulting set from the
train set and the test set from below
and let's go ahead and look at the two
different variables we have train set
equals an array of one two three test
set equals a numpy of ray of arrays we
have 0 1 2 1 2 3. what's important here
is that one it's a numpy so that leaves
a out and then we're stuck with three
other options and i'm going to say the d
is out none of these and let's look at
np.concatenate
versus
np.vstack concatenate would put one set
after the other so you would end up with
probably give you an error because one
set is one two three and then we're
going to concatenate array 0 1 2 and 1
array 1 2 3 the array of arrays onto the
end of that what we really want to do is
stack and by the way you can actually
switch there's variables you can put
into concatenate obviously they can
change this so you could use the
concatenate with a lot of fudging around
but really we're looking for is v stack
v stands for vertical versus the hdac
which is horizontal and if we do a v
stack we can simply do train set comma
test set and stack them together and so
we have c resulting set equals np.v
stack train stack test set both option a
and b would do horizontal stacking but
we would like to have the vertical
stacking option she does this again you
could add the axes in and use the
concatenate to stack it the correct way
number 33 how would you import a
decision tree classifier in sk learn we
have
sklearn.decision tree import decision
tree classifier from sklearn ensemble
import decision tree classifier and we
look at these and they're all import
decision tree classifier that actually
last part happens to be correct and it's
really just a vocabulary knowing where
is the decision tree classifier stored
what module is that a part of and it is
of course part of the sklearn.tree
number c number 34. you have uploaded
the data set in csv format on google
spreadsheet and shared it publicly how
can you access this in python what's
important here is to know that we can
read stuff with pandas so we don't show
it here but you can there's actually a
number of ways to do this what's
important here is to know a couple
things one we have our link generated
from the google docs and spreadsheets
and then we can do a string i o dot
string i o request get link dot content
so there's our source and then finally
we know that pandas can read a csv
there's obviously many ways to read a
csv but data equals pd.read underscore
csv source number 35 what is the
difference between the two data series
given below below we have df name and df
location colon comma brackets around
asterisks around name comma where and
then we have df equals pd data frame
aabb xxuu comma 21 165033
columns equal name and age so let's take
a look and see what they're looking at
we have just glancing at the questions
they want to know is it the original
data frame or is it the copy of the data
frame and you can see here that one is
view of the original data frame and two
is a copy of the original data frame two
is a view of the original data frame and
one is a copy of the original data frame
both are copies both are views and if
you're working with pandas you know that
unless you specifically in certain
things tell it to do it in line and a
lot of functions don't allow you that
you're always taking a slice and it is
always a copy so c both are copies of
the original data frame number 36 you
get the following error while trying to
read a file temp dot csv using pandas
which of the following could correct it
so here's our error trace back most
recent call last file input line 1 and
module unicode encode error ascii codex
can't encode character oh i hate it when
that one comes up and we have four
different entries we'll go ahead and
just pretend the d doesn't exist unless
we really can't fit it into one of the
other answers and the first one is pd
read csv has our file compression equals
gzip well gzip is just an unzipping and
you actually get a zip error on there
the second one is dialect equals string
again not an encoding or coding setup
and then we have encoding equals utf-8
well that would be the encoding error
switching it from the character code
there's utf-8 there is unicode that's
the most common two that goes between so
really this is about understanding the
difference between a utf-8 coding and a
unicode and the error that comes up
quite regularly with that number c
encoding should be utf-8 number 37 how
to set a line with any plot given below
so looking at this we have import
matplot library pi plot as plt and you
should know your way around this how to
do a plot in there plt.plot plt.plot1234
plot equals show and so this is a little
bit of a vocabulary test the vocabulary
is it width equals three line width
equals three lw equals three or
something else and the vocabulary word
that we're looking for is lw equals
three which stands for line width in pi
plot library pi plot number 38 how would
you reset the index of a data frame to a
given list so this is a vocabulary
challenge and understanding what
re-indexing is re-indexing as we have
the different values here we have the
first one which is reset the index well
we're not really resetting the index
re-index number b means we are double
checking our indexes to the column and
to the main index and so the values
match correctly where reindex like now
brings in a new index outside of our
data frame to a given list so this is
coming from external and thus the
vocabulary word like is our keyword that
is external and we have a data friend to
a given list number 39 how can you copy
objects in python the functions used to
copy objects in python we have copy copy
for shallow copying and copy deep
copying for deep copy number 40 what is
the difference between range and x range
functions in python well this is a good
one we have matrixes and arrays with a
matrix the range returns a python list
object x range returns an x range object
and with arrays an x-ray returns an
x-range object x range creates values as
you need them through yielding the key
here is that x range returns the values
as you need them so it actually
processes it post like if you have for x
or for a variable in x range it is
processing them as you need them zero to
nine it doesn't create an array zero to
nine it just hands you zero then one two
three four one at a time number 41 how
can you check whether a panda's data
frame is empty or not the tribute
df.empty is used to check whether a
panda's data frame is empty or not and
so you can simply create a we have down
here importer pandas is pd we create our
panda's data frame equal to an empty
array and is df dot empty comes out as
true one of the catches you got to
remember with these vocabularies is with
empty along with some other pandas set
up whether you need the brackets or not
at the end number 42 write the code to
sort an array in numpy by the n minus
one column this can be achieved using
arg sort function let's take an array x
then to sort the n minus one column the
code will be x to
x to colon n minus two dot args sort so
let's see what that code looks like we
import numpy as np we'll create our
array
our numpy array which is uh one two
three zero five two two three four so we
have three different entities with three
different columns in there and we go x
of x and so we take x of
all the rows
first entity well in this case it's
actually the second one because it's
zero one two dot arg sort so that would
be the second entity or minus two would
also be the same you could also do
instead of one you could also do minus
two there instead of the one arg sort
and then we get an output of the array
one two three zero five two two three
four number 43 how to create a series
from a list numpy array and dictionary
so we'll go ahead and input import our
numpy our pandas and have my list and
you can see here we have my list equals
list of a b c d e f g over all the way
through so my list now makes a list of
that for
array we have np.a range to 26 my
dictionary will create a dictionary with
a zip my list my arguments so i'll just
use the numpy array we just created with
my array to go into
the dictionary and the solution is
simple with the
pd.series my list pd.series myarray
pd.seriesmydictionary so it's all about
knowing the dot capital s-e-r-i-e-s
don't forget that capitalization number
44 how to get the items not common to
both series a and series b and you can
see here we have instead of series a and
b we have series one and two and we have
one two three four five four five six
seven eight the solution is we take a
panda series we have a series u equals a
panda series np union one dimension
series one series two so we can now make
a union of them we now have series one
panda series with an intersection and
then we can remove one from the other
series u is series u dot is in series
one so if the union is not in the
intersection then you know it's a unique
value a little bit of logic going on
there playing with three different terms
to get the answer we want 45 how to keep
only the top two most frequent values as
it is and replace everything else as
other in a series so again we're working
with pandas because if we're talking
series and data frames that means we're
working with pandas so we're going to
import pandas as pd we'll go ahead and
create our panda series we're going to
do that by creating a numpy random
random state 100 so 100 in the numpy one
and then we have our panda series you
can see here we're a random integer
numpy random to a random integer 1 comma
5 by 12. and so the solution for this is
we go ahead and we've created a pd dot
remember the capital s series solution
we're going to print the top two
frequencies and that is our series dot
value counts and then we take series
values count dot index of up to two so
we're going to take everything up to two
and then we'll do the series is in so if
it's not in the first two then it's
going to equal other and this would be
something you'd want to write down on
paper if you're if it looks confusing
take a moment pause the video
write this down and see if you can
figure out how the logic came together
and try to throw yourself a couple other
little logic puzzles like this number 46
how to find the positions of numbers
that are multiples of 3 from a series
and in here we're actually going to use
a numpy to solve it the first part
series lets you know it's going to be a
panda series and if we come down here we
have
np.arghware so this is a vocabulary
question series with remember the
percentile 3 is a remainder so if the
remainder equals 0 then we're going to
generate that string where the object
divided by 3 equals 0 has no remainder
so then we know it's a multiple of three
number 47 how to compute the euclidean
distance between two series and this
one's really cool because we have our
panda series p and q and what i like
about this one is they give us two
solutions you can go with and really you
should kind of know both the first one
would be yes you know what the euclidean
distance is and that is we can take the
first series minus the second series
squared and then sum them up and then we
do the square root which is the same as
taking the power to 0.5 doing the power
to 0.5 is easier than doing the square
root so a lot of times you'll see that
as a switch but you could have also done
the square root and used the math in
there so there's solution one you should
know your euclidean distance and then
solution two is the numpy solution so we
have np dot
lin-alg dot norm that's how we're gonna
compute our euclidean distance
p minus q very elegant and very
straightforward and easy to compute
number 48 how to reverse the rows of
data frame so here we have our data
frame we're going to create a numpy
array by 25 reshape it five minus one
and this creates a 25 by 25 data frame
and so our solution is to do the dfi
location and this is just understanding
how steps work the steps you have your
colon colon minus 1 so we're taking all
the rows all the columns minus one so
we're stepping minus one going the
reverse direction and then we're just
going to use across all the different
columns on there let me say that again
the first colon is going to be your row
starting row stopping row step minus one
that's all this is about is that step
minus one comma and then all the columns
forty-nine if you split your data into
train test splits is it possible to over
fit your model and the answer is yes is
definitely possible one common beginner
mistake is retuning a model or training
new models with different parameters
after seeing his performance on the test
set my favorite example of this is you
have your script put together and you
keep hitting the re-run button until you
get the answer you want not taking the
answer it first gave you or running it
over an array recording all the answers
to see how they vary number 50 which
python library is built on top of map
matplot library and pandas
to ease data plotting the answer this is
seaborn seaborn is a data visualization
library in python that provides a high
level interface for drawing statistical
information informative graphs so thank
you all for watching this session on
python developer full course i hope this
video was useful and informative if you
have any questions then please feel free
to put them in the comments section our
team will help you solve your queries
stay safe and keep learning
you